foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
together
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
a storm is brewing you're never going to
beat hikarados on game not in these
positions within the Tempest the best
have come to test their skills and brave
the storm
oh we missed it oh yeah oh my goodness
the wheels the wheels have come out that
could be the magic for some this is
familiar ground oh my goodness 98 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this this insane oh
look at
look at the electric that is
dagger the moves will be fast oh my God
the 97
tricked at the end the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
we welcome you back to what surely will
be another scintillating speed Chess
Championship matchup between levonne
ronian and Dimitri andrekin I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me my
good friend my co-commentator here at
Grandmaster Daniel naroditski donea
we've had a fun first three matches you
excited for number four
good afternoon Robert hello everybody I
am super excited for number four the
matchups this year are especially epic I
have been on the edge of my seat for
every match and I'm sure nothing is
going to change today
oh certainly not because there is so
much at stake in each and every SCC
match it's had in illustrious history
and we're just getting started here in
2022 because in this first round where
we are now 16 players started only a few
have been eliminated two thousand
dollars goes to the winner with another
split of the two thousand dollars based
on wood percentage and of course they
really just want to go to the
quarterfinal So Daniel I mean it's
always fun to see them duke it out for
the prize fund but it's really the glory
that they're after it is the glory and
that's the amazing thing about the SEC
it's the prestige that this uh
tournament has built up through every
year that it's been held to the point
where you want to be the one to say that
you won the SEC over Magnus Carlson
Hikaru Nakamura and the other
mouth-watering names on our general
bracket
for sure and they're only three names
that cannot claim this year's uh
speeches Championship because they've
been eliminated we'll see who is the
fourth to be eliminated today but
Fabiano caruana started things off with
a win over Arjun Eric garci surprising
some people in that matchup dingley Wren
didn't want a close matchup against
Alexander grishook the qualifier who is
a superstar in his own right and then
Maxime vascher lagrav he was upset about
giving that candidates to Jana palmushi
in 2020 2021 he gets a little bit of
Revenge by kind of demolishing him in
the bullet section to win 19 and a half
11 half but Dania today is all about
Lavon aronian and Dimitri on draken
levonne aronian he leads their Blitz
head head but they haven't played too
many games against one another which is
kind of interesting because they're more
or less from the same generation and
it's not that their last Blitz meeting
with 12 years ago 2010 feels like a
different Millennium so it's just
amazing to see them reconnect again
Dimitri on Drake and I mean he really
needs no introduction anymore he has
made such a name for himself especially
in the realm of online chess with his
performances in the RCC and just with
his General Blitz and rapid play
anywhere he plays I mean he's been
ridiculously consistent he's a nightmare
matchup for anybody
yeah he was the rapid Chess Championship
finalist losing to Jana Pomchi he made
into the cgc top eight where he played
from Serbia so he is just a force to be
reckoned with but so is Levon aronian
and the community got involved and they
were trying to predict this eight nine
matchup where LeBron is a slightly
higher scene and he gets the nod from
the crowd Dania 55 to 45 which is kind
of interesting because Dmitry and draken
undoubtedly the more experienced player
again within the framework of online
chess but Lavon aronian a higher rated
player definitely the sort of OTB
favorite if you think about classical
chess but 55-45 I think that's pretty
accurate I could make a compelling case
for either player to win this match
well you mentioned experience so let's
dive right into the insights between
these two because Dimitri on draken is
just about as experienced as a player
can get that's not named Hikaru Nakamura
on draken has played so many Blitz Games
we see right here
3553 to a whopping a tiny disparity
190 from levonne Ronin so it is quite
shocking that Levant really does not
play
outside of the SEC yeah it's like when
you look at some players as game's
history you see three plus one three
plus one you just know they play title
Tuesdays with Lavon all you see is five
plus one three plus one and one plus one
because you know he just plays the SEC
every year but obviously lavon's played
in many world Blitz and Rapid
championships he's played in Rapid and
Blitz events in St Louis so it's not
like he doesn't play Blitz at all and he
actually plays a pretty darn well he
moves relatively fast in classical chess
as well so he compensates for his lack
of online experience with his General
Blitz Mastery but no question that
Dimitri is more experienced player as
the numbers show
he certainly is and let's remind
everybody of the format the time
controls that will be played today we
start with five minute plus one second
increment and then we get down to the
three plus one and find the one plus one
and of course in this knockout format
you lose your go home if things are tied
we get Armageddon that's exciting for
all stressful for the players but great
for the fans so I think that this match
could go down to the wire with two very
different styles but an evenly matched
set of opponents here yeah and I I'm
really really excited to see how they're
going to handle these different time
controls I think for Lavon he needs to
try to make that push in the 90 minutes
that we have of five plus one I think
that's where he needs to stake his claim
because we've got 60 Minutes of three
plus one and then the 30 minutes of
bullet is where I really think Dimitri
on draken can try to make that push so
if Dimitri can keep that match close
throughout until the bullet I think he's
gonna have a pretty good shot and
obviously we'll get a four game
tiebreaker in the event of a tie but as
I always say We'll across that bridge if
we get there
yes and Dimitri on Drake and he probably
doesn't want to get to a tiebreaker he
would you know be content with it he is
the better player in bullets so we would
think but levana Rooney is no slouch I
think people underestimate him just
because he doesn't play that often but
we've seen him participate in bullet
chess championships he's won many
matches in the SEC I believe five
matches he's won he's been eliminated
six times so uh it's about uh you know
he wins one a year is really how it goes
for him and he would like to even up
that overall record by beating Dimitri
on Drake he also has an epic background
the brick wall which uh we're about to
see but I'll put that aside for now I
just wanted to say uh that there was
another interesting Insight Lavon does
lose a lot of games by time and I really
think that one of the key story lines
that we're gonna have to watch
throughout this match is whether Levon
is going to be able to handle himself in
time scrambles because that's where your
lack of online experience can really
hurt you it's when you get down to five
seconds ten seconds yes there's a one
second increment but it's going to be
crucial for Lavon not to panic when he
gets let's say below 30 seconds
I agree especially because Dimitri is
such a solid player I mentioned that
they have different styles down yet
Lavon he is as creative as creative gets
he's a maestro in the openings he had
that exchange sacrifice to beat Magnus
Carlson many years ago at this point but
I don't remember when like A3 Bishop
takes away Rook takes A3 and they
demolished Magnus on the king side so I
feel like when you think of Lavon you
think of just all sorts of masterpieces
including a loss to official when Vichy
had a masterpiece himself but for
Dimitri on draken I think of solid hard
to take down he bends but he does not
break and I think that style could help
him in this match yeah I mean definitely
Dimitri's preference at his core is
positional chess he is a grinder he's a
very technical player I still remember
his win over Hikaru in the RCC that
incredible end game uh carpovian type of
Victory but that's not to say that
Dimitri can't handle himself tactically
he is a sicilian player and in the cgc
his match against Wesley so didn't go
his way but he had couple of very
impressive openings with the black
pieces so I'm excited to see what Dima
will bring to the table especially with
the black pieces
and let's not forget we saw him excel in
the shorter time controls at least
there's stretches against Fabiano
caruana but we are off cgc that I was
referencing E4 by Levon of ronin and
can't get a sicilian there we go and
Dimitri plays a bunch of different
Sicilian variations but he likes the
taimanov let's see if that is indeed
going to be his choice is the queen
going to come out okay Asics kind of a
version of the taimanov
right and Knight F6 played by him so
this allows white to capture on C6 and
play E5 which is not available in some
other variations but I don't think
that's what Lavon writes here uh wants
here I should say and you know what's
interesting Donna is Lavon for a while
he played a bunch of D4 now he plays E4
and D4 of course these top players play
with two hands so they say uh but he's
playing aggressive out the gates
yeah nice use of uh playing with two
hands I like it and F4 by Levon a very
ambitious variation this move has gotten
popular in a lot of different Sicilian
systems recently you can see Dimitri
putting immediate pressure on the E4
Pawn by getting his dark scored Bishop
out and pinning the Knight
yes and you know by the way chat thought
that dimitro draken would take this time
Patrol he plays E5 showing that he has
no fear and that does technically
sacrifice a pawn with Knight takes C6
and then F takes E5 but that's not a
healthy Pawn structure for what you are
going to lose that pawn right back and
it actually should be a good transition
for andrekid yeah and moreover after d
takes C6 it opens up the possibility of
Knight F6 to G4 and that is a very
dangerous move to face if you haven't
castled yet which is why we see Lavon
closing down the diagonal for the bishop
with F5 and Paving the way uh for a lot
more safety once he castles kingside
there are some crazy tactics here
revolving our Knight takes E4 because
White Knight on C3 will be captured
after Bishop takes E4 if we can show
this quickly energy yeah Queen H4 check
so I wonder what Levant has up his
sleeve I don't think he just blundered
upon the center it could be ideas with
queen to G4 and the mix going after G7
yeah especially here I think would be a
great opportunity to throw in Queen G4 I
actually think that is his idea and
black can help himself to another Pawn
but you're gonna have to wave goodbye to
your entire King side and your king uh
shortly thereafter with Bishop H6 and
queen takes C5 coming in this is out of
the question good call by you I don't
think Dimitri is going down this hole
this rabbit hole but what if he starts
with Knight takes he plays H5 so okay
he's going for Knight G4 just and most
importantly taking away the G4 Square so
if you think the threat is Knight G4 and
you play H3 to deal with that then you
actually fall victim to Knight takes E4
so clever move by andrekin oh because it
covers the G4 Square I thought his idea
was more positional to play H4 and
create the G3 Outpost for himself but
you're right it's to play Knight takes
C4 and this kind of misdirection it
makes it so easy to blunder because you
think it's it's one idea and then
there's actually a hidden idea under the
surface Queen D2 is lavon's choice so he
allows Knight G4 but Knight G4 doesn't
look all that dangerous it can be met
with Bishop G5 you could even give your
dark Squad Bishop away not the end of
the world although the dark squares are
quite important in these types of
positions
no they are so you don't want to give up
that Bishop I like your this point just
move the bishop away could you go back
to G1 yeah if you wanted to and then
Castle Queen side and continue uh with
your development so here's a big moment
for Andrea I'm still trying to make
Knight takes E4 work because there could
be a knight takes E4 Bishop takes C3
Queen H4 check but you need to be a
million percent sure that otherwise you
might just lose the game if you're on
draken yeah it's incredibly committal
and it's it's played on the board and I
take C4 first so he's gonna follow up
with Bishop takes E3 using the pin let's
see what Lavon can bring to the table in
response big moment
and Levant takes so I wonder if he
missed it or he had just calculated a
little more deeply because right now
there's the intermed so Bishop takes C6
check so you're going to lose the bishop
of money for anyway you might as well
grab that pawn ruin Black's Queen Side
Pawn structure get obstacle Bishops and
then it's anybody's game Bishop takes C6
a brilliant little in-between move and
after Queen takes you through you're
also hitting C6 as well as E5 that seems
to be the only Pap forward I can't make
Queen takes C3 work after Queen H4 Queen
takes C4 Robert I think black gets away
with it and might even win a second Pawn
on F5
and that's the good thing about having a
five minute start with that one second
increment because Levant can sit and
calculate right now I believe he will go
for Bishop takes C6 check everything
else looks bad for white whereas Bishop
C6 it's a position with opposite colored
Bishops a lot of life left it's not like
an end game where it's just equal
nothing of that sort I actually like
White's chances if he does in fact throw
in that move the only remotely feasible
alternative I was gonna say is BC and
then Queen to F2 and Castle's King side
to keep the f-pawn secure I'm still
shocked he goes for this he's trying to
play against this bishop on CND he's
saying hey you can't really develop your
queen side that easily I'm gonna go rook
ae1 and I'm also gonna play against this
highly vulnerable Queen on e4 here's
that creativity we talk about
and if you think about you're going to
Castle kingside for black watch out for
F6 to break open your king and go into
those dark squares so I love it you know
I was just saying that Lavon should be
happy that the game start with five
minutes if this were a bullet game I
feel like black would lose in three
turns you're not casually anytime soon
even castling Queen side seems out of
the question because Bishop D7 and if
you get your king over there the dark
squares are too weak so I think from a
practical point of view Donya a great
choice from Lavon yeah the key word
there being practical I would totally
ignore the eval bar I don't care this is
where lavon's creativity manifests
itself it's in these unconventional
decisions that pose serious practical
problems dude Deema already down to two
minutes on his clock he's going to be
playing a bullet game soon enough
and there's only one fully open file
it's the D file but guess what Bishop B6
is going to sit there and no Rook is
getting the D5 for black and white can
take the default so I actually don't
really see how black is going to deal
with these threats like Bishop B6 Rook a
to D1 start doubling your Rooks on the D
file potentially the one problem is the
F5 Pawn so if black can play H4 at some
moment and Rook H5 you may win a second
pawn and that's too much to deal with
yeah once you lose that pawn the
floodgates open the bishop gets out
that's the downside of levon's play it's
very high risk you're gonna have to show
something in the next few moves or your
initiative Fizzles out you're not just
going to be much worse you might just
flat out be lost if you're down two
Pawns
why you know this is a critical moment
and Levant senses that that's why he's
taking his time he has a slight lead he
did pre-move a few turns in a row at
least it felt like that when he decided
to Queen F2 castles King side but he
goes Rook E1 first just shoeing that
Queen away from the E4 Square it's
happily goes to C4 you often want to
plant your pieces in front of double
isolated pawns so why not take over the
C4 score so Dania do you believe in
levon's plan here or is Dimitri handling
this well I did two moves ago I'm not
sure I do anymore I actually don't see
how Lavon can actually infiltrate uh
storm the barricades here despite the
outward passive appearance of Black's
position and this move H3 I think is a
clear indicator that Lavon is kind of
switching to defensive mode
yeah H3 kind of out of nowhere I don't
really see it why exactly
maybe he wants an eventual G4 or
something I I just don't see why that
move was necessary and H4 played by
Dimitri not only is that a strategically
good decision but Rook H5 becomes a
renewed threat it's a huge threat again
you can't afford to lose F5 if you're
Lavon and it's too late to switch to the
D file I think you can try Rook D1 but
after Rook H5 Bishop B6 black gets the
bishop out in time and guess what the
king doesn't have to Castle it can stay
in the center but you can also castle
kingside if you're feeling unsafe Queen
F3 to stop Rook H5 by Lavon
but now we see the downside any single
Pawn push leaves the control of that
square was previously covering so G4 was
under blacks control now if Black Goes
Pawn gobbling with Queen takes A2 or
queen C3 that White Queen will slide to
G4 so you can be very very careful here
you don't want to abandon your king if
you're on draken and Bishop D7 a
flexible move by Dimitri is he preparing
to Castle Queen side well maybe he
doesn't even know he wants to keep him
on guessing Lavon doesn't want to allow
the option Bishop B6 and I think he's
gonna go kingside
no he's gonna go upon grabbing
he is a hungry guy again for
Thanksgiving he is an American so
understandable but Rook D1 go to the
open file and there might even be a
queen G4 to follow he starts with queen
G4 but now black and Castle we've been
talking about that in G5 I was gonna say
look at that move
that caught me by surprise and be
honestly done it I think it's time for a
sacrifice I don't know if rookie five
works but I'm like trying to take all
the pawns I know what you mean I'm
Bishop D4 Bishop B5 but it's too slow he
goes Rook D1 he switches to the D file
of on is somehow able to weave a rather
nasty web around Black's pieces Queen
comes back to F7 Rook D6 your earlier
idea of doubling on the D file Robert
and if the bishop has to creep back to
C8 you're in trouble again
certainly are actually I don't see what
black can do the only hope I believe
black has is to play A5 A4 distract
White's pieces long enough to survive
the scheme because looking Dimitri's
clock he's done a 38 seconds Avant at
nearly a minute and Dimitri just can't
find a move with Rook fd-1 Castle he has
to Castle because Rook fd1 otherwise
would be followed by Rook d a check and
now the bishop drops back to you at
least you keep d8 protected can Levon
find a way to Target this F6 punt Bishop
d8 comes to mind here
oh as well as Bishop C5 maybe go after
the Rook I don't know he plays Bishop C5
and B6 is giving up the pawn I think he
wants queen H5 to follow and just get
off those pieces off the board let's get
rid of those Queens but then Black's
pawns just start dropping like flies A6
and C6 are isolated and the F6 Pawn is
weak so Bishop d8 right now looks very
strong Rook B8 instead Dimitri's Choice
occupying the open five the bishop can
come back to C5 maybe he wants to
continue chasing the bishop of The Rook
B5 and here's that time scramble I
talked about Robert how is Lavon going
to handle this both sides down below 30
seconds Bishop d8
the position is just too good for one I
think he's gonna handle it very well
what is blacksmith Queen G7 he finally
plays it Rook E6 he wants the second
Bishop F coming up oh
whoa what a move Bishop H5 opening up
the attack on d8 and that's not a bishop
Levon can afford to par with no that was
extremely clever and I think you could
trade on d8 make a rookie a check and
make a draw here if you're lucky I think
that's what he should do
yeah otherwise he can take on C6 but I'm
trying to count the pawns and I'm
struggling
wise decision
talked to this a few times practical
choices I think Lavon made some very
good practical choices throughout the
game here but I think that Dimitri
showed he may get in trouble at some
moment but he is not going to break and
it is a draw in game one but let's
ignore the result for a second that was
a hard-fought battle both sides of
chances
oh yeah that was great really combative
from the opening I love the choice of a
sicilian from Dimitri meeting Lavon at
the top couldn't ask for a better game
one
mm-hmm and where is game two these two
have to get a rematch going we'd love to
see more from them but I have to say
that no that's it that's all we get
I think that Lavon might not know where
the rematch button is he hasn't played
you know in a year so it has been since
the last SCC and we see Dimitri played
his D4 his beloved D4 he's always going
to be doing that and for Lavon I'm
curious what he's going for and it looks
like he's answering our question quickly
here a queen's game of decline yeah
Lavon is a shape-shifter with the black
pieces against E4 he's played the
Queen's Gambit accepted decline
grundfeld slav he's played everything
under God's blue sky and here he goes
solid and speaking of solid E3 by
Dimitri that is a very undraken-esque
variation yeah okay
I like how you put that because it's
true instead of developing the dark
score Bishop he's like no let's be calm
protect all of our pawns you know C4 is
defended well just play it slowly
um and I think Lavon is taking a page at
a Maxine vashir Le gross book and you
may think oh no wait doesn't Maxi play
the grootfeld uh he doesn't play this
line no it's because he's eating all
matched like every time I see Maxine
he has like a whole tray of food I don't
think I've seen Lavon stop eating and
drinking thus far and drinking
on drinking nice big thermos
yeah
and scratching his hair yeah he's just
trying to uh remain energized throughout
this game here and we see the bishop
kick back to B7 So Daniel the big
question is was it beneficial for white
to throw that pawn up to B5 my answer is
no because the side that controls the
pawn breaks is off on the side with the
advantage now black can play a timely A6
maybe now is that time where you can
start opening up the flank and that
could be bad news for white instead
Levon chooses C5 which was also approved
by the evaluation bar there yeah the the
question with White's play here yeah
you're grabbing space but have you
bitten off more than you can chew
lavon's doing a whole lot of chewing uh
but to Demetra and Drake and I think has
bitten off more than he can chew and he
can take on poisson but that lets the
Knight get out and then you've got that
open C file and before you know it in
the time the white takes to complete his
King side development you could get some
nasty stuff going on the queen side I
like levon's position out of the opening
here I think he might even be slightly
better
I do as well I think you can just put a
rook on C8 I don't know if you should
swap Knights on C3 first but either way
a Works coming to the open file and we
get this sort of grunfeld type of
position black has an extra Pawn on the
A and B files white has an extra Pawn in
the center so what does black want to do
you often want to trade pieces because
pawns they limit your opponent's pieces
and if you start trading well
you just don't have so many limitations
they're not fighting for the same
squares so that is why Dimitri says no
trade for you Knight to E4 but he has
not castled yet and look at this long
diagonal Rook A8 should be played just
to fill up the entire A8 to H1 diagonal
there was also a screwy tactical threat
of Knight C6 takes D4 I think opening up
the discovered attack on the C3 Knight
so I think he had to move it away for
that reason as well and is Lavon going
to carry out the classic grunfield-esque
idea Knight A5 Knight C4 could play a6b5
there isn't all that much going on in
the queen side so it ain't that easy to
prove you know to prove something
concrete let's see how Lavon handles
this the next few moves here really
important if Lavon wants to solidify his
Advantage Knight A5 is on the board
and he spent 38 seconds to play Knight
A5 which is a move that came to him
instinctively I think that he if you
swing bullet he would have played that
move in two seconds
um so I wonder what else he's
calculating I'm not criticizing him but
I'm wondering if there's some Central
squares that he's looking at maybe a
timely F7 to F5 just to boot the Knight
out of E4 but that is a committal
decision so you don't play F5 unless you
have a clear follow-up because that
weakens E6 also gives control of the E5
Square permanently to White so that's
why Lavon plays the standard Knight A5
and how are you gonna stop Knight to C4
he answers that with Queen to E2 but I
do think that both F5 and playing I was
gonna say A6 B5 but then I looked is A6
hanging
that is a spicy move Bishop takes A6 I
think he wants to trade and then close
off the queen with Knight C4
I don't know there's another drink from
that huge thermos
okay but after Knight C4 white could
play Queen B5 this at least needs to be
calculated but Dimitri says I don't want
to touch that with a 10-foot pole I'm
getting all out of the center well he
said you don't want to touch it now you
can't now you have the pawns protected
right there Knight C4 is happening
sooner than you know and I feel like the
position just looks very pleasant Rook
ac1 to fight for the C file and the C4
Square the Knight on D5 will slide back
to the newly vacated B6 square and that
night May hop to C4 or even to A4 don't
forget about this Pawn on A3 the bishop
on E7 is eyeing it from long distance
and if he ever has to leave B2 and go
back to A1 You're simply going to drop
that pawn on A3 so I like the look of
this position it reminds me of this game
I believe where karpov beat Kasparov
where he used the a file to his event
all of his pieces went to the a-file and
Knight B6 heading to A4 looks like a
problem for a dragon to deal with can't
quite remember that game off the top of
my head but when I hear karpov and a
file I think karpov unsecker from the
Olympia the famous Bishop A7 game but
that was of course a completely
different structure but Knight B6 Knight
A4 it reminds me of an octopus sort of
winding its tentacles around its prey
and Dimitri trying to put a spanner in
the works here with A4 that's a good
look and move but the eval bar sees
something wrong with it and so does
Robert Hess by the looks like I actually
was looking it up and I was correct it
was game six from the 1984 World Chamber
match where karpov won with black women
look at this what's the material two
pawns were just snagged but black is up
a rook so let's try to figure this out
maybe bishop takes A6 is available here
for Lavon and Rook C2 that's it right
Bishop A6 looks good for white because
A1 is under attack Knight C7 oh I did
not see that follow-up I'm gonna be
honest I just thought there's so many
pieces hanging with crazy pieces you
just gotta find something but now A6 is
hanging V2 is loose the queen is
overloaded to the defense and levonne
Ronin has stolen material yeah and he's
going to be up in exchange When the
Smoke Clears Dimitri could capture
either Knight he could take A6 he takes
a one now the knight's probably gonna
slip into B4 and white has a pawn for
the exchange no doubt that this is a two
result game now with the queen on B7
also experiencing problems Rook on C2 is
very strong but something was wrong with
that move night before as Dimitri
invades the center with 95 that wasn't
the refutation apparently Robert the
move was Knight to C5 slicing off the
connection between the bishop and the oh
and The Rook on C2 would have been in
big trouble had the queen then slid down
to B3 wow that is not that easy to see
because the bishop could take on C5 but
it opens up the bishop on A1 so there's
a lot to calculate there but there isn't
that much to calculate in the live
position the game will continue I'm not
saying it's over but it's clear that
black is much better so you said playing
for two results here let's bring our
Rooks to the queen side the second Rook
the rook and fake can go over to B8
right now you're not so worried about a
pin uh because of Rook B1 your knight
can slide back to A6 but the big
question is Dania what trades can black
allow you may say allow you're better
you have more material but sometimes you
trade a little bit too much and you
don't have enough pieces remaining to
win a better position and that's a great
point and an example of that if you
remove all of the pieces except one
white knight and one black Rook that's
actually probably closer to a draw than
anything else with a five on four on the
king side so it's absolutely not a given
that you just want to remove pieces from
the board especially given how nicely
Black's pieces are coordinated there's a
back rank uh Checkmate threat with Rook
C1 the Knight could drop back to D3 you
could make some lufts with G3 or G4 I
mean this is such a hard position to
defend with a minute on the clock
it is but if I trust a player to be able
to hold this despite the worst position
it is Dimitri on Drake but he looks a
little frustrated right he's got his
head in his hand and obviously no player
would want this position with the white
pieces but the match has not gone his
way thus far it really does seem in just
the first two games Levon has been in
control and that is not what you want to
feel in these long matches you want to
feel like even if you lose the game you
still have chances in this game right
now I feel like levana has just been
better with black from the first few
moves he most certainly has he's been
calling the shots his creative ideas
have been hating the Target and you can
see a pair of Rooks has disappeared from
the board I like the way Dimitri is
handling this so far F6 by Levon a move
that you mentioned a while ago
okay Knight back to D3 Dimitri can try
to Target that E6 spawn the king can
just slide up to F7 and protect it
and right now just there's nothing to
attack black is up material but look at
the pawn structure F2 is protecting the
entire chain F2 is ultra well defended
thanks a knight on e4 and the Knight on
D3 so I think that's why Lavon is
pushing his pawns H5 here bring the king
up to G6 slow play will probably create
some problems you don't want to rush it
you don't want to make a move like F5
and then create a problem in your own
position the E5 Square the E6 Pawn so I
think that Lavon is all about timing
right now
yeah and you just need to keep your eyes
open because oftentimes in such
positions it's so easy to blunder a
minor piece a skewer a pen a fork
something like that so Lavon will have
to stay awake to these opportunities he
closes down the king side with H4 very
instructive move creating this weakness
of H3 and you might say what do you mean
this Pawn is unattackable but again it's
all about the long run maybe in some
alternate reality that Rook lands on H1
so you want to create the preconditions
for a later win E4 by Dimitri very
committal move night before even is a
possibility here
the circulation cut off between the
bishop and the Knight on D2 so Knight
takes before Rook takes D2 and now you
regret the fact that you played E4 if
the pawn were on E3 Donya I think we
could agree uh pretty much gonna be a
draw but now white pawns stick out and
this is what Lavon Roy is demonstrating
a master class and there's a moment
where he went H5 to H4 rather than
trading that pawn on H3 is a long-term
weakness so the white king will have to
continue to stay near it with Kingdom G2
eventually and that means the E4 Pawn is
going to be loose and the King needs to
keep an eye on H3 at the same time
So the plan consequently is to push the
white king back to G2 and in timely
fashion not missing any Forks to
infiltrate with black skin let's say to
E5 or to F4 also don't forget about the
idea in some positions of sacking The
Rook for the night and getting a winning
Pawn end game due to your better King
placement
and look at this King G2 looks kind of
fourth King E7 no Forks available for
that white knight but don't go King D6
too soon because that Knight C4 check
will happen so as long as Levon can
avoid falling for a fork and look at
this he goes to EA just to avoid any
checks whatsoever taking the back road
is Lavon aronian but that Knight on E3
so well placed there's also Knight F5
that you need to watch for don't allow
the setup Knight on F5 Pawn on D6
because that could be a fortress this is
hard to win walking on hot coals here is
Lavon aronian no King D6 now
he's gonna keep this Rook away but now
D6 is happening but you might get into
zuke's wrong at some point that's what I
think oh Rook at five
can he get he does it and he wins good
call and he wins and that's exactly yeah
that's what I mentioned an F4 might be a
chance here but with two extra pawns
there's no way you can hold that no and
levana rolls over scoop up F5 and scoop
up the first win of this match he is
gonna just go to F4 with his King he'll
play F5 and the King will be forced away
from F2 and the opposition but no this
is not a theoretical draw folks no no no
no no no no no no
no more opposition for you
That's All She Wrote what a win by
lavon's surgical Precision in the end
game how did he I mean that was so
smooth
uh you might call him a beast I mean he
played a great game from start to finish
he had the advantage the entire way and
he never let it go it wasn't there was
not a single moment except for me no
Knight C5 move that you mentioned that
was the only time where Dimitri had the
evaluation go somewhat near equality but
that was a hard move to play and once he
missed it he had no shot
but to do that in a Blitz game I mean in
a classical game that's kind of what you
expect from these guys in a five minute
game that level of smoothness in the
technical conversion phase is absolutely
incredible that's what we have been
treated to thus far in the SEC another
Sicilian on Deck here with the bishop
coming out to before this time Lavon
going for the very ambitious C4
variation this is the recommendation uh
by most modern books and courses against
uh against the con
yes and D5 was played you could have
like Bishop takes D3 check which is a
double an isolated White's pawns but
that would have been bad news for black
you look at the pawn structure for black
all these compromised dark squares you
need to keep that Dark Sword Bishop
until the time is right that's why
Dimitri is playing in this fashion and
Dunya I think Now's the Time where you
can start trading pieces because after
Knight takes D5 Knight takes D5 Knight
takes C6 or he changes the move order
but the point is black is going to get
an isolated Pawn on D5 which means that
white has a free hand to play for win
without any risk in his position
yeah and at the risk of being overly
critical here again I'm not a huge fan
of Dimitri's opening choice he's just
slightly worse here he's giving Levon
exactly what he wants and Lavon showing
that he's more than up to date on all of
the topical recommendations I mean he's
got the bishop pair he's got a risk-free
position and he's got a one-point lead
so
Dimitri has his work cut out for him
here that was fascinating moment I I
just have to say that Dimitri gave up
his dark Square Bishop to protect D5 and
that was committal because now white has
a an isolated Pawn just like black does
but has the bishop pair Queen D4 right
now let's put pressure on a pin piece
and it's not even that you want to take
on F6 immediately but A6 is also sniped
by the bishop on E2 so there's no Rook
C8 for you anymore and I just feel like
the little things in this position of
Rook coming to B1 that Bishop on E6
worse than his counter on E2 the bishop
on H for of course better than the pin
Knight and F6 I think every individual
element including the queen placement
favors Lavon here and to piggyback off
of that consider things from the
opposite perspective black just has to
react to write black has to play purely
reactively he has no active plan because
there are no targets to attack and you
can say well what about the C3 Pawn well
how are you going to attack that pawn
that Queen is fully anchored to that
pawn The Rook has to stay anchored to
the A6 pawn and if you push A5 well then
you weaken the B5 Square so whatever you
do uh you're weakening something else
this is a flat out unpleasant position
for Dimitri and sometimes you play he
does it G5 to get rid of the pin yeah
but that's like the other problems I
like it as well but I think it creates
and look at this move Bishop D3 please
take me on G3 because if Knight takes G3
normally we play H takes G3 and don't
think about it here you take away from
the center F takes G3 you take over the
f file and get a rook to F6 that would
have been the idea so that's why Dimitri
goes Rook C8 and A6 is hanging but so is
C3 so the Knight on e4 is extremely
valuable in this position and Dimitri
putting up his hands in like prayer
formation there and one of the the key
defensive ideas of course is to offer up
a pawn as a bargaining chip and say hey
I'm going to give you a pawn in the
center in this case it's not even really
a sacrifice because C3 hangs but Dimitri
would like nothing more than an opposite
colored Bishop end game with the Queens
off the board that would give him the
most practical chances that last move
Rook C8 I like it it's active and Lavon
could just play Rook C1 and said he
snags the pawn on A6 and now he's got a
passer on A2 which you could Rumble
forward even on the next move
and Lavon just senses this right he's
it's a palm tree with even material but
the position is far from even that pawn
is going very quickly and as soon as the
bishop slides back from A6 I'm not sure
what Square will go to but A5 for white
followed by A6 is very straightforward
and block hating with a queen is the
worst possible thing right you never
want to blockade with a queen because
the queen on A5 doesn't protect the king
side and the King side may not be open
right now but if you ever take on G3
then F takes G3 as I mentioned earlier
your King on J will be under some heavy
fire and you don't always even need to
open up the the king side you've got
this kind of screwdriver pieces that can
infiltrate via the dark squares there we
go Bishop B5 Bishop to h8 was a huge
threat that explains Dimitri's last move
he wants to meet it with Queen to C3
that's an astute defensive resource Buy
on draken but oh is black hanging by a
thread or what that is unbelievable that
Queen C3 is available and actually I was
wondering if white could even go for
that just to trade queens and get it out
outside pass Pawn against a central pass
Pawn so that was an opportunity Queen C3
still available for Dimitri that forces
the Queens off the board but you better
be certain as he plays Queen C3 that
this A4 Pawn will not just go to the
other side and I think that Rook A1 to
D1 was a mistake because if the team has
to leave the blockade you really wish
your Rook were back on A1 and perhaps
Rook A1 to A3 merited some consideration
just to cover the C3 square but that's
obviously not an easy move to play and
Lavon at this point might have nothing
better as you said than to trade queens
and kind of waste the tempo on Rook A1
but that seems to be an eminently
drawable position for black especially
given what he just went through a couple
moves ago it's funny how what we learn
as principles like bring your Rooks
towards the center it's not always the
thing to do so Rook 81 I think was a
huge inaccuracy giving away most of the
advantage white is still better that's
clear but with the Queens coming off the
board and then likely some minor pieces
because once the Queens get swapped then
Knight goes into C3 and then white will
be forced to trade so I think that the
advantage is not nearly that large and
if that's the case Dimitri on drinking
he might be having a huge save he cannot
afford to go down two points at this
early to live on and I think I think you
nailed it I think that the importance of
this game extends past the result alone
yeah the result is important I mean you
don't want to go down by two points this
early in the match but it'll be a
confidence booster if Dimitri can hold
the draw and he can say hey my defensive
skills are still in order I can still
pull things out he makes some opening
changes uh and and he's right as rain so
let's see let's see if Dimitri can can
can follow this up with a couple more
accurate moves Lavon really sinking into
a deep think that says it says it all
and I think the Lavon we saw in game one
remember that moment where instead of
playing Rook takes C6 when rookie a
check and forced to draw I think for
LeBron right now down so much time he
should try to find a way that he could
play for a win sure but he has no losing
chances because the last thing you want
is to have 30 seconds left and two Rooks
on the second rank here going after the
white king
and we saw that kind of thing happen
with nepo in in his previous match
against mvl where they had countless end
games that seem to be two result games
but then Yani made a couple of sloppy
moves and he actually ended up losing a
lot of those enemies there's nothing
more tilting than that to be in charge
and in the driver's seat for the entire
game as you said and then just to to
throw away half a point uh just by being
sloppy and I don't think lavon's going
to do that no no no no no and he is nice
centralization here I still like the
look of Knight C3 from black it's
exactly what we've been talking about
trading off pieces should be good for
Dimitri in his defensive test but
instead he goes backwards and the reason
I don't like that not all obstacle and
Bishop endings are drawn the bishop on
D4 protects the B6 Square so if the
Knight does take on B5 after ab5 the
pawn is quickly going to B6 and the
black king on G8 also looks a little bit
iffy so I do think that Lavon has some
chances here and Dimitri's not trading
at all
yeah he goes hither and thither with his
Knight and the idea is to dislodge the
Bishop from D4 and set his own Pawn in
motion and as a consequence of that he
might be able to drive his Bishop into
C4 if he can get one of White's Bishops
off the board in strategic fashion I
think he'll be fine not totally sure
that he should take on D4 here that's a
big decision
I kind of like though Knight takes D4
Rook defense Rook A2 Rook A2 not going
yeah anywhere and you're Rook on F1 also
not going anywhere because the second
Rook will land on the second ring you
can just go King f8 King E7 King D6 go
to C5 or E5 I'm trying to appreciate
Black's position I'm declining a draw
here with with black given the time
situation you're absolutely right this
King plan King infiltration to E5 the
d-pawn starts moving you start sweating
here
this could get nasty for white it
already has gotten nasty yeah just I
like the look of King he was King G7 I
thought king of Fate also was good but
he wants King F6 King E5 and you can't
play F4 for white you want to trade
pawns play F4 keep trading but then that
Rook comes to C2 and G2 is loose I
actually think LeBron's gonna lose this
game
yeah somehow he's stopped oh he's still
chewing that's wrong but he stopped
drinking his water he goes back to D1
and his idea to go Rook to A1 and get a
pair of Rooks off the board so that he
can move I like it I think this is a
great defensive move by Lavon but
there's a tactic here Rook CEO Rook
exactly if you play Rook A1 Bluetooth F2
your Rook on F1 can't take on F2 and
defend A1 simultaneously so I do think
that Dimitri can pick off a pawn that
said this is the best decision for Lavon
the F2 Pawn not so consequential it's
just to make sure that you can relieve
the pressure
he went Rook C1 instead so what Dimitri
saying is yeah I'll let you get a pair
of Rooks off the board but I'm going to
recapture with the bishop not only am I
going to win the a pawn but the path
forward for the d-pawn is going to be
paved open and Lavon has no choice but
to refrain from the trade now the bishop
can slide into E4 this is very bad news
D3
oh I think Bishop D3 might save it right
because you're gonna take on e4 even if
you lose the a pawn if you can trade off
a pair of Rooks then you will be able to
hold the draw Bishop D3 Playboy but only
17 seconds we know he doesn't play very
much online so I would just move maybe
even to C5 or something
um actually then there's gonna be a
Trader Rook a once he plays Rook B2
that's smart and be careful because
after the trade black will be
threatening the devastating E3 and if
the F Pawn disappears you're going to
get mated with that Rook on F1 covering
the Escape score Rook B1 again Levon
tries to trade Rooks and at this point
the the two on three should be pretty
easily savable although with 10 seconds
absolutely anything can happen yeah here
comes F5 F4 oh yeah it's an A4 tg6 easy
play for what G4 but then E3 he plays G3
okay so F5 or maybe King H5 King G4
first
yeah you want to milk this as long as
possible maybe threaten some E3 related
pins Dimitri taking a moment here to
figure out the best way to torture Lavon
I guess King H5 the downstairs Rook F5
so white just starts attacking Black's
pawns but if you can get your king to G4
and play Pawn to F5 all of a sudden you
have very legitimate winning chances oh
totally and I think okay King H5 on the
board and Rook out five as you only said
is okay he was back just he's just
making Levon prove it and four seconds I
think he's gonna go F5 I don't really
see another option no Rook A2
okay so still King H5 there's Rook F5 so
that's always the whole 3.9 seconds
Levon actually lost 0.1 seconds in the
move he's a little slow you guys now he
goes up five
back to A4 preventing the move G4 which
should have cut off
the coordination between black spot now
there's a chapter one and an F3 is going
to be very dangerous yeah
and there's all these ideas Robert would
like E3 a breakthrough and a promotion
one second for Lavon he's barely getting
the moves up when he is getting them off
that's the most important that's a great
move King five bring the king up
Dimitri throwing the kitchen sink enemy
at point six and E3 E3 wins oh you let
him get a protected passer on the third
Rank and he's gonna flag
that's it and we knew it as soon as
Dimitri took on D4 he took over the game
and that is the problem that levana Roni
is going to face when he plays someone
like Dimitri on draken who is an amazing
Defender and a Speedster this is a big
problem for Lavon going forward
and this is what worries me so much
looking forward to the bullet Robert
because you think this is a problem now
wait until there's one minute to start
the game lavon's gonna have to pick up
the pace when things get down to a Time
scramble
frustrating loss oh it must be but look
at him he looks like nothing happened
he's still eating he's still just
focusing on the board and on on one hand
it's a frustrating loss on the other
you're kind of like okay I didn't have
time so I didn't get outplayed that's
the good news for LeBron thus far he
didn't really get outplayed in this
match he'd lost his Advantage sure but
he has not really been worse on the
board except for that Time Square where
he would have drawn if you put more time
with the clock so at least
psychologically speaking he can tell
himself that
yeah that is a level-headed way
of looking at it that is always what I
tell myself when I lose totally and then
I just calm down and move on and play
well the next game
hey there's something else in hashtag
never tilts he's the only player besides
Wesley so who did not lose a match in
the global Championship so you know he's
undefeated oh yeah that's actually a
great point he was of course replaced by
Sam Seville in the finals for for
personal reasons
uh but yeah he was undefeated yes and he
has had a tough year over the board he's
lost many rating points in classical
chess but he will play in tata steel and
Vikings day so that'll be good to see
Lavon getting back over the board and
right now in this position Dania again
Dimitri plays a quieter system right
caught on E3 Bishop on D2 but Lavon says
it's not quiet time let's open up that
center with your king only one
yeah that's a classic Lavon move we're
gonna get a bunch of trades in the
center okay after Knight takes E5 what
is Lavon going to recapture with Rook
takes C5 makes possible this idea of D4
but it just looks awkward Bishop takes
C5 maybe I don't know C takes D5 Knight
takes D5 there won't be any effective
discoveries if all if everything's
traded on D5 I think we might get some
sort of a liquidation just into an equal
position well can white just take on D5
right now I mean I know you're allowing
Knight takes F3 check and no I missed
that but but if you do take a on D5 and
he goes for it and that's one of those
moments where you're like do I trust
Levon aronian and Lavon has this
reputation at the highest level of both
being a brilliantly creative player but
also a bit of a bluffer the players talk
about this like Levant plays very
quickly in classical chess as well and
sometimes he doesn't actually know the
position he's just trying to pretend
like he does and you won't go for a
riskier line so here Lavon is down upon
but this is clearly intentional the King
on E1 is not going anywhere white has
moved both Rooks F3 is loose there's a
rook on E8 staring down the e-file I
like this in a Blitz game but white is
still a pawn to the good why does a pawn
to the good white does have the G file
there's not much going on there though
at the moment and after DC Bishop takes
C6 the Bishops looks Mighty menacing uh
staring down the barrel of the king side
so maybe DC and something a little more
conservative like Bishop E2 is what is
what the doctor would order here but
then maybe The Rook can come to CN and
Lavon can potentially open up a second
front on the queen side uh by pushing
these these pawns forward and targeting
the queen
yeah the extra Pawn does not feel worth
it here I don't see a plan for white G7
is threatened but it can always go up to
G6 if there's an issue and so Dimitrius
Bishop D3 but now for C takes D5 what
have you gained as white your king can't
go anywhere the C takes D5 threads D5 to
D4 with a rook on E8 it just goes Knight
E2
locating the D4 square and Paving the
way for Bishop C3 which I think is going
to come next
yeah I can buy Bishop C3 that looks good
um the H3 is hanging that's what I'm
considering I don't think you could take
it right now because they're gonna be
Rook H1 tactics things of that nature
but H3 is loose and at some point that
will be snagged
it probably will be Rook C8 now Bishop
C3 of course has a price tag attached to
it it walks into the pin and then B5
comes to mind as does in some cases like
D4 and Knight T5 you've got to watch out
for all sorts of tactics with the King
stuck in the center now permanently
let's not forget the Rook has moved away
you can't Castle either side both Rooks
have moved actually
okay can we take on H3
I don't actually see the recipe why not
rookie one maybe there's Queen D7 let me
just defend my Bishop
oh yeah and he doesn't and maybe Dimitri
was the one bluffing there
that's a big deal
and I like this feature chair game this
looks like a 960 position and that's
probably why he didn't take on H3 look
at this right here black can play D5 to
D4 and you can't take it because of the
pin on the e-file and I really feel like
white is two moves away from just
completely falling apart here
yeah but on the other hand if white well
I was gonna say if I can get in King F1
then I realized there's Bishop H3 check
get off me sending the king back to E1
and Lavon with Bishop B4 chipping away
at White's kind of central peace Mass
DeForest
oh but D4 you can take with a knight
because you Bishop H7 just you know what
game this reminds me of from the
candidates rajaba dingley ran against
her job of a little bit if you know what
I mean where oh I know ding got his King
stuck in the center where dropov had a
rook sack on E3 in a similar structure
and I love the way Levon is handling his
wait Queen 64 almost works there's
Bishop H7 right so that's the problem I
I assume Levon saw that he just goes
Knight D5 but oh he's giving away H7 and
look at the eval bar it's sliding up in
White's favor but Donna you have maybe
more experience playing crazy position
like this in some time travel just
because White's two pawns ahead the evil
bars is good it's still so complicated
Knight takes E3 on top on tap Queen H6
as an idea for black of course the
pressure on the bishop and C3 to begin
with so I feel like I still think that
LeBron has good chances here and that is
shown with Dimitri's retreat but a wise
move by and Drake and again kind of
using uh his extra Pawn as as a
bargaining chip and saying hey I don't
mind the trade on C3 and then the trade
on B1 I'm even happy to give my extra
Pawn away as long as the Queens are off
the board and now of course Bishop takes
H7 is a huge threat because it wins the
night
right no problem down the D file H7 is
hanging with check G6 would be would be
my first inkling but then there's like
H5 to consider just to pry open the king
side at all costs ah it's not an easy
position to figure out for Lavon
thankfully for him he has to do it and
not me and he has time to do I was gonna
say sack on E3 I didn't really mean it
seriously though Rook cheese seven
whoa King f8 oh my gosh there's no way
this is objectively sound
but what a mind-boggling position we get
with a minute and a half to figure it
out for Dimitri
what is happening yeah I'm like
struggling to Kevin here because I want
to play Brook takes G7 check the king
should go to f8 of course and then Rook
takes H7 so I'm just grabbing all the
pawns I can but I understand that the
white king is in some danger as well he
does take on G7 and I think he's gonna
take on H7 I think you called it yeah I
just want to keep my king as safe as
possible F takes E3 might also be good
but I'm not worried about the ripping
loose on G7 yeah you're gonna take on C3
and take on G7 so I think here he's
committed to playing Rook takes H7 I I
mean I guess you can play F6 C3 Bishop
takes C3 BC oh Queen B1 Bishop B1 and
the bishop hangs on D7 he takes on F7
okay that line you just showed was
absolutely ridiculous and maybe we can
show whoa speaking of ridiculous lines
Queen H7 goodness gracious if you take
on C4 you get me to made it immediately
made it but King King f8 takes the sting
a little bit out of Queen H7 because it
doesn't come with check and it gives you
the chance to eliminate the Bishop from
C3 might get a Perpetual here of some
sort I think that's what the evil bar is
saying wait but your point of a bishop
H3 check being annoying is still true if
you trade on C3 Knights oh Knight C2
Queen can take on C2 but you want to
distract the queen and then Rook takes
C4 and Rook takes D7 oh holy smokes
this is so what I thought Knight C2
fourth King F1 I forgot about the queen
on H7 and then that was a bishop H3
check get your Bishop off the hanging
Square Queen F6 defending F7 and h8
queen G8 check there's the Perpetual
Queen G8 and queen H7 because obviously
the king can't go to d8 you get mated on
D7 I think Dimitri is going to go for it
with 30 seconds left it would be Madness
to go for the win here with Rook takes
D7
but this game has been full of Madness
this match has been full of Menace I
mean this might be another draw but that
first draw we saw was definitely a
fighting game in this too
what else is there besides the
repetition I might need to show that F
takes E3 line after this game concludes
because that was ridiculous and that
probably was the win according to the
eval bar so I'll put that up after after
this game finishes yeah especially
because we're about to go to our
halftime break in the five plus one
portion and this game is officially a
draw so Donna take us through that line
because that was just a really deep idea
so it happened in this position Dimitri
found an incredible idea in his own
right but it only led to a draw instead
F takes E3 it looks like it fails
because after Bishop takes E3 You're
Gonna Lose The Rook on the next move and
be down in exchange but you can take
with the pawn opening up a line of
contact between the Queens no problems
Queen takes B1 and then I take the Rook
but lpdo Loose pieces drop off the
bishop takes on B1 opening up an attack
on the D7 Bishop after King takes G7
Rook takes D7 it's not totally over but
something like Rook takes E3 King F2
white has two pieces for The Rook he's
picking off B7 and this is a technically
winning position but who can fall
Dimitri for not spotting this in time
pressure right because what you had to
find was Bishop retreating move Capture
One B1 that's not your typical idea so
that was a deep idea it was available to
Dimitri on Drake and both sides had
chances in this game I mean early on it
looked like Levon was in charge but that
was a fun game it is a fun match it is
two to two so we're gonna send this show
to break for now but wouldn't return
it's more from Lavon aronian and Dimitri
andrekin here in the speed Chess
Championship
[Music]
Danny wrench back again Chief chess
officer bringing you chess terminology
let's Dive Right into one of one of
everybody's favorite tactics if I might
be so bold because it's surprising it's
something that never never fails to
deliver shock value and excitement
whether you're watching a broadcast or
just reviewing some famous chess games
and that is the process of an under
promotion when you move upon to the
other side of the board almost always
you're looking to get a queen but the
rare times where it's better to get
something else or perhaps even required
in order to maybe not stalemate your
opponent or keep your winning chances
alive are some of the most fascinating
exciting moments in chess so with that
let's dive into what under promotion is
and show you some of my favorite
examples
under promotion as we said is the
process of promoting a pawn but not to
the most obvious or most powerful type
of piece which is usually the queen
in this famous example between Nakamura
and Vladimir kramnik the fact that
Hikaru was winning is only because he
under promotes on C8 to a knight that
move comes with check on the black king
so that on the next turn white can
capture the E2 pawn it should be noted
that if Hikaru had queened
black would actually go on to win
because now black queens with check and
ultimately chromic would have been able
to not just save but actually win this
game another promotion tactic provided
to me by our own Sam Copeland vice
president of content one of his favorite
examples is the move D7 and after Bishop
to E8 the only way to win the game is to
underpromote to a bishop underboarding
to a bishop doesn't happen that often in
this particular study it was designed to
be so the point is that if the bishop
moves over to H5 we check and mate along
the A4 EA diagonal and if the bishop
moves anywhere else white actually plays
a subtle move Bishop of seven first and
there is no way to prevent Checkmate on
the next move shout out to everybody
watching this video thank you for tuning
in and enjoying our breakdown of under
promotion and we'll see you on chess.com
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we are back here at the speed Chess
Championship 2022 this match is between
Lavon aronian and Dimitri on draken it
has been all knotted up to this point
some Fighting Chess to be sure but the
players cannot gain separation it is two
to two Donya and what a whirlwind these
last four games have been
they have gone back and forth it seemed
that levonaronian was controlling the
pace uh and the games early on but that
second game that defensive effort by
Dimitri on draken was incredible and
then a wild one in the game that we just
saw in a ragazan I mean they have gone
back and forth the games have been all
over the map
they certainly have been in lebanaronian
he is a world-class player has been for
decades at this point and he's a former
World Blitz Champion so he has won that
highest title and Matt from these
insides Tanya I think the interesting
part is the pressure that he puts on his
opponents he wins a third of his wins
are by time that's interesting because
he kind of seems like the slower player
between the two but he didn't keep that
pressure up he does make sure that he
uses that to the very end yeah I mean
he's capable of playing quickly that's
obviously the case but can he keep it
together throughout all of the time
scrambles in this match we'll find out
seat belts or speed belts I guess
fastened the next game is about to begin
in Lavon he's got the white pieces and
are we going to get another Sicilian yes
we are it's one of those matches down
here we're good yeah just uh you just
know Rick Wall yeah they just want to
prove that they're the better prepared
player they have more comfort in these
Sicilians and once again on drinking
goes for this Knight of six line and
Bishop B4 so we saw this in game one
here we see it again in game five and
that was an interesting Knight takes E4
tactic in the previous game I wonder if
Levant had a chance to look at this
during the quick break here the answer
seems to be no because he has no move
but he is repeating a line that actually
looked quite fascinating and complex
yeah and I wonder if this is part of
Dimitri's preparation and it probably is
we'll live on he's too busy drinking
more water whatever's in that gigantic
thermos of his
he hasn't moved yet though this is not a
good sign if you're a levonne erodian
fan he's repeating an opening that for
sure he thinks is good because why would
he play in the first place but then he
didn't look at it and Dimitri is playing
it again so now it's psychological what
did Dimitri look at do I have to be
afraid of something was there a win for
Dimitri there that he didn't see in game
one and Lavon is spending a lot of time
here Dania yeah cannot afford to be down
a minute and and you made a point years
ago in an SEC commentary which is that
when you keep repeating the same opening
and you're convinced that it's good for
you but you can never seem to actually
find the reputation that takes a
psychological toll on you you start
getting annoyed and for some of these
players who are kind of proud you know
they they don't want to be the one uh to
switch their openings because that is
kind of a psychological Victory as some
of the players themselves have pointed
out in interviews but you don't want to
be the one who admits that your
preparation is worse you spent a minute
and a half and there's the deviation he
played F5 in game one there's Queen F3
on the board now well you know how I
said no Lavon is quite known for
bluffing playing quickly and pretending
like he knows something he just played
slowly and then went Queen to F3 when
all was said and done and it just feels
like Dimitri should have the upper hand
he could just take this Pawn on F4 hand
his opponent isolated Pawn in the center
and that will give some chances though
if he does take the swipe in Knight G4
first he's keeping the status quo there
the bishop on D3 looks a bit silly uh
and here's a big moment for Lavon will
he play that F5 move like he did in game
one
hmm well now he's got to move the bishop
as we've established giving up the dark
squared Bishop here very very bad
positionally he goes Bishop D2 and I I
still think Dimitri can take on F4 and
then later on try to control that E5
score prevent the E Pawn from moving
forward which could be dangerous in the
event the black Castle's King side
although I just like ef4 as you're
saying Queen E7 get a knight to E5 it
seems like a very straightforward plan
yeah and no way for white to take
advantage of that so uh Dimitri is
wisely taking some time he's up plenty
on the clock and he takes a force Now or
Never because white will play them
Bishop I think that's like F5 right now
yes and say thank you very much and
obviously you're not fearing the check
on F2 that's a paper tiger just King E2
and black will actually lose a piece
I'm shocked that Dimitri didn't take on
F4 there's something he didn't like
there but that seemed like a very
favorable Pawn structure transformation
for black right and if you play F5 here
the Knight can go to F2 you just slide
your Rook on over to F1 Castle Queen
side a bit later uh your king is
perfectly safe and that pawn on F5 it's
such a thorn in Black side your Bishop
Advantage I'm putting that in quotes at
least in my head because your Bishop
won't see it is not a good piece in fact
it's quite bad and will remain bad and
you get to keep the important Bishop the
dark squared Bishop uh and and white can
actually Castle Queen side you can say
well enough to The Rook has to move but
you want to Castle queenside there
anyway and uh execute that idea you
mentioned earlier of F5 F6 in some cases
that was a surprising strategic mishap
by undraken like this is not what you
want if your two choices were to take on
a four and blockade and isolate a pawn
or to get the bishop pair but your
Bishop on C8 is not good this is clearly
the wrong thing to do and you may think
oh Queen H4 check but you're not going
to take this Pawn on H2 you're really
trapped over there so he plays B5 but
Donna this is just not at all looking
good for Dimitri I just it's just hard
to play when when you've got a piece
that that's not coming out like this I
mean it could come out to D7 or B7 it's
passive and as you mentioned that this
this Pawn chain is uh both strong both
from a defensive and an attacking
perspective shocking shocking to me that
that Dimitri allowed F5 there
and by the way Queen G3 is a pretty big
threat in these G7 and E5 are both under
attack if your investment was Queen F6
that's not exactly promising so right
now I think that Dimitri
should not develop his light Square
Bishop it's not going anywhere promising
anyway on B7 or D7 you know what I'm
kind of looking at what about the move
Rook A7 to kind of open up F6 later to
defend all across the seventh Rank and
I'll be Rook A7 to D7 at some point just
to attack this Pawn on D3 yeah no I like
that idea a lot I think in terms of
developing some activity uh that's as
good as it gets but instead he plays
more straightforwardly Castle in
kingside I think intending to meet Queen
G3 with F6 opening up the seventh ring
and then we actually might see Rook A7
so should Lavon consider the move F6
himself the drawback is that that will
allow a queen trade after Queen takes F6
and it will get let the bishop develop
to E6
yeah I don't think he can afford to play
the move F6 is white so I'm looking he
plays Knight E2 just he's rewriting the
Knight to the king side if black plays
F6 white will essentially pre-move G4 H4
G5 and just open up the king side
um so for black what is an idea here I'm
just he goes Bishop he's
he's retreating he's on his back foot
here but he is stopping many of the
plans that white was going for with G4
G5 he's stopping F6 and he could play
Bishop G5 himself at some point if he
wants to avoid having a passive Bishop
behind opponent F6 and he's also opening
up the pathway for the C Pawn but whoa
another transformation D4 by Lavon
another typical Levon move and I think
he wants to meet he takes deeper with is
it E5 and F6 is that his idea it
definitely is Dania and this is starting
to look very promising and I've used
this word I'm gonna keep using it in
this match from a practical perspective
F6 was a really good response and a
quick response from on draken and white
should probably play E6 now uh one of
the things you're going to do here is
white is you're going to keep your Pawn
E6 protected pass Pawn uh black will
need to play C5 C4 C3 something like
that quickly but with the Rook n A8 the
queen perfectly positioned on F3 I think
just takes a little bit too much time
for black to get away with yeah white
will play Knight F4 Knight H5 and go
after the G7 Pawn no I mean you could
get checkmated on G7 by the time you
finish getting out of bed I think
Dimitri has to play Rook A7 at some
point in order to have the possibility
of defending the G7 Pawn he doesn't do
it Robert I think this straightforward
idea of just putting a knight on H5 into
Queen on G4 with no possibility of
defending the seventh rank is going to
be totally devastating I think it's
winning you said straightforward he's
going for the even more straightforward
push Bishop H6 I think he's talking
about the night I distracted you because
Queen G4 Bishop H6 is just that simple
well you can move the bishop out of E7
uh to open up the possibility of Queen
E7
so what's The Knockout in that position
is it Bishop H6 and Rook takes D4
that looks pretty darn good in the
double in the D file you can also Rook
lift rookette I mean Rook F3 now oh yeah
more than tempting just Rook F3 Rook H3
Knight F4 Knight G6 this is just oh come
on and black black is nothing going on
the queen side not a single attacking
idea
and you know it's what we're gonna keep
talking about D4 such a strong practical
Choice by Lavon he sensed that his
opponent can be put in immediate danger
he realized that the pawn deficit was
not the most important thing here and
now isn't he just winning with Knight F4
to G6 and Rook H3 to come and I think
after night up for Queen takes day two
first of all obviously Queen A1 the king
easily escapes the checks you could also
play Knight F4 and then Rook G3 in order
to induce Rook cheat and then Knight G6
leads to a very pretty h-file mate Rook
G3 it's over yeah it really is beautiful
though rookie and then Knight she's like
a smothered Checkmate uh Knight G6 is
the more kind of just forceful approach
Knight G6 check Rook H3 check Queen
takes on G6 and the King's getting made
anyway so this feels like uh in just a
nice game a nice overall win the only
thing black has is a single check on e4
with that Bishop but that's not going to
do anything regardless and great time
management by levantes left himself with
just enough time to figure this out Rook
C1 though
very I don't know how to call this move
I mean it doesn't give away the win of
course
I guess he said this is simple like not
even go let my opponent go after my king
in any way if G3 isn't yeah I know that
was definitely just Checkmate so I don't
I I just don't really want to criticize
it because it's still completely winning
but it's a kind of it's the kind of
mistake I think what you're hinting at
you can't get away with that as the time
control gets shorter and yes it will be
a little bit more complex you can't
afford these inaccuracies yeah but here
of course okay now I hope he goes for
everyone if he doesn't go rookie one now
we're gonna have to pause the match and
have a little conversation he might play
B3 first and then oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my God that's an epic
moment
how did you know that because you can
just he wants to just bury the queen as
much as possible first you know what
they say right when there's Checkmate in
one look for better he knows he's gonna
win the game so he's just prolonging the
suffering
Robert hassonian
wow I cannot believe that just happened
Rook fb8 that is a sad move right there
oh gosh just checking
it's just like literally the most
one-sided position of all time
that was impressive though no that was
you know we're laughing just because of
the B3 move but I don't think Dimitri on
draken is laughing at all look at him
he's just like what happened there Lavon
just completely dummed him the game and
this game is being restarted because
LeBron just won with the white pieces he
has to get the black pieces here we go
uh the players rematch each other and
now Dimitri plays E4
he's like I liked the way you won there
let me do a little bit of that Lavon
says I'm not playing the Sicilian that's
what you're missing in this equation in
a fortnight Scotch is this a David
perravian match
yeah what is going on here and good
shout out for David perovian I mean he
loves this fortnite Scotch game and
white plays okay H right here with Queen
F3 Bishop G5 those are sort of standard
moves or Bishop to F4 uh but on draken
he switched first moves down here but he
has not switched his gameplay he's still
playing very straightforward solid chess
yeah and you know an interesting choice
he wants to change things up a little
bit and he's only down by one the good
news about losing a game like that as
unpleasant of a taste as it leaves in
your mouth it's worth the same exact
point that a long technical loss uh is
worth so I don't think that draken is
too broken up about it and he decides
okay let me tone things down a little
bit with a relatively risk-free system a
good choice overall
yeah no I I like the way Dimitri plays
in these matches because he's not really
going to get blown off the board in the
openings right that's just not something
that happens to him very often
um but then when he's down in the match
I think that's when I get a little bit
concerned because sometimes you need to
take risk not in this particular match
time it's so early uh he's down one
point not a big deal but you know what I
mean like he's if somebody is down a
point I trust like a Lavon aronian to
get that point but for Dimitri he just
plays a little bit too solidly and I
think that can hurt him in some
situations yeah which is why he should
avoid being down in this match that's
totally no I totally understand what
you're saying and we see a rook on
before actually not that uncommon in
these types of positions you see this
idea from time to time and a big
question is going to be where live on
positions to seep on I think he's going
to go more conservatively with C6 C5
grabs more space but opens up various
possibilities of Bishop C4 for example
that Queen could end up very vulnerable
after that that last move by Dimitri
yeah and what you're saying with the
movie C5 what you're correctly assessing
is that black doesn't really want to
play C5 and D4 that may look like you're
advancing your structure that's great
but you're giving away all the light
squares and guess what your opponent is
a light Square Bishop a knight on C3
ready to hop to squares look at the
Knight on C3 now E5 under control E4
under control of course D5 uh is ultra
defended so I like the way Levon is
handling these last few moves but I
still believe Dimitri has chances here
you want to play Knight A4 at some point
take over the C5 Square mid Queen E3 to
follow and I do believe that there is
some hope for an advantage a legitimate
one right now no this is this is a more
pleasant position and he loves these
types of positional grinds he plays
Knight A4 good call and a Black Knight
Tails whites Knight to D7 covering all
of these dark squares and potentially
preparing to jump into E5 although
that's not really an idea right now
because after Queen G3 again that Queen
on D6 is a major problem piece in this
position
wow and C4 is in great move by Dimitri
on draken remember that game uh where
Lavon was white where he handed Dimitri
that isolated Pawn on D5 that was the
game two that Jimmy actually ended up
winning but at a very tough position at
some point this is a the same situation
colors reverse I think Dimitri has found
the perfect placement for all of his
pieces he is going to hand his opponent
a worse Pawn structure and he can keep
the game going he is the faster player
between the two and queen E3 by the way
also threatens Queen A7 and A5 is loose
so I think Levon has to be very careful
these next few moves oh absolutely and
there's all sorts of ideas in the center
you could play Bishop D3 to B1 I'm
pretty attracted to that move the Knight
could come back to C3 at a moment's
notice and apply more pressure on D5 and
as you pointed out you can't fall asleep
on the queen side either that A5 Pawn
could in fact be targeted with that
Queen escapad another great call you're
on a roll Queen E3 on the board
yeah this one was a little easier to
call the other one was a joke but here
here it just goes to show like D4 for
black is not what you want you give away
the light squares uh that's a problem
and if you leave the pawn on D5 that
leaves the queen access to A7 oh it
could be a swap a D5 would you just
notice and after D4 there's just a funny
Fork Queen G5 you don't say this every
time forking the d8 rook and the A5 Pawn
of course black can defend both but if
you have to play Rook d8 to A8 not a
good sign either no no I didn't see that
as a follow-up I just thought D4
strategically is not what you want uh
but Queen G5 is a brilliant follow-up so
I think that Lavon deep in the think
tank right now and down uh 40 seconds
and counting this is not good for him
he's probably just trying to find an
idea but it's a position where black
doesn't really have ideas black just has
to Parry off threats it's funny how
quickly this got bad they were in theory
like seven moves ago it looked like a
totally normal four night Scotch
position and I think David Province
showed this in the in the RCC this is
actually a dangerous opening it's not
just something you play to bail out and
make a draw far from it
no and you mentioned paravian he really
is like he's like person who plays the
most it's what he it's autopilot for him
and we see a swap on D5 at long last I
think Rook C1 makes sense that's a newly
opened C file let's use it and white has
the healthier Pawn structure A2 and B3
they're in connection with one another
upon's best friend is another Pawn the
pawn A5 is a straggler it's isolated it
can be attacked at some point it's not
easy to defend you can use heavier
pieces so Rook C1 H6 by Levon and Dania
how to follow up here for Dimitri
there's the answer Rook dives into C6
and there is the major threat
potentially of an exchange sack on E6
think about a battery that could happen
on this diagonal of course there's
Knight f8 later to defend H7 but still
Levon has to keep a ton of things in
mind here also Robert your earlier point
that A5 Pawn can be targeted as well
with Rook to A6
just Rook takes E6 looks so scared if I
were playing Black I play rookie it
might not be a good move but I I'm maybe
a little bit too afraid but I am very
scared of Rook takes E6 just looks like
yeah the long-term issues in the light
squares will lead to a win for on Dragon
and slowly the clock continues to take
down it's not a problem until he drops
below a minute but that's going to
happen very very shortly
and you also can double on the C file
and potentially try to infiltrate C8
Rook E8 another good call there is the
move Bishop F5 but I don't necessarily
like that it's tempting but the Knight
can drop back to f8 and the last thing
you want to do is give away your light
squared Bishop it's a huge asset also
Robert from the perspective of covering
the Luft Square on H7 creating long-term
problems with Black's back rank but why
did Dimitri play Knight C5 because that
9a4 even though it was on the rim it was
not dim it was actually blockading the
pawn and now black I think it was A5 to
A4 exactly you were getting rid of your
worst piece and now I feel like black
has no more targets to go after I think
that was a big oversight by Dimitri he
just got a little bit I don't want to
say careless but you know what I mean
you just sort of forget that your
opponent could push the pawn and as soon
as it happens like way that's not at all
what I was looking for yeah he played
one of those moves that kind of looks
tempting because oh look at my pieces
they're very active but they're not
actually attacking anything Black's
Queen and Rook are connected to each
other and once the queen side disappears
it's just an immediate drop you're
absolutely right that 9984 was the hit
was was the unsung hero of White's
entire position actually
I just I think this is one of those
moments where you just want it back and
we talk about this a lot down here it's
not about winning games necessarily it's
about maximizing the pressure if your
opponent plays Perfect Defense that's a
different story than you playing very
imperfect offense and Knight C5 that was
just a move that was played a little bit
too quickly it allowed black to
immediately get rid of the only true
weakness on the board and as you see by
Demetrius time management now he's like
oh gosh it's still in disposition
there's still some juice to be squeezed
here I think I I would say that 0.0
assessment is a little bit misleading
levon's the one who has to be careful
would you get behind that oh for sure
Lavon has to be more careful too because
uh the bishop on E6 is worse than the
bishop on B3 what has an outside pass
Pawn compared to a central pass pawn and
it's not really threatening to go to D4
anytime soon and I'm also looking at
Rook takes E6 I know I shouldn't do that
I still am trying to play for the win in
my head but you have to look out for
those light squares because Black's King
will not be safe yeah and doing it
prematurely risks losing the game of
course black also has the counter
exchange sack on B3 if he wants to make
a draw
um but if I'm white I'm looking for ways
just to prolong the game now Rook takes
C6 was a huge threat in Queen E7 but
lavon's staying as alert as ever oh and
that is a relief not only did he trade
the Rooks he pre-move Queen takes B7 so
I think lavon's showing that he's got
that bullet skill in him and now D5 is
threatened but it's also protected by
all of Black's forces so what's the plan
for black I don't have one but I just
know that black is doing okay but not on
the clock
not on the clock and it's gonna get
uncomfortable if white can find a way to
set this Apon in motion now if you do it
too quickly black might want to find a
way to slip the move d4 in using tactics
to protect the pawn so Dimitri Gets
behind that pawn first but Lavon does
the exact same thing on the a file this
is just good chess from both and queen
D6 check quickly go back to A3 Union
Prim of Queen Primo I would probably do
that there you go
spending those three four five seconds
he just has to make quicker moves and he
allowed A4 I I'm I'm and he also allowed
something like Queen to H4 to provoke
more weaknesses I don't know about the
utility of that move H5 instead Dimitri
going Rook to C1 he wants to keep the
pawn on A2 in order to keep the bishop
anchored on B3 doesn't want to deal with
an undefended piece but maybe that's
what he has to do to generate winning
chances no I think he does but he might
just have winning chances on the clock I
think that's what he's going for at this
point so at timely A4 just to be a bit
of a distraction uh maybe play a move
like it was Queen F6 you're just poking
and prodding and making sure lavon's in
the lookout another five seconds another
10 seconds spent by Lavon he can't play
D4 there because if Bishop takes E6 and
the G6 spawn would have hung guess what
that's the price you pay for putting the
pawn on H5 but can Dimitri keep this
game going he's down to 30 seconds
himself in a queen trade
right but the problem is for black this
D5 Pawn is there and it goes in D4 Rook
C7 can be slammed and the white king is
very close to the center King F1 King E1
I would have gotten it into immediately
I would have gotten it to D2 immediately
now the pawn can slip into D2
potentially although you could argue
that it could become a weakness
great move great move Bishop E6 trade
the Bishops right now play Rook B6
though put your Rook on B4 and there I
don't think white can get in oh great
point you could get your king back to C2
and then start moving The Rook around
though oh he's taking H4
and now the pawn gets forward but the
king can blockade it easily wow that was
really well done by lobotomy he's
showing that he can play in time trouble
and he's keeping 10 seconds on the clock
now the clock is equalized no this is
this is a give the he shouldn't have any
problems anymore
he wants his Rook closer to his King but
don't trade Rooks you trade Rooks you
lose if you're LeBron because of the
outside pass font and it's easy to
blunder in time pressure just
accidentally playing like Rook D6
putting your rook in front of your king
he's got three seconds Dimitri's still
trying
okay Rook at four check he wants
because barely getting these moves up
and that there we go you can't take the
pawn he's in trouble now
he's going to six
great defense
what about G3 here you're gonna lose
Rook away The Rook at five all right now
it's too late
yeah this is a hold liquidation of the
king side and it's a draw
but three seconds for both all the
pieces come off and Lavon aronian he's
saying shush don't you talk about my
bullet problems no I'm holding this game
and Donya I mean we remember from the
cgc vasil Evancho he couldn't do what
LeBron just did right when he got into
those time scrambles he was losing on
time Lavon is still holding on but as
this match continues watch out for
moments just like this on Drake and
mayev uh allowed not allowed I think
Lavon earned that draw but Dimitri maybe
could have kept peace on the board
blockade the pawn but I think as we get
to three minute and eventually the
bullet then Levant will have serious
problems because game after game it gets
stressful and what would a high-level
SCC match be without the Berlin
you know we were that's exactly what we
were missing I was thinking there was
just something that we weren't getting
and now I realize what it is
yeah so uh where's Canty when you need
him
uh but in in all seriousness the Berlin
is actually a very rich opening and it
has a lot of interesting ideas once you
get past that initial draw phase because
some players they make that queen queen
D4 Queen E4 Queen D6 Queen six draw with
scenicaro and Wesley do that so many
times but if we try to break down the
Berlin in just three seconds well then
we're not doing chess justice but if we
take it seriously just for a moment here
uh blood's Pawn structure compromise
Right double pause the C file but what
does black have in return has a bishop
an extra one compared to a knight and
this Pawn on E5 often sticks out like a
sore thumb so you know if in certain end
games with the black king in the center
it can approach that epon attack it and
it may not be easy for white to keep it
defendant and that's exactly right and
as a result of the pun being on E5
you're also weakening a lot of the light
squares which would have been protected
where the pawn just one square back on
e4 I'm talking the D5 score in
particular you sometimes plant a bishop
on D5 pressuring and I don't have three
and combine that with your idea King E7
King E6 White Center could collapse
pretty quickly also the 9.5 a pretty
major asset it's just nicely placed in
the center and H5 a very King
zindian-esque idea you see this in the
king's Indian on the other side of the
board with a knight on C5 and the pawn
on A5 to prevent a potential G4
it's really good of you to draw
comparisons between different openings
because it's true like the Knight is not
a square the bishop would usually be and
with a bishop there there is no G4 oh
the bishop behind it on C the Knight
often gets kicked so H5 stops that from
happening and you mentioned A5 A5 is
still an idea in this position because
you want to gain space and black does
have an extra Pawn on the queen side A5
maybe even A4 with Rook A5 to follow we
mentioned the E5 Pawn potentially being
a Target you can lift your Rook up from
A8 up to A5 or you could swing it to d8
looks like that's more likely to happen
in this game
and Bishop E6 sort of a standard
developing move by Dimitri this looks
pretty watertight for black I'm sure
this position has occurred before and
like mvl against Hikaru and Tata Steel
2013 because this end game has been
contested now for well over a decade
well over two decades at the highest
echelons uh of Chess and we have the
bishop standoff here who's gonna Flinch
first so I think levantage made a
mistake levonne made a mistake there it
looked good to take on E6 and give your
opponent this isolated Pawn but
oftentimes black is perfectly okay with
it what you do now is you trade on G5
you play King E7 and not only does black
have access to the D5 Square for trying
to double the Rooks but also the D4
Square so the Knight on G5 will not be
that good of a piece I don't like the
trade there I think that was I don't
really understand yeah why give up the D
file I mean why give up the D not that
it's the end of the world that all of
the squares on the default are protected
but but it is an asset and why cannot oh
great before good move yeah
and I don't get H4 either Robert I mean
if it ain't broke don't fix it yeah Rook
takes D1 uh you know I don't want to be
overly harsh but it just doesn't make
sense right you just handed your
opponent the open file where as you
could have connected your Rooks right
trade on G5 play King E7 so it's not
like Dimitri has a lost position but now
he has no hope of any counter chances
and he is just simply going to be worse
for the remainder of this game and if he
holds that would be an accomplishment
and I think I I would assign his
likelihood of drawing this higher than
levon's likelihood of squeezing this out
but with no no longer a Pawn on H5 G4
could come at a very inopportune moment
for black uh perhaps white should
combine it with a move C2 to C3 to cover
a potential square that the Knight could
jump out to so definitely a very
pleasant end game at this point for
Lavon
yeah I just I I just don't know for
Dimitri because he doesn't have a plan
here and he's down upon if you count
each side has six pawns but if you dive
in white has three on two majority on
the king side and B5 another very
positionally committal move
you know what's happening here
potentially Dania what opening is
Dimitri been playing the entire match
the Sicilian he might just not feel that
comfortable playing these systems and he
decided to play the Berlin of course he
is a wealth of experience in all sorts
of openings but his last bunch of moves
just they come off to me like somebody
who has not played the Berlin that much
at least not recently and I might want
to check this during the brand but I
don't think he plays the Berlin that
often he he's a sicilian guy and when he
plays e45 I think he likes going for the
main line so I think you're absolutely
right and you might ask well what
exactly is the drawback of B5 well it's
that it weakens the C5 pawn and later on
especially after a bishop trade on E7
this knight from F3 could jump first to
G5 it could stay there but it can also
wind itself back to E4 and then worm its
way to C5 and there's a rook
infiltration to D7 So eventually black
is going to you know these weaknesses
are going to come back to haunt him
well said and
um he plays C4 look at that he is
cementing the C5 Pawn in place if you
take on Z4 Rook C1 and that is the
ugliest Pawn structure you could
possibly have bc4 triple isolated Pawns
of the C file an isolated E Pawn unless
I say g-pawn and in isolated a pawn I
really don't think I've seen worse that
is a power move right there that that is
a class move C4 fix the weakness and
make the idea of Knight G5 to E4 even
stronger so strong in fact that it could
simply win the C5 pawn and the moment
one of the pawns is gone the whole
position collapses you might have to
play BC yeah and I think that if you
don't play BC you play B4 but then you
have this C5 Pawn then you're just gonna
lose and that's not exactly making
things any better so uh B4 Bishop E7 you
mentioned this idea with the Knight
rerouting if you played BC Rook C1 and
here Rook C1 I think you can play
because you might Force the move B4
anyway then go back and then you go
right back and play trade Bishops Knight
g594. and you shouldn't think twice
about investing a Tempo in a position
like this because the value of every
Tempo is greatly diminished it's an end
game White's not risking black doesn't
have any immediately active plans or
threats so this Rook C1 Rook D1 idea a
lot of people hesitate to do that but I
thought it was very good he goes G4
instead of sort of a more concrete
approach getting the Knight off of F5
and opening up a little uh Square for
the white king as well
okay so now feels like King G3 but then
there's Knight F7
yes okay
and then E5 is under pressure so you
can't move your knight that easily this
might actually be inaccurate by Lavon
but you know what he's gonna do he's not
going to trade on E7 I think that's
lavon's plan he's going to bring his
Bishop back maybe to F4 to keep E5
defended or just go to E3 directly but
the point is that black really would
like to trade Bishops and have the Rook
access along the last rank but with the
King stuck on E8 I think Bishop E3 is
the superior option than Bishop takes E7
and now Dimitri I think should play B4
again using the fact that it's very hard
for white uh to solve the problem of the
E5 fund you actually could try to get
your king over to E4 but then guess what
you're occupying the square that the
Knight wants to go to and potentially
you could get yourself in trouble now
there's also Knight T2 to B3 uh which
shouldn't be slept on but from the
opposite perspective Robert Knight d8 to
B7 could be a valuable defensive
resource when necessary
I love you thinking about King of the
Hill here the King on e4 is very strong
can't even be checked from that I liked
the way the sentence started I think you
should have started stopped it at you oh
oh
well that may be true as well I don't
love Dimitri's position especially after
that move uh Rook C1 but I I think he's
gonna go King D7 King C6 so I don't like
the look of it but that was a good
choice I think by Dimitri a great choice
he's opened up at the queen side for
himself and he's kind of left White's
pieces in the dust on the king side and
he's got still worse I mean you can see
the eval bar it's still around plus one
but it hasn't you know the ticker hasn't
changed in a while
there is a clever Rook F4 at some point
just to make that Knight leave F7 and
that will free the Knight on F3 he goes
King F4 you mentioned this idea a long
time ago I think Lavon probably feels
like he should win this game like that's
the sense Oh Yeah from the position and
he just rolled up his sleeve so that's
awesome but I do think that Lavon has no
risk here and he is just better in like
six different ways including the pawn
structure he's ahead in the clock he
feels like he's gonna win this game and
another unpleasant idea could be to move
the Knight back from me one position it
on D3 and then send the F Pawn forward
to F5 using it as a battering ram to try
to get rid of this kind of basis of
Black's hole position the E6 Pawn here
it comes 91 to D3 King E4 Pawn F4 Pawn
F5 you're creating a pass Pawn white is
a pawn ahead yes if I count it's six
excuse me five pounds with five pounds I
can't count clearly but white is
essentially upon head because black has
these double Pawns but now a big
decision for Lavon he can do three oh
boy blundered are you look at him 19 he
just noticed it he knows
he blundered a piece knight T3 check
oh my gosh and does he have a chance to
leave it he can get his King to G6 it's
not over it is not over and that's the
thing he's very upset with himself but
with Dimitri down to 20 seconds and we
see a rook trade do you trade the Rooks
on C5 and go get 56 but then the Knight
comes back to D3 but you have to do it
it's obviously losing but 18 seconds
it's so hard to handle these positions
when Knights are terrible at stopping
past pawns it's true and Knight takes E5
G5 and then G6 here G5 anyway no Knight
G4 wins that's it very nicely done
oh what a heartbreaker oh he did
everything to win that game and
blundered a piece in one move and he
recognizes I'm doing it as soon as he
played Knight takes C5 he slapped
himself in the head like what am I doing
and well what he has done is made this
an even match three and a half three and
a half and I'm gonna be honest Dania it
feels like Levant should be winning this
match right now I feel like yeah uh the
score does not justify his level of play
I do think he's played better between
these two but Dimitri continues to use
that Mantra Bend but do not break and
even in tough endings he finds good
defensive resources and he is able to
survive
and this could be the last game of the
Met of the segment but probably they're
gonna have enough time for for uh one
more after this one another four night
scotch and this is a very fashionable
line White's currently up two pawns but
Black's gonna win one of them back and
then on the next move he's gonna take
the other one on C6 I think White's
considered a tiny bit better here but
you know both of these players have
analyzed this to exhaustion
you know it is true that White's
considered a smidge better but I believe
that Lavon thinks just equal I mean he's
moving quickly he's played this before I
think even Dimitri believes it's just
equal but that's what we keep saying
about Dimitri on Dragon he doesn't mind
equal openings he just wants to play a
position and that could be bad for him
if he's down in the match but if it's
even it's great because he is not going
to be distracted or upset that he
doesn't probably something out of the
opening he's just playing
he's just playing and he's playing with
relatively little risk I think he wants
to keep this match tied after the
five-minute portion if possible which is
again as I mentioned at the start a
successful result for him he would love
to get this into the bullet with a tied
score
he certainly would and for Dimitri
spending a little bit of time here just
trying to find a way to cause black some
problems but I don't think there is a
problem to be had I just think C6 drops
and right now and now the pawn structure
is exactly the same except for this Palm
being on F3 so the bishop B2 is strong
but the E3 square is a little bit of a
vulnerability especially if black gets
Knight D5 it yeah this this just seems
like a very colorless position of the
symmetrical structure no targets for
either side I think White's advantages
is purely purely symbolic here and
perhaps even non-existent
maybe a draw for it's forthcoming I was
going to ask you down if we place the
Knight on B6 rather than F6 would you
then take black or would you still think
it's not or maybe even take white well I
don't know I mean if the Knight gets to
C4 in some cases there's a weakness on
the E3 Square so you know maybe a
Dimitri should consider just taking on
F6 and and uh signing the peace treaty
and he does I actually do think that if
the Knight was able to move and black
played Pawn F6 black would just be
better that's the problem with having
one Bishop against a knight when you
have a bishop pair you control both
color complexes one is just one Bishop
you can't it was a bishop on B2 you can
never could control any of the light
squares the Knight would hop around
black is better here according to Asia
bar and I think the reason why is the
more active Queen and where is White's
Queen going if you go Queen E2 in comes
a rook T8 if you leave the queen on D1
Rook d8 with Tempo so it's weird to
think that black is better here when it
seems like oh they're just gonna make a
draw I think Lavon is gonna sit here and
be like I have easy moves to make and I
can play Rook d8 Rook D5 and that Rook
can go to A5 or to H5 with the attack
like this is a position that I think
with King G7 Rook h8 as well white needs
to be very careful
yeah and and lavon's not going to take a
draw here given the time situation given
his objective Advantage at this point
this has not been a successful opening
experiment by by Dimitri it was in their
previous fortnite Scotch game but a nice
strategic modification by Lavon this is
a good example of not being headstrong
and and realizing when something doesn't
work out for you you can make a minor
change still play the same first move
but change up your opening Choice a
little bit
and I like to move Rook D2 here I know
A7 is hanging let's get our pieces on
the second rank which is black seventh
Rank and go after that white king of the
core King G7 will be very safe and Rook
h8 to follow I keep mentioning it
because it's a worthwhile idea to keep
in mind that at some point you want to
slide that Rook from f8 over to the H
file and cause white some serious
problems yep and Lavon trying to figure
out the best way to put pressure he gets
the Rook to D4 instead so I guess he
wants to lift it to H4 your old idea
but how is that how does that work
exactly I don't get that move yeah that
felt
A4 okay but and queen B7
nah Queen C2 is gonna cut it just a draw
nah that is the trail yeah no it and
again it feels like this doesn't seem
all that important hey like he makes a
draw with a black it's a solid result
but he really could have put more
pressure in this game that was a serious
chance there and to be fair both sides
have done this in different games they
just like missed their moments to create
a little bit more pressure
okay it draws a grade which means we
have plenty of time for one more game
and and the score is four to four it is
and you know how I usually hate to draw
for it that one I didn't mind it was
completely even I get it both sides
recognize that uh it's gonna be a draw
with not even just best play with like
the obvious play so I'm okay with that
but here we see an alapin and Daniel we
both love the elephant Sicilian
yeah no it's it's such a practical
opening it's a lot more dangerous than
some people give it credit for and
Sicilian players hate facing it in most
cases right because you don't get the
sharp tactical exchange sacrifices on C3
like you're doing a dragon look at it
it's a closed position here and the one
difference is the D4 square is ultra
defended the D5 square is protected by a
piece rather than a pawn so you can take
on C5 give black an iqp an isolated
Queen pawn and they go Knight B to D2
Knight to B3 and blockade that pawn
Aaron nimsovich would be proud
yeah these types of positions have been
have been known since the dawn of time
and of course black has his own share of
active ideas the bishop can drop back to
C7 pressure H2 the other Bishop will
come out to G4 of course y can play H3
and does but the drawback of that move
is that there's a weak Square on G3 you
have these really cool traps I can
actually show this if we can pull up an
analysis board really quickly or maybe
not he's played Queen D6 okay if white
makes a nonchalant move like rookie one
there's Bishop takes and he did Play
Bishop rookie one and he missed it oh he
played it I'm actually showing this line
and actually Queen G3 straight away
no it's not Queen G3 straight away but
my idea is after Bishop H3 GH Queen G3
check can be very dangerous
after King H1 Bishop takes F2 it's on
the board
I can't believe this
I was just showing a purely hypothetical
possibility and they're actually playing
it is this some kind of line okay I
think I've seen lines like it's on the
board but I feel like I've seen lines
like this in the E4 E5 variations but
not like this
but the thing is it's actually not as
good for black as it looks I think most
people would just assume black is
winning but he's not there there's no
mate here so did Lavon kind of goad him
into it tricked him a little bit like I
think oh no I blundered Bishop takes H3
and queen G3 and it's like oh okay
actually it's just better for white
because Queen H3 check the Knight drops
back to H2 and even though Bishop to G3
looks like you're about to pile on the
pen piece white can bring the queen up
to E2 defend bring the queen to G2 and
then we get three pawns against a bishop
and that's about even in terms of
material value but with so many pieces
on the board the I think the minor
pieces outclass the Pawns
and the the pawns are all on the king
side and they can actually be targeted
by White's pieces uh you could position
a rook country one later and it's weird
to talk about white attacking on the
king side that sounds absurd but if the
Smoke Clears that is precisely what's
going to happen Knight F5 Dimitri
involves another piece but the White
Knight drops back to H2 and forget you
know the three pieces three pawns for
the piece first of all Dimitri has to be
careful not to lose another minor piece
on the king side I think what's gonna
happen or I feel like after Queen H4
just opening up the G3 Square for the
Knight you we may see a position where
black gets a rook and two pawns for a
couple minor pieces but still the minor
pieces are better uh than the rook in a
couple pawns because there's a weak Pawn
on D5 in the long term uh there are
Targets in Black's position so I I think
that Queen H4 here is Nessa Queen H3
blunder is the bishop one F2 that
defeats the whole purpose that's the
only move Queen H4 with Knight G3 check
to follow I think gets that exchange but
you've already given a piece for two
pawns so I do think that that's why
white is better um it's a really
difficult position to assess but the Eva
bar steadily claiming white with the
advantage
it's important to point out that Knight
H4 tempting as it may seem runs into
Queen takes D5 then the queen can swing
over to G5 forcing the queen trade and
you know melting Black's uh activity on
the king side straight away Dimitri
though it concerns me that he hasn't
played Queen H4 yet he has to find this
move or he loses yes and well he I mean
he didn't he thought Bishop takes A3 is
good and then he's here and he's like oh
no this is not as good as I hoped it
would be and that now he's in big
trouble I mean Lavon has only spent 42
seconds plus a few because he's gained
some time out from the increment but he
is in charge here oh Queen F3 and he
didn't play it Rook 88 ah but Queen F3
he'll trade Queens by Knight G3 check
that's his idea I guess
yeah so now it's lavon's turn to take a
little think actually Queen F3 if we
extend that line though oh Black's gonna
lose both the bishop and the Knight and
Levon sees it I did not see it but good
call by you partner the point is that
you get the Rook on F1 sure but instead
of taking the Knight back on F1 um take
that Bishop on F2 I mean we can show
that position quickly because it's not
gonna happen uh yeah yeah it's really
good fine by you actually Dimitri might
have to move his Bishop here to preserve
some chances he also might resign but
after Knight G3 King G2 you can see the
evil bar shooting up you might say well
two pieces for Rook doesn't seem that
bad King takes F2 where are you going
with that Knight nowhere you're gonna
lose it and three pieces for a rook is
unplayable this is completely losing
Dimitri grabbing his head there
with a minute left on the match clock
does it make sense to resign here and
get another game underway I don't think
so I think you should try to resist this
and he's dropping now down to a minute
and he is going to take and move his
Bishop back and try to seek his Fortunes
in this piece down position it's not
totally over though he's got two pawns
he's got some activity Lavon still has
to demonstrate some finesse here uh to
pull off this full point yeah look at
zipli's believe it or not saying Levon
is a Savage Levon please believe we're
not playing a great game of chess here
uh but what I will say you ask the
question could to be to resign get
another game Dimitri wants the shorter
time control so even if yeah the
position was completely lost he doesn't
want to start that last game in five
plus one he's not scared he's not gonna
be here because oh no another game
against levada Ronin they both have so
much respect for each other but I think
ultimately he prefers being in the
shorter time controls because Lavon has
been a little dicey in time scrambles
but there's no guarantee that Levon even
wins this game
no because especially now that rookie
two is I feel like Dimitri has improved
his position in the last couple moves he
has
for sure and we just got to count the
material right you have two pawns for a
piece and that's just a one point
Advantage if we think about the material
like that and as you're highlighting
rookie two check at some point is a
pretty big threat right now just to uh
remove the defender of the G3 Bishop
I think though with the clock situation
lavon's still the heavy favorite to win
this game uh because the Bishop from B5
can drop back to D3 and set in motion
the chain of events which is going to
lead to the trade of at least one pair
of Brooks which greatly relieves the
pressure on White's position
for sure there is some an interesting
element here that if or when on Dragon
takes on G3 we could get some opposite
colored Bishops and now we you know you
used to think of opposite color Bishops
being a draw but when you have a
material imbalance actually the side
that has in this case the extra Knight
for a couple pawns it'll be good for
that side because the bishop can start
attacking Black's pawns and then Black's
Bishop will not be able to defend in
fact in the game uh between a car and
Nakamura and Nordic abducotaro from the
Tata steel rapper that's going on it was
something similar whereas obstacle
Bishops but it helped Nordic win the
game having those obstacle Bishops uh
and he had a yeah for a couple Pawns and
Dimitri trying to squeeze as much
activity out of his pieces as possible
he doesn't take on E1 he tries to trade
on his own terms but Lavon can now play
Rook to E1 he probably will
and uh you're right I mean it those
those minor piece positions aren't that
easy to win
and here we go
um you get five you could think about
taking on C6 and then by 93 and B4 and
A4 but it's a committal choice the good
thing for Lavon his clock time
management superb in this game and if
Bishop takes C6 wins he will spend the
next minute plus calculating it and he
says ah no let's just go for the move
yeah he plays Knight T3 instead
activating his Knight I'm really
concerned about this D5 pawn it might be
worth playing D4 in some positions but
that gives white the pawn majority of
the three on two uh with with C4 so 12
seconds left I don't see Dimitri pulling
this off in the long run I I think
though he's gonna play King F7 King F6
Bishop C7 things like that
he starts and Lavon might go Bishop A4
to B3
there's still Bishop C7 there it's the
pin that he might be right
yeah this ain't easy it's it's
surprising I mean you're a piece up but
everything's sort of defended and after
King F6 you're ready to play G5 and keep
the pawns going
and if you start trading off a bunch of
Pawns you might have enough material
remaining to win even if you start
stealing some of black two pawns that
you're down so this is a big moment for
Lavon here he really wants to get this
win but how to continue Knight F3 is met
by the simple King F6 just keeping the
Knight out of the black position and
then Black's ready to go G5
yeah that ambulance might have been
coming for White's winning chances here
I don't I mean I like 94 though
yeah nice blockading solid move
important enough to try to play Hero
ball
yeah it's almost Checkmate by the way
but there's King H6 and Knight can go to
episode
and then oh my God there's like Knight
G8 check which is a threat after Knight
F6
can you believe that there's a knight d8
F7 one second Knight F6 threatens Maiden
two
wow Knight G8 and the Knight G7
that is sickness beautiful
it's over you're gonna get mated
cannoli it's mate this is
how oh the king runs the age of four now
but I I think you can just play just
take on G5 just take the pawn and King
G4 look at this domination well done
Lavon taking all of the pots here
Dimitri's gonna resign
okay it's over Knight takes G5 yeah and
it's over it means you kind of grabbed
his face kind of like you know let me
just forget about this one let's wash
let's wash ourselves from the sin of
this game but what a performance from
Lavon aronian I mean it is five to four
after nine games so he has the one point
lead but I was saying earlier and I'm
gonna say it again I feel like if I we
look across those nine games Lavon
probably has missed some chances more
than Demetrius
yeah Lavon with a major dose of nasty in
this five minute segment but the good
news for Dimitri I mean it was a
torturous long 90 minutes for him but he
manages to keep this match close I mean
it didn't get out of control he
exploited enough chances to keep it
close and he's got to be feeling really
happy given the momentum and just
generally the feel of the match that he
can tie it in the very next game in
which he'll have the white pieces and a
shortened time control which is
definitely in his favor true and Lavon
should be feeling happy and well
speaking of happy happy holidays to
everybody we just had Thanksgiving here
the US team made it through in the world
cup so we're very happy we're also very
happy to offer you this limited time
offer it's your last chance to cash in
on this incredible limited time offer to
upgrade your chess.com account to
premium membership and get one month of
Premium free you heard that right
chess.com is increasing the free trial
of Premium from seven days to an entire
month simply go to our website and
upgrade to get your free month that's
one month of unlimited game review
puzzles lessons and a cute little Emoji
next to your username for free but Act
Fast the offer ends today drop the
command claim in the chat for details
and directions we'll be right back for
more from the speeches championship
match between the monoronian and Dimitri
on draken in just a few
[Music]
my name is Ethan Curry
you know we all have nicknames
Chicago is naturally where I'm born and
raised so that's how I got the name I
guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion I'm always looking
for a good fight you know evidently
it'll make a difference man this
Checkmate coming up it don't matter
what we're trying to do is to let them
know hey we playing down here in Houston
Texas
if you come down here help step in trust
me we're going to beat you you better
bring your game
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
a storm is brewing you're never going to
beat hikarados on game not in these
positions within the Tempest the best
have come to test their skills and brave
the storm oh we missed it
oh my goodness the wheels the wheels
have come out that could be the magic
for some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness 98 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fab
i electric that is
dagger the moves will be fast oh my God
no 97
tricked at the end the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
and we return to the speed chess
championship match between levonne Ronin
and Dimitri on draken I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me my good friend
Grandmaster Daniel narodisky Dania 5-4
lead for Levon aronian now the players
and ourselves just got a break what do
you think Dimitri has to change to even
up the score once more
well first of all I'm curious where he's
gonna go opening wise he's been all over
the map with both colors E4 D4 with
white Sicilian E5 Berlin with black so I
think he's got to make a couple of
decisions about you know where he's most
successful so that's one area he can
make some improvements and then just
some of his early middle game decision
making he seems to be steering a lot of
these games in lavon's Direction a
couple of questionable choices like that
time he didn't play he takes F4 Robert
In the Sicilian game so I think a little
bit of a crisper decision making could
go a long way for him as well well we
are ought to reach the shorter time
controls and smarter chess did make some
predictions about this match and levonne
Roni was a 75 favorite according to whoa
stats but I cannot believe what I'm
seeing in the quicker time control big
lead for Iranian predicted to him and
also win in bullet Donya something feels
off about that to me
that's a very bold prediction and Lavon
there were a couple of games where he
was playing really quickly in the
opening a middle game we see that he
knows what a pre-move is he's capable of
playing fast I can see where smarter
chess is coming from but that is a
minable prediction I definitely don't
agree with that especially in the bullet
yeah I think we're not trying to not
that I ever agree with it well I don't
think we're trying to say that Lavon
isn't a Powerhouse but Dimitri on draken
yeah he's won how many title Tuesdays I
think the answer is 10 since February of
2022. so he knows how to win three plus
one when it counts and he is about to
make it count against levona Ronin or at
least hope to because he is dead one
point as the games get underway
the games will get underway and I think
Dimitri will have the white pieces
in game one is that correct that is
correct you just lost with black in the
last game and here we go here we go
Knight F3 another it's still different
first by Dimitri he's now played D4 E4
and now King's Indian attack
and he just wants to play something calm
at least that's what I believe because
uh he doesn't want to tilt it's hard to
tilt him to begin with uh but that kind
of crazy positions we saw that in game
one in the global championship against
Wesley so he had a dominant game he was
completely winning and he didn't put it
away I think he just prefers a position
just like what he's getting a slight
Plus for white where he feels like he
has no risk
when you say he starts until that is not
an exaggeration I was watching uh his uh
titled Arena stream a while ago and he
lost a very painful game he like gets
flagged in a night versus night position
and then the next game he plays a couple
of moves and then he plays the move H5
and he says let's convince our opponent
that we're tilted Let's Pretend let's
pretend that we're tilted I was gonna
say I would play H5 because I was
actually tilted but Dimitri was just
pretending to tilt he is incredibly
level-headed and that goes a long way in
the SEC matches just ask Jana punishing
that was below the belt sorry I wasn't
expecting that you know that Finishing
Touch there but uh yeah it it's true
though I mean and here we see that B6
was played and Dimitri was Rook a to C1
this A5 that's not a move I was
expecting but Daniel left field how
quickly Lavon played it I feel like he
knows this position the ins and outs
that was literally at our left field yes
that really stopped me five
so yeah and I guess A4
now who does this benefit I mean one
would say optically white because the
pawn on B6 is now a very serious
long-term weakness think about a bishop
landing on D4 on the other hand so are
the pawns on C4 and A4 maybe they're
harder to attack but they're still weak
I would say the position probably is
equal
and I'm looking so with the eval bar
which is more important I would love to
get this knight from F6 to C5 if I were
live on but that's never going to happen
you can't play Knight D7 because the
Knight C6 is loose and if you take on d8
right now with the Rook maybe Dimitri's
idea is Knight D5 to C7 just go after
that Bishop I was thinking the exact
same thing and then if you have to play
Bishop D7 The Rook could slide into D1
there's gonna be tactics based on those
minor pieces H3 I feel like Dimitri has
played this move on more than one
occasion and unexpected no levonne was
the one who played H3 in game one when
we weren't expecting he announced
Dimitri's turn yeah H3 over here it
seems kind of random it's not a bad move
obviously uh but it doesn't create any
threats and maybe that's what Dimitri is
suggesting that he doesn't need to
create threats because black has this
loose Pawn on B6 as you mentioned he
played C5 so he's just trying to open up
a square of Luft I mean we I said I love
you earlier and now he's getting left
for the kids
well I love Loft yeah
okay enough enough I'm digging myself
into a serious hole here yeah you're all
good knight D5 cuts off the bishop on G2
you can also head to B6 to attack A4 and
then B4 square is black under black
Central just like the B5 score under
whites control and what is going on with
this Queen side tension done it's given
me a bit of a headache
could we even say that with H3 his
Ambitions are a bit lofty or lofty oh no
you didn't have to go there did you
I couldn't just let it go that's that's
my my great great sin you don't gotta
hold it back anymore but you asked the
question I'm supposed to answer it what
is happening on the queen side yeah it's
a head-spinning arrangement of minor
pieces I think largely the battle
revolves around who will be able to
attack each other's weaknesses on the
APO on the a file maybe white can drop
the Knight back to B3 he goes Knight B7
oh my God they're so easy to blunder
here you could also get Robert a mutual
liquidation after Knight takes A5 and
that basically means straw maybe a
smidge better for a white dude to the
bishop air but not anything significant
yeah I would definitely take white in
that position uh and white has the
bishop pair and blacks and knights can
be kicked around at some point with the
E2 to E4 things of that nature and I
believe that you know especially that
looks like oh just a draw all the pawns
on one side of the board but looks can
be deceiving and I actually think it's
not that easy for Block to hold a
position like that
no you're right and and there's also
Rook C8 check which could come at an
inopportune moment for black
okay what's Dimitri thinking about yeah
is he thinking about Bishop takes D5 no
no way he takes B5 cooler heads prevail
and what's Lavon thinking about I was
gonna ask you the same thing right we're
about yeah exactly good because B5 is
just hanging
I guess Knight A2 is a move but I don't
think it is a move even Rook A1 yeah
Rook C2 something like that just
attacking the Knight so lavon's been on
wake up valuable time here and he I
think he will ultimately played Rook
takes B5 but Rook CA check in Knight C4
and there's a bishop pair
and it's a minute extra for Dimitri on
Drake and if you can get away with Rook
C5 you definitely would like to get a
pair of Rooks off the board but you got
to calculate all the ramifications you
know there's Bishop D5 and there's E4
and you can easily lose a minor piece in
the blink of an eye Lavon down to 18
seconds he does play Rook C5 and if he
can get away with this then I think
he'll have enough time to draw right but
I think as you were pointing out Dimitri
can take out C5 take on D5 e takes D5
will be forced from LeBron isolated upon
not the end of the world but definitely
not desirable so I think with the time
the way it is this is how you win games
when you're playing such a strong player
you just need to put pressure on the
clock
and he was trying to induce F5
after which I think he would have
followed up with that line instead Levon
makes less of a king side weakness I
like the move G6 The Rook trade happens
and continues to poke in prod
staying on top for now well Bishop takes
D5 I would just definitely take the
Knight to seven you can win a pawn Oh by
force this is really good take D5 97
take on B4 and go Knight F6 check very
forcing sequence and here it comes which
is which is why Lavon should have put
his King on G7 to cover that square and
Dimitri is not going to miss that and
that this is a great winning chance
given levon's clock these are hard hard
end games to defend I would say pretty
good winning chance even classical chess
but when you have 12 seconds on your
clock good luck to you just King G2 you
can push your Pawn slowly but surely and
then just try to figure out where your
knight belongs
and it's so easy to blunder into a
situation like Knight F6 check right you
go one way you blunder the bishop you go
other way you blunder the pawn
but Dimitri instead focusing on fixing
the pawn on H6 if you can get black to
play H5 and create another weakness
that's basically game over
okay but the king for black can go to G5
at some point like right now
well gotta be careful not to get mated
there on H4
and Knight D5 King E5 bring the Knight
back some or I mean up to B6 just yeah
so many people worried that Lavon will
blunder a trade or or a fork Bishop C7
okay it was up to B4
if I'm Dimitri I'm just making quick
moves
F4
and try to induce F5 if you can induce
F5 then you can start worming your
knight around you can try to torture
Lavon indefinitely here one second five
huge moment F5 you can't bring your
kingdom oh F5 you gotta go to D6 but now
the Knight worms its way to the king
side and here you can attack the h-bomb
that's what I mentioned Knight G4 forces
H5 and I just goes back you just keep
attacking the pawn
Knight F2 infinite waves of attack now
try to get the Knight over to F4 but
Lavon squeezing his King into F6 to
restrict the Knight further
oh E4 E5 is a demon Bishop C1 was a
great move because Knight E5 or G5 and
Bishop takes either his check
now back to D6 not anymore five
oh the problem for the white king is it
wants to stay on F4 but if that's going
to E4 then black was King G5 King H4 qg5
and I guess he wants Knight F3 but now
how do you reshuffle your pieces
beats oh
maybe H4 at the right moment and he
plays it
oh Bishop six now
not in Bishop E1 it should be one's
great
okay lavon's making great progress here
and he's got no time he's barely getting
these moves off I know he's gonna flag
if he continues this
oh he's moving he's getting it done he's
got three seconds now Knight D3 and E5
coming qg3 and King G3 E5 now Dimitri
making progress
ah
now it's winning Knight F4
a knight of four is just winning right
an E6 now we're
I don't know no bishopy white boy he
Blended people under the pawn
oh my gosh and every E6 you swap
and now Levon doesn't have to do
anything because E6 you take one pawn
and then you give the bishop up for the
other Pawn but he gives up the H Pawn
for free
his King's the perfect place for Lavon
that's why he gave up the pawn he wants
his King in front of what's going to be
a passport there's a night sack on F7
but that never works the bishop is is
good enough to restrain the pawns
Dimitri will still try here but he might
be out of winning chances and look at
Levon because Bishop A1 Bishop B2 stay
away from that Knight don't Mouse slip
and where does the Knight need to go to
be tricky Knight C4 now Bishop C3 oh
King it's a very good move Knight D6
check the problem is always hanging
exactly so you can only give one check
and then you have to immediately go back
he's trying to restrict the bishop but
you actually can't cover all three
squares at once which is funny and we
just passed the century mark move 101 is
is just about to be played here two
seconds left for the fun he's gotta keep
playing quickly
E6 at some moment when LeBron is least
expecting it
he's thinking his internet service
provider Lavon keeping time on the clock
Dimitri has made no progress here
no there's just no way
oh Bishop going back unless his Bishop
or he's pretty much and E6 happens
this might be a repetition you have to
try E6 at some point like right now
just play it nothing to lose or just go
and take on F7 right go like Knight D6
check and take on F7 right the funny
thing is had Dimitri flagged he would
have lost because Lavon still hasn't
have fun and it's a draw wow and Dimitri
wow so that's one of those games where I
kept saying before I feel like LaVon had
more missed opportunities now Dimitri
misses a huge opportunity there he was
heading the clock he was up a pawn he
actually found a winning position but
then just when he had the win in his
grasp he blunders the H4 Pawn
immediately allowing Levon to survive
we won't go back because it's a little
bit too technical I think the move there
was F6 and he blundered the H Pawn with
Knight F4 to D5 he had to keep his
Knight on F4 and prepare to break
through with this with his Pawn majority
yeah a huge miss that game took 11
minutes off the match clock and that was
a three minute game okay look at this
they're repeating their their French
type structure but this time Dimitri
improving with Knight F5 and I think
that is a better move than the sack on
H3 oh for sure he said fool me once all
right you know you got it you took that
dub but you're not gonna get me again
that's what we talked about sometimes
when you have a good position out of the
opening you keep trying it and trying
and trying it then when you go for the
sacrifice that you think is good and it
just gets uh rebuffed very quickly
you're like nope never ever again he
learned his lesson but this position is
going to be a lesson in blockading and
isolated Pawn because white has Knights
on B3 and F3 you have to watch out for
Knight H4 I don't think it works just
yet but black might use them with Knight
H4 to distract an nf3 from defending the
H2 Square so just keep an eye out on
this battery on the diagonal
yeah no it's always dangerous especially
if you can combine it with a timely like
rookie a to cover the king's Escape
Square to E2 and guess what not
something that white does easily giving
up the bishop pair in an open board
situation is good for black now don't
miss Bishop C5 if you're Dimitri and of
course he doesn't what a surprise
actually doesn't miss a one move tactic
no I I was gonna say Bishop E4 so I was
about to miss it
I'm honest but I'm glad you pointed it
out Knight D4 let's trade some Knights
but the problem for white is after
Knight D4 you really want to play Knight
takes 24 but then there's Queen H2 check
so you're not getting that and this is a
long term Plus for white even though
black is better right now that sounds
like it doesn't make sense but if white
is somehow able to Stave off the
pressure on the diagonal and if you
trade the Queens then white is already
better but that's such a long ways away
so I think LeBron in Bishop B4 nasty
idea sorry no no you're it's a really
good point I'm think saying Lavon is
playing for this long-term prospects but
in the current position it's just good
for a Dimitri with the activity and
speaking of long-term prospects if you
can force white to play G3 very likely
now uh that Lavon will play that move
then White's got long-term promise on
the king side as well and black doesn't
have to necessarily just Bank on you
know one idea working out now it should
be pointed out that Bishop takes F3 at
this point is not a serious threat but
Levon is tired of it he's tired of
having to deal with the check on H2 and
he says Hey I'm don't care I'm going to
make some weaknesses at least I can
breathe a little bit easier for the time
being yeah it makes his next moves
easier and Dimitri's next one's harder
because you can go out for this H3 Pawn
sure but the white king wants to go to
H2 anyway the pawn F2 is very well
defended and now the knight in F3 can go
to D4 where it belongs so here after
Queen D7 Knight D whoa two played whoa
I don't like the look of that move yeah
why is it retreating
now his idea was that Queen takes H3
there would would have been Knight takes
C4 and then a check on D5 but that's not
the problem with the move the problem is
just that it's very passive yeah yeah
unnecessarily so and he still has the
blockade going on that's the good news
Queen F3 is possible here just to bring
some more pieces to the king side but if
your knight ever leaves the D2 square
and your Knight's not good on D2 then
the black Bishop can just slide right
back into E4 or queen to H3 and before
you know it there could be a Checkmate
so look at Demetrius poking and prodding
in all directions and I think for Lavon
he needs to find a plant
yeah Queen B5 knifing his way into the
queen side but the Knight meets the
Queen at the top that does yield the E4
Square you always point this out once
squares defended one door closes another
opens there's a lot of open doors on the
king side here for black
I think he's going Knight D2 back now
like Knight D2 Bishop's Queen F3 and
then black and black queen B5 and then
we're just going on a Merry-Go-Round
back and forth to the same position so
uh here Knight D2 looks kind of forced
and then first of all time situation
very bad for Lavon and in some
situations black could even give away
the light squared Bishop Knight D2 Queen
H3 is not out of the question Knight
takes C4 Rook takes C4 oh King H2 but
now the H4 Pawn is still vulnerable due
to the PIN
but how do you get your queen over there
right Queen to H5 Queen to G4 not
available because the Queen's on E2
perfectly placed so it's a little
frustrating to have this position as
black you know there's something there
but proving it is a whole different
story and he puts F5 and F4
why not closing down the bishop and
Lavon says Hey the bishop on E3 it's
well enough protected by my heavy pieces
I'll move my queen away I'll still have
the D4 Square I like how lavon's
handling his defensive chask so far and
he's gonna play around the bishop on e4
he's gonna use the D4 Square uh he might
want to trade dark Square Bishops at
some point but if the Queens come off
the board black is in big trouble
because the light Square Bishop it's
staring Into Thin Air not attacking
anything and so I feel like again now
Dimitri is doing well but with a couple
trades if he's able to make those trades
happen then that's what Lavon is banking
on but I like Dimitri's Rook lift maybe
Rook H6 and just threatening G5 yeah oh
my gosh I didn't see that that's a
massive threat a massive there a knight
F3 bottle of on can you take and play G5
taken G5 the idea of course FG Rook
takes H4 check again using that pin and
then sliding it over to G4 and attacking
G3 dangerous ideas here but Dimitri now
down to 30 seconds as he struggles to
calculate these lines good tactical
Vision by you with the G5 idea it's so
hard to think about that with a knight
and two pawns and a bishop staring at
the G5 Square Dimitri misses it all
together and I just don't think it's his
type of position but queen queen G5
Queen City G5 and Rook H4 almost works
and then Bishop takes three and oh what
an idea yeah he said what is this not my
type of position he actually was lining
this up and is there Bishop G3 or
or do you go Rook H1 and Rook H2 you
have a draw in your pocket you do he
takes on G3 which is wait apparently
that's wrong why King F1 and Bishop G1
oh my goodness what oversight and what a
find by Lavon
oh my God that's so easy to miss sliding
the bishop back because just by F4 F3
just like throw your pieces forward you
don't have a lot of time neither players
H2 but now I think the queen can move
back to D1 there's Bishop G2 check oh
gosh wait I would just go Bishop F2
maybe no I don't know this is really
tricky right now I think Bishop F2 might
be the move
or oh he doesn't want to do that that's
clear but Bishop F2 is like
there's Queen B5 attack
I didn't see that square actually what
about still so dangerous really good
move though because Rook H1 Bishop G1
you block everything and Rook takes C4
for sure Rook takes E4 right now we're
still not out of the woods tg2 queen D5
check take on e4 that's a big Pawn to
win oh my God and if you had started
with Queen D5 you would have allowed F3
oh Dimitri springing one last drop two
seconds for Lavon he finds Queen D5 to
take the pawn here's Rook F1
no Queen 64 there was F3 check oh he
might make a draw Rook G4 back
maybe
six he attacks the tail of the discovery
and he takes him he's still winning no
good discover check King goes F3 Bishop
D4 now all of his pieces are out oh now
he's completely winning Dimitri's gonna
flag and Rook H6 now throwing the
Checkmate Dimitri losing time levada
somehow wins a game where his King was
caught in the crosshairs of a vicious
attack but Dimitri on draken couldn't
find the right continuation
what a brilliant Queen Sacrifice by
Dimitri but Robert it does turn out that
he should have given that check on H2
and probably just taken lavon's Queen
back and played that exchange down end
game where his Bishops would have
constituted a big Advantage what a
defensive effort by one guess what that
bodes so well for his bullet chances the
fact that he demonstrated this ability
to defend that position with two seconds
left are you kidding me Levon is a
genius I think weirdly it bodes well for
both of their chances Dimitri on
Dragon's showing he's willing to get
into a tactical melee and actually
outclass Lavon for a stretch of that
tactical sequence and lavon's saying I'm
down to get to two seconds left and
still Fight Quest and Knight takes D5
another tactical shot this time by
Dimitri Andreas there's A6 at the end
what is this
is this Mickey all tall or is this
Dimitri on Drake and what an idea I mean
that is just so ridiculous out of
nowhere who has he become we were
talking all match he's solid he plays
positional he goes away from tactics and
he said you don't know me at all and
maybe Lavonia is you know you only know
where they say like
um you know I could handle once you get
punched in the face I don't remember the
exact expression but that's what it
feels like is happening here on draken
is showing you know when he needs to
find the tactics he will and now he just
swaps on d8 plays A6 don't think it
matters but the Rook on eight is loose
and Dimitri andrekin showing off his
tactical might
and move on in serious trouble because
there's gonna be a b and the Knight C5
to knock the bishop out of B7 then the
knight's gonna be undefended but if
you're Dimitri don't take on D.A first
because then the knight's gonna drop
back take back and defend the pawn on B7
I think you need to play a B and Knight
C5 with the Queens still on the board
you can see though Dimitri shaking his
head that's kind of like when you know
Steph Curry hits It's a three after
missing a couple and then he starts
shaking his head because he expects
himself to win every game Dimitri Stills
that last game still stings but what a
recovery thus far in this game oh he is
just cruising down this h1a8 diagonal
and I looked it up it's everyone has a
plan until they get punched in the face
so that's a Mike Tyson quote but here I
I just don't know what levada ronian you
know can do here because a takes B7 well
at the very least win the piece back and
right now white has two extra pawns and
look at this just
you just like Bishop back to somewhere
oh but if you're not careful if you play
Bishop G2 there might be Knight E4 but
the 86 B7 so you do have that move
available
now you could take first which he does
and now drop the bishop back obviously
don't take on B7
yeah LeBron's losing his P spec no
question about that how can he get the
most out of you know the two Tempe that
he has
is it Knight D4 is it Knight E4 I guess
I don't know Knight D4 the drawbacks
Bishop takes B7 and A7 will fall
so start with Rook C8 and then go Knight
D4 he does go Knight E4 so he's gonna
play against this Knight on B7
okay and then Knight D4 now how so your
idea he plays Knight D4 second because
he gets to keep the A7 Pawn in this
variation black is down two pawns but
clearly getting one back would you take
on e4 here would you ah it's kind of
complicated
it's kind of thorny actually because
White's pieces are pretty
discombobulated you know it's like white
has done all of this and suddenly the
rest of the pieces have been on vacation
this whole time and Knight takes E2
check followed by Knight takes C1 it's a
real threat with B2 being loose so it
feels like white is in danger of not
being able to keep even a single Pawn
lead and that's not good news for
Dimitri on drinking as he tries to cut
his deficit in half
yeah and he's sinking into a deep think
here has to contain the activity of the
knights there's also some mating ideas
when Knight takes E2 and Knight takes F2
you've got to be careful about
I don't know Bishop F3 might be the way
oh Bishop 3 is clever he plays E3 but
now Knight E2 takes C1 and then you play
Rook B8 and take B2 with your Rook I
feel like it's just gonna be a one Pawn
lead and I say just as if that's not
important but I feel like LaVon is
putting up very good defense
yeah two games now Dimitri has Uncorked
some brilliant tactical ideas but then
he suddenly looks up and you know he's
only up upon in this case but here I
still think he's got great winning
chances if he can keep the tension up
right no it is true and you know as the
famous quote says the hardest game to
win is a one game and uh this position
has never been winning absolutely for
andrekin but he's had a great position
in this one and now Rook a takes C1 B2
is going to fall you take with a rook
you play Rook B8 move the Knight and
then take on B2 no he says let me take
the bishop and watch out if Levon can
push that pawn to A5 we already see the
compensation but that's why Dimitri will
probably stop that pawn in his tracks
and it's such a dangerous tandem the
bishop on G7 controlling the promotion
Square coupled with the a pawn which if
it lands on A4 or A3 spells major
trouble so I would be seriously
considering a blockading maneuver which
is exactly what Dimitri does Rook before
attacking four and potentially bring it
to A4 preventing the progress of the
apron but Robert Rook B8 has to be
reckoned with pinning the Knight
but I think maybe the other Rook to be
it was also available
um just to keep your Rook behind the
a-pawn but he goes work ABA it's still a
good decision and after Rook B3 Now The
Rook is defended the Knight can move and
so Levon leaves the B file so C2 is a
clear Target but so is E4
and you could play Knight D6 and
exchange these two pawns you could oh
you can't play Rook C1 because then F2
hangs he does play Knight T6 still good
winning chances he's got to pull this
one out does Dimitri on draken I feel
like the winning chance are huge in this
game like Rook B7 bringing Rook to A7 K8
Knight to G5 at some moment
I'll bring the other Rook to D7 maybe
you'll have mating ideas before you know
it Knight G5 right now and on the
knights under attack threatening 96
Accord Knight F7 check
down to 10 seconds
Rook C6 maybe he plays it good call by
you Rook D1 oh wait
no I was thinking about it it's I clear
I blundered F2 but I guess it was okay
but
Knight E4 Eve
yeah
but Dimitri is doing very well though is
he's taking his time look at this he
wants Knight F4 Pawn H4 Rook D1 things
like that
oh maybe G5
merited some consideration to at least
try to temporarily restrict the Knight
now the Knight is running amok you're
right and kicking the bishop away from
the A5 Pawn you go Bishop G7 use A5 but
the bishop here does not defend the king
so now it's time to throw your pawns
forward if you're Dimitri on draken and
a nice little prophylactic in the middle
there to defend F2 but Levant ties
himself to perhaps White's last
remaining weakness trying to get this
Rook to stay on F1 he's got one second
though and he's gonna flag I think he's
gonna flag well not yet drops another
Pawn it's over yeah he's walking into a
pin left and right problems Galore 96
check this game and so is that winning
on time is Dimitri on draken he deserved
that game with a beautiful tactic on the
long diagonal and now it's six and F5
and a half so Dimitri on drinking
Strikes Back
Dimitri on Drake and heard from under
pressure
that was impressive that was flat out
impressive he didn't lose his cool when
Lavon generated that counter play and
let's not forget Knight takes D5 and A6
just a brilliant tactical idea right out
of the opening and Lavon deviating
from the open Sicilian with a 3b3 I
actually play that line quite a bit
Robert it's more interesting that people
give a credit for it is as you can see
as you can see already castle and queen
side D4 striking in the center and where
is that black king going that's the big
question and look at Levon H4 playing on
the flank he can do a rook lift he can
play Pawn to H5 first you can play G4 at
some moment I wouldn't do that just yet
with the bishop on B7 slicing across the
diagonal but the point is H6 now serves
as a hook and so you can throw your
pawns off the board
yup and Dimitri with his favorite idea
A6 and B5 he's played it in the Berlin
this is now a little bit of a more
appropriate occasion to push the pawn to
B5
I feel like
Levant is tempting Dimitri a little bit
too much right because Dimitri likes to
play quiet solid games but this is still
very solid not a single Pawn has been
traded and Black's Foundation is better
than white so it's a pawn stick on E5
there's a pawn stay on H5 black just
played C4 ready to break open the queen
side and G7 is defended from that Bishop
108 Knight before could be a threat I
feel like this is very dangerous
territory for Lavon and you can't say
he's tilting after just a single loss
but this just feels like why did he
change his opening he's been getting
pretty decent yeah again if it ain't
broke don't fix it but Dimitri's attack
that started up faster than a Ferrari
accelerating on a freeway I mean that
went zero to 100 in literally three
moves real quick
yeah C4 Bishop A3 Grand Prix attack
style night before and ugh no you're
being you know I don't really like to
complement you but you've done a great
job
referencing other openings it does feel
like a Grand Prix attack just throwing
your Pawn forward against a king that's
already castled and so nice two
compliments in one commentary I know
maybe to watch yourself you might even
get a third slipping if you keep up this
Behavior but A3 and then maybe there's
B4 for white at some moment you could
take on C4 actually because the Rook on
G3 is so well placed oh it's defending
A3 yes defending A3 so bc4 opens that
Rook up and maybe The Rook will slide to
B3 after bc4 bc4 we've blundered it and
he plays it
and Dimitri blundered that move I'm I'm
positive he forgot the Rook was
defending A3 and you can't blame him how
often does a rook on G3 depend upon an
A3 in a sicilian and I was just saying
maybe uh he's tempting uh Dimitri into
sort of tactical Waters maybe he's
luring him there like this is Levon
aronian he's a frustrating player to
compete against because he's so strong
and he makes moves like Knight B3 his
Queen's under attack you expect the
queen to move he quickly plays Knight to
B3 and what attack does black have there
is no attack everything is defended on
the queen side he's simply up a pawn and
actually his King is quite safe and
Black's King is nowhere to go
yeah so impressive how Lavon has beefed
up the security on the queen side just
dropping a couple minor pieces in there
and driving the queen out of A5 now as
you said no attack to be found and guess
what White's gonna start things up on
the king side here maybe bishop D3 and
then drive the F Pawn up to F5 things
could get just as just as bad just as
fast as they did on the queen side
this suddenly looks terrible for black I
mean we were just horrible
complimenting his position thinking
things were good he was C4 he just I
think completely missed that Rook on the
third rank that Rook that was lifted up
there was defending the queen side and
that's why Rook lifts are so powerful
it's not just going for an attack which
is uh what you normally think of a real
clip but it just covers the entire uh
file excuse me the entire rank pardon me
and it did just that in this position
and now it's also take on G7
and you can also play yeah what is he
doing just take on Jesus he's going
Bishop G5 and G5 he wants to trap The
Rook okay so I'm
I'm appreciating it a little more now
are you gonna set up a sack on G5 but
that's not that good because then the
queen comes out and also prevents F4
oh
goes after the night
but nice I don't know what the move is
here Knight F4 Knight H5 so I think
Bishop D3 develops and if king of Fate
now we'll take on G5 and then he'll get
an outside pass pawn and dark score
domination
and you have ideas like Knight C5 now
you're absolutely right the fact that
the queen can't take on G5 is actually a
huge deal I think the move instead of 97
was Knight to F4 with the additional
idea of actually taking that pawn on H5
trapping The Rook
wow it actually looked pretty strong
there and said he goes Knight
don't go Queen D6 and get your queen
trapped oh that would be
shockingly oh he's Rook H7 his truck's
not trapped oh he didn't see anything in
Lavon but there's Knight C5 that's a
huge move okay so it's actually even
stronger but the Rook could have gone to
H7 there
it absolutely could have but Lavon Going
Down The Adventurous oh and Dimitri
throwing another Pawn to the wind
how is this not completely losing for
black
okay you have before the extra exchange
how many pawns is white have for the
exchange three
I did major math
and you know that I I do know that guess
what I think white has some problems
with the sort of General placement of
his minor pieces Lavon though one for a
piece that doesn't have any problems is
that Rook as it's maneuvering itself to
G3
I I think one Rook lift wasn't enough
for LaVon in this game nope
no you need another one and he can play
rookie three anyway but he decides to
conserve that Knight now rookie three a
massive threat and to meet you down to
20 seconds so he takes on G2 Brave guy
that he is
help yourself
Quincy one Rook takes D3 Rook G1 that's
what I'm looking at right now
yeah Rook E3 Queen takes F2 and the G3
square is suddenly undefended right
that's why like I didn't see one that's
why I want to cover the G1 square right
there
fantastic move it also aims at the H6
spawn which could have been important
rookie 4 instead Queen F2 so Richie
foreign
but A4 Bishop A3 looks really dangerous
it does but maybe there's some tactical
shot that Dimitri has like a knight no
he doesn't have Knight takes C5 so I
don't know what he does King C2 oh
because A4 now is the Knight before
Chuck he's just covering the B4 Square
yeah that ship has sailed Dimitri could
win this five seconds for Lavon I don't
see a continuation of the attack no in
three seconds okay guys Rook cheese
checking the train he's losing the
thread he just completely but he wants
A4 of The Rook took on d8
uh-huh good to see anybody's game here
Queen D3 suddenly a major threat it's a
maid threat yes and you could actually
even take on C6 on the queen D4 and some
queenless positions are still gonna he
goes Queen E3 for that reason
who's better and why I think it's
probably black a bishop whoa what is
Knight B7
he wants the Knight on C5
but he's still very dangerous he's even
think about taking on C5 at some point
pushing a seat Pawn up the board and
there goes oh one second he barely got
the move up yeah he's really in time
trouble oh he but 25 seconds to give C5
yep he's gonna flag
he's done oh my God
it's tight again
Dimitri is just going to Pummel LaVon in
the time scrambles that's what he's
saying
like you know what that's what's so
worrisome
of course I mean Lavon had some good
time scrambles he held that draw in The
Rook end game but you can't keep it up
game after game when you are the slower
player you don't have the mouse speed
that Dimitri on drinking does and now we
have a tied match to meet you on
drinking storms back after going down by
two points is six and a half six and
that's the Midway break you're done a
great showing from on draken in these
last couple games
a great showing indeed and I'm gonna
sound like a broken record but the
closer you get to the bullet the more
worrisome this is Lavon has demonstrated
don't get me wrong uh some incredible
abilities in Low Time situations but if
you tally up the totals Dimitri has
still prevailed by a country mile in
these time scramble uh time scramble
moments so Dimitri could not possibly be
happier with a tied match going into the
halftime break of the three-minute
segment for sure especially at the start
of this game where it looked like Levon
was going to crush him and maybe a
miniature after he won a pawn but good
fighting for Dimitri on draken a great
match from both these two players and
we'll be right back for the second half
of the three plus one time Patrol when
we turn here speed test Championship
brought to you by chess.com
[Music]
now you can use gifts from the biggest
chest stars on all your favorite
platforms just search chess.com and your
favorite chest star on Discord Twitter
WhatsApp and more to find hundreds of
gifts from chess.com's biggest broadcast
and events nepo Donya Bobby Anna's and
even me Danny try it today
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
and we are back here at the speed Chess
Championship this match is Lavon aronian
versus Dimitri on draken Daniel raditzki
alongside me Grandmaster Robert Hess and
Dania we have a tied matchup after
Dimitri on draken won two games in a row
to even things up here but it's anyone's
match so what do you think the players
have to change especially levonaronian
who just kind of let the leads live
yeah I mean Lavon getting exactly the
types of positions he wants to get he's
been so creative in the opening and I
really appreciate that some of the ideas
that he's brought to the table have been
incredible same for Demetria Drake and
by the way those two sacrificial games
in a row Lavon has to tighten up his
speed just a little bit he's got to try
to be better in time scrambles but other
than that I think both players really
giving it their all
and on Dragon is a force let's introduce
people to dimitro Dragon if they don't
know him already I mean he is an
absolute boss in the speed chess High
patrols he wins title Tuesdays left and
right you see he's won 10 times in 2022
already that is ridiculous that is that
might be one of the most
that's so impressive no no I'm just
shocked it's I mean it's not for a car
Nakamura we'd all be mesmerized by that
number but a card seems to win double or
maybe even more than double that amount
but 10 title Tuesday wins for Dimitri on
Dragon that's ridiculous
it's it's absolutely wild it shows his
incredible consistency it obviously
shows his ability in the three plus one
time control and this is a huge 26
minutes as I said at the start Dimitri
most certainly doesn't mind a tie going
into the bullet can Lavon pull it
together and stop the bleeding he's lost
two in a row I think Levon needs to take
a slight lead before heading into bullet
I don't think he wants yeah even an even
score he knows that Dimitri is the
faster the two players and Knight F3 by
andrekin once again so
um stumped
okay
stumped so much they had to restart the
game I wonder what's going on here Lavon
I wonder what he's saying
hmm
I mean Dimitri did just win with black
so he does get the white pieces so I
wonder what the issue is and Dimitri
gets white once again and surprise like
plays Knight of three I didn't like the
first move we're gonna keep recording
until you play a different first move
well we do see a sort of King's Indian
structure it's very symmetrical from
both sides and the big question for
Lavon is does he just play the com C6
like Dimitri did and have the exact same
position no he plays B6 he wants an
eventual C5 C4 and this is one of those
interesting ideas that might seem weird
but of course in this context B6 is a
weakness now you have a bunch of
tenderness going on on the queen side
there the C6 Square you got some light
score problems I like this Choice by
Dimitri kind of calming things down and
getting a risk-free position
wait you're saying Dimitri on draken as
a risk-free position I am just I know
first time those words have ever been
uttered but I I'm totally with you
because the position we have here
um there's some tension between the
Knights black of course can't take on E5
because then the D4 Pawn replaces the
Knight and the Knight F6 is pinned so
Rook C8 both players vying for the C
file at some point black should probably
consider the move H6 like right now I
would probably go for it and well that
asked quite a very important question
are you gonna back up or you take this
Knight and F6 and give black the bishop
pair
yeah H6 is a very timely mood here I
totally agree there's Knight takes D5
which is a semi threat I don't think
it's actually a threat because if you
think about it when white takes on C6
the queen moves up to D7 pinning the
Knight to the queen but still it's a lot
of tactical unpleasantness going on on
the queen side which black has to
resolve very carefully here and we see
H6 and Bishop F4 played and you can play
G5 we saw actually on Drake and do that
I believe all the way back in game two
to keep kicking that Bishop around uh so
it's an idea it's tempting but maybe you
should just play with like Knight D7
instead he goes A6 but I really want to
get this Knight out of E5 done yet
yeah it's it's a splinter it's a bone
and Black's throat and white might get
that night out of E5 himself he could
play Knight takes E6 and replace it with
a bishop but that doesn't seem to be an
overly scary approach but how does
Dimitri turn up the pressure dial here
does he have the means to do so I don't
really think so no and if he doesn't
Knight C6 the bishop could take on C6
but A6 would fall so actually uh and the
queen gets back to D3 that's very
important the queen cannot get trapped
okay so he does take is he gonna go
Bishop E5 yes he does but this is
basically dead equal and after B5 you
could even start making a case that
black uh is the master on the queen side
yes because black has access to double
Rooks that Rook on f8 going over to C8
in the very near future so you could
play a move like Queen D7 which actually
threatens some tactics if white is not
careful with the queen staring at each
other through the Rook on C6 absolutely
instead he goes Rook to C4 establishing
The Rook on a nice Square trying to get
white to play B3 a little bit later and
weaken the C3 Square Dimitri drops his
Queen back to B3 and I think Levon is
likely going to follow up with B5 of
course you always have to watch for A4
in these cases right well I think which
Dimitri could very well play right here
he might do that but after A4 I think
can be safely mode Bishop C6 the problem
for White is you can't take on B5 twice
because your knight will get pinned but
he does go A4 so he sees something like
you saw and the evaluation bar still
slightly seems to prefer White
well I'll tell you what I saw really
quickly in case of B4 there's this
typical idea Knight to A2 and the point
is to meet Rook takes you on with Knight
takes C1 and then reroute the Knight to
D3 where it not only pressures D4 but
threatens to jump into this very nice C5
Square I think that's what attracted him
Lavon dropping over a minute behind on
the clock he's got to be very careful
here they're still in the middle game he
goes Knight D7 but he didn't have to
sort of expand his pawns the way he did
like Rook C4 wasn't entirely necessary
to get to Knight D7 but he's not afraid
of ab5 because the D4 Pawn can be
captured right now so it's a trade white
gets the outermost pass Pawn if you will
but black has this really strong Pawn
chain from F7 to D5 and both sides have
their pluses and minuses
white could try to orchestrate E4 at the
right moment to expose some lack of
coordination among black spaces and I
love the move Queen A3 this is how
Dimitri has to play in levon's time
pressure these cagey moves which create
a lot of threats and very easy to
blunder if you're a Lavon aronian Queen
B6 though solid good defensive move and
often the threats are very subtle like
Queen E7 could hit you while you're not
looking and be a problem for the black
king and the 97 but Queen B6 was
excellent as you said it protects A6
while putting pressure on B5 B3 wants
queen B2 oh Dimitri go
yeah he wants to play against that Rook
on D4 which very well could get trapped
that's kind of like hikaru's Rook
against Wesley in their cgc game for
sure oh I mean if ab5 here Queen B2 now
all of a sudden E3 is a big threat he
goes oh is that a mouse slip that has to
be a mouse slip right
yeah A5 so because he he I mean if
you're already moving the a pawn at
least take the pawn to have something to
suffer for
now Knight A4 is a big problem wait wait
wait wait 984 is a winning threat wait a
second was that a mouse lip or did he
want the B4 Square for his rook and
protected squid ah it might be really
that might be it
but I don't think it's very good because
there's E3 and Bishop takes D5
maybe that's met with Knight C5
oh but in this line 23 Rook before it's
very important that the white Pawn is on
B5 not the black pawn because Blackboard
B5 Knight A2 would trap The Rook so
there were some subtleties here and now
I think he just needs to of course he
doesn't take on D5 and lose an exchange
but he needs to play like maybe Knight
F6 here trade Bishops on B7 he still has
a chance but he's worse and he's in time
trouble
and he does go Knight C5 I thought that
was the idea but there's even the move
Knight to A2 here oh I think Knight A2
might be very strong there's Knight D3
as a result oh my God I'm not Dimitri
you calculate it maybe I'll play Rook
f51 just covering the D3 Square
that is that is the Soviet Schoolboy
approach right there well you can never
capture on D5 because the Knight will
replace the bishop with a fork and E5 is
loose and then your knight A2 move looks
very strong oh
is there an Intermezzo I feel like
LeBron just has to take on B7 you can't
spend this much time when you have just
seconds remaining
Dimitri might have forgotten that after
Knight A2 there's Knight D3 because now
he starts thinking why did he release
the tension you were absolutely right
because Robert the bishop on D5 guarded
the B3 Pawn now if you go Rook fd1 Lavon
can safely take on B3 and cement The
Rook with A4 and now Cemetery who's done
under 20 seconds so both players in some
time trouble here he plays Rook D1 and
that made no sense it's still a game
Lavon could still flag him oh Knight G5
H3
but Knight T5 comes in first oh yeah I
was hanging
oh oh my goodness can you cheat
how do you actually make something of
this discovery maybe Knight F6 and go
back to A1 or something oh it's such an
annoying move H4
E4 cementing the Knight one second A4
what a move to play when your king is in
danger I know but what else are you
gonna do you might as well
just maybe just where is it two seconds
to find it it's King G2 and now nice
five check
or Knight D7 get after the rook and stop
it with Rook A5 oh it's mate Rook dates
oh Rook d8 Rook h8
well done Dimitri on draken that was
sick
amazing and guess what another time
scramble another win
no it's becoming a room in this match
that's very bad news for levonne Ronin
but this position has been good news for
him this alapin the white side of it he
won that game earlier when Dimitri
sacked on H3 it didn't work out for him
now he's gonna play against the iqp so
Dimitri has the lead there's still about
18 minutes and 45 seconds remaining in
this time control but for Levant he kind
of probably feels this match slipping
away from him yeah I mean he I think
this is the first deficit he's faced in
the entire match yes or yeah so that's
never a pleasant feeling it's never a
pleasant feeling when it comes this
relatively late in the match because now
you start looking at the clock and you
start saying hey I go down by two or
three points and then I've got to do
that come back in a bullet against
Dimitri on draken not what I wanted but
this position is not what Dimitri wanted
either I mean maybe it is but I don't
know why you would want but why is he
continually going for this I don't
understand he's just worse he's worse
it's easy to play for Lavon who's
struggled in time trouble just Queen D2
Rook A1 to E1 very simple moves and you
have the long-term plus against playing
against this D5 Pawn so this is way too
easy for Lavon to play I mean I know
Dimitri wants simple positions he
doesn't want tactics but look at this
it's just so clear that white is better
and A5 making more weaknesses on the
queen side and LeBron could just carry
on with his business with Rook a1ning
that goes Knight D4 and the other
problem Robert you mentioned easy to
play what that really means I think is
that you've got three or four good moves
on every turn so the value of each move
is reduced you can basically that means
you can play quickly without having to
worry that your advantage is going to
slip away black can do no such thing you
make one further mistake you're staring
down the barrel of a lost position and
you've given up the B5 Square which can
be very important Bishop takes G6 might
just win the D5 Pawn on the spot uh and
he plays it because if you're a queen to
six I take if you play fg6 and play Rook
D1 I can play Rook D3 next I'm just
gonna pilot all my pieces on the D file
and this looks so bad for black it's
terrible and you can do this with Ice
close he goes through ke1 which also
makes sense because he already had a
rook on the e-file he says give me that
file it's the only open file on the
board the only fully open file and Lavon
has full control of it I have to say I
like that move more because I think
creates more issues for black that are
less easy to resolve so I like rookie
one Rook F6 is a great decision by
Dimitri you must work but look at this
Knight rerouting from H2 to G4 where it
hits the rook and protects F2 at the
same time and you can play Pawn F3 you
can play this kind of slowly if you are
white just watch out for D5 and D4 if
black can get rid of the isolated Pawn
it's not game is immediately a draw but
that's one of Black's bigger concerns
here Lavon is on an absolute role in
this game and he has to convert this
into a full point a draw would be pretty
devastating here for LeBron
and we see DC I don't know you know what
you're saying is you have to make
something of the fuzz what do you see he
wants Rook D7 Knight G4 that kind of
stuff I mean I don't see a concrete win
but I like the way he's playing this
he's playing this aggressively he's not
making Dimitri's life easy on a single
turn Knight G4 Kick The Rook back then
Rook D5 where's that Queen going
yeah every move creates a threat well I
guess it'll drop back to f8 and you'll
curl up into a ball and say where's the
win then I'll play rookie six I'm just
bringing my he said one at a time bang
bang bang and then I'll go King H7
you'll go Queen D3 exactly
sign me up as unfolding as we speak
rookie 6 looks fantastic here for white
and does black have the move G5
potentially after rookie six maybe but
so many loose squares
no this looks oh this this looks major
nasty for black
and you have to try to get a pair of
Rooks off the board if you're Dimitri
but that's so much easier said than done
because anytime you play rookie 8
carelessly you have to watch out for
tactics like 95 and rook d8 and there is
Rook E6
so G5
what is Weiss follow-up that's the big
question because then black at least has
protected pawns on the king side the
queen side's still a bit vulnerable for
white excuse me for black and white has
all the activities so let's see how
Lavon continues what about Queen z360
goes to Rook G6
well King HH
and then he wants then you're
threatening a fork yeah then he wants
Rook D5 to D6 and he might sack on H6 at
some point whoa no no no no you walked
into a discovery you walked into a uh a
very nasty queen move here I don't know
if that was necessary doesn't that
improve White's position yeah like can
you just bring the queen up to D3 what
was King H7
and then he'll have to go King h8 but
the queen is so much better on D3
because it's got easy access to the king
side and all those light squares for
sure that was a strange moment but
Levant doesn't seem convinced by moving
his Queen the diagonal
no something's bothering him what is it
oh there he goes Rick D6 he's setting it
up because he if he plays Queen C2 or
queen D3 next then there's a sacrifice
in H6 and it's just game over
Dimitri I think has to try 97 maybe
Shuffle the Knight over to F5 just put
as much stuff as you can on the king
side and pray he goes there's sacks all
over the place
no this has to be winning for white I
mean you just look at the eval bar look
at the position there and look at that
diagonal
well you start with Queen C2 oh oh but
he went that's a big mistake he stayed
in the rook's eyes on d8 that was oh
that was the mistake it was because now
if you sack on H6 and you take again
blackcast Queen takes H6 to hit the
queen after King h8 black is suddenly
fine but Dimitri he's gotta move but it
looks scary like even if it's not losing
it feels scary just we bring your king
back but what are the Alternatives what
is he thinking about there's literally
no other move
and okay
over Rook D6 is Knight F7 check and gh's
Rook HX check very important Rook after
it takes F2 that was the move oh my God
and that's why the queen need to be on
C2 as well
it was defending the F2 Pawn who could
have known Dimitri's holding this Knight
takes d8 but how is again taking
Rook somewhere that's all I know
five maybe Rook he takes a two
is mate
back rank mates
well King G1 I guess technically but you
could just take the Rook yeah I mean
that is just unreal
and look at Levant he smiles but that's
a smile out of sadness so he doesn't cry
Dimitri looks incredulous he has now won
four in a row not only could
I not imagine that Levon wouldn't win
that he actually lost it and he's down
by two and it's just amazing really bad
the difference Donya between Queen D3
and queen C2 Queen D3 is so much more
natural because you're going to the more
advanced square but Queen C2 actually
kept all of your bases covered and was
out of the Rooks uh you know stare down
on d8 it protected F2 and that small
mistake made all the difference and did
not allow Levon to tie this measure in
fact he goes down by two and now it's
Demetria dragon's match for the taking
but I was so impressed with him if Rook
takes F2 Robert in the middle of all of
the chaos Dimitri finds the only move he
doesn't panic and again time scrambles
time scrambles time scrambles that is
where Dimitri has ultimately proven that
his lack of experience is uh not going
to be insignificant in this match
not at all and I really like that
username from the feature show that was
pudding snack I was like oh I would like
some pudding right now uh but Bishop
takes F6 Queen F6 so once again Levon
gets the you know Bishop pair here for
nothing that's what it sometimes I don't
understand what you're doing when I play
like this thinking I'm playing solidly I
always get punished when Dimitri does it
it's like the evil Bar says he's
slightly worse and then he still looks
good winning these games in a long end
game grind so I I just don't know how he
does it
I mean from a purely like principle
perspective the center is relatively
closed and obviously you you have the
the rule the knights are better in
closed positions but a position is not
entirely close you know the queen side
is relatively open you could have E5 at
some later point so I I'm pretty puzzled
at Dimitri's choice but maybe again he's
just trying to be solid and that can be
very tilting when you're when you're in
the middle of a losing streak and Lavon
plays B5
uh I wouldn't rule this out because
there's Queen A3 in the end I don't know
probably not
I see what you're saying though it
doesn't work no but I see what you're
saying that it doesn't seem to lose a
piece on the spot that's the good news
but he goes nice there was just Queen
takes A3 and Knight take a rook takes B2
but anyways Dimitri wants Rook C2 Rook
C1 you know take over the C5 Square get
your knight there eventually
um I could see him being better in like
five turns how is he making this look
good
that's what I don't understand Dimitri
on drinking is that kind of player is he
little decisions they have huge
consequences and he just does that so
well in title twos after title Tuesday
in the rapid Chess Championship in This
Global Championship where he made the
top eight so he just he's just a beast
he really is and Lavon pushing his Queen
side pawns very ambitious approach could
be potentially very good if you go B4 he
actually uses the b-pawn as an anchor
here
pretty good approach as well Dimitri
could play B3 on demand to chase The
Rook out
but he probably doesn't want to do that
because that leaves the A3 some of these
dark squares I'm queening through right
now he could play it again but it's Rook
A3 instead Rook A3 but it's just the
square now all of a sudden black has a
little something here The eval bar
hasn't changed still says an equal game
but you start to feel like you have a
little something for Levant and you're
up 30 seconds I like the move Rook C3 by
Dimitri to reinforce the threat of B
take C4 and essentially Force The Rook
trade I suppose you could play Rook
before but I don't know about giving up
full control of the C file and your Rook
might just get trapped in a few turns
yeah
I think Rook C3 is smart and then maybe
B4 for black just to give the B5 Square
to the bishop and all right your pieces
are activating
yeah before Bishop E5 on on B3 is a
fixed weakness that Knight doesn't
really have a lot of prospects with C3
now being guarded you want to get it to
C5 I mean Bishop B5 looks very good
right now
yup an easy to play position again we
talk about how important that is in the
reduced time control
but Lavon is down on time he was up 30
seconds and then you close your eyes for
one second and suddenly it's on drinking
with the lead in the clock and it just
happens game after game in ways that
aren't even noticeable but this is going
to be a problem for Lavon
a huge one in the second half of the
three-minute portion it seems like in
every single game Levon is at least you
know 30 seconds down on the clock once
the position hits the the late middle
game
yeah he's no problems here from a
positional standpoint but he doesn't
know what to do and Bishop B5 there
might be some kind of night moves Queen
A7 I like that
yeah he's burning so much clock though
every single turn he's just using those
precious seconds
um Bishop D7 here
Rook C7 suddenly a threat by the way yes
it was Queen A8
protecting his Bishop offering a trade
of Queens
which is not out of the question for
white you could trade and you could
basically say that the a file isn't all
that dangerous and the b-pawn cannot be
attacked by Black's Bishop funnily
enough even though it's on a light
Square
somehow I don't like the look of it but
Dimitri goes Knight F4 so if you swap
Queens the B3 Pawn is not hanging
because the bishop on E8 is loose
yep good move Dimitri keeping the
tension again Lavon down to 30 seconds
and this is where he says struggled the
most he has to at least make a draw here
I think he can do it by force swap
Queens Bishop D7 The Rook attacks the
bishop with Rook C7 the bishop goes to
E8 and you just go back and forth Rook
C8 and the bishop is untrappable
yep
and he does it and Dimitri of course is
more than happy to oblige or will he try
Rook d8 I don't think so will he just he
broke some time off the clock that's
what I was about to ask you will he just
sit here quote unquote think for 40
seconds and then repeat no he's just
gone for it
yep well he's definitely aware of the
match clock and I would have wait I
would wait 45 seconds to make sure that
the next game is the last
and he's doing it it's smart can't blame
him uh there is no other move if you
play anything else you'd lose the game
most likely so he plays Rook C8 the game
is a draw Fair result there a solid game
from Levant he gets the white pieces he
needs to win this one
yeah this very likely going to be the
last game of the three-minute segment
and Dimitri
d4d5 a Queen's Gambit declined here
an A6 A6 Magnus Carlson has made this
increasingly popular he was A6 and then
H6
and it's a bit slow it does you know
develop very quickly but at least your
Center is protected you can play like
this as well
um I mean this is solid stuff from on
Dragon extremely solid and that's how he
needs to play right now
yeah I mean this of course is a Carlsbad
structure a version of the Carlsbad
story but black playing in a very modern
style a G5 weren't we just saying this
is very solid and then he plays G5
Dimitri's been doing that all match
hasn't he the moment we start you know
labeling his play he does something
crazy like he sacks his queen or he goes
G5 in the opening I know this has been
played before because uh when I was
coaching at the Olympiad I looked at
this with one of the players and for
white right now there are several moves
with Bishop E5 is certainly an option uh
but he's castles and States I'm not
afraid of Knight takes G3 I'll just take
back with my H Pawn look how far ahead
white is in terms of development
yeah but he's down on the clock again he
also might take back with his F Pawn I
have seen even Magnus I think he
famously made that type of recapture
against Mahmoud yarov and there it is
there it is FG on the board wow so Lavon
he plays F takes G3 he just wants to
control the f file
um what would you like to do is get the
bishop on E6 off the board and take over
all the light squares easier said than
done because black is saying if you're
gonna trade you're going to take me on
E6 and the pawn F7 will replace the
bishop
great point and King H1 Lavon playing it
slow row style Slow Roll style of course
C5 is a very pertinent idea here for
black to try to open up the bishop but
Dimitri fist the moment I start saying
he'll play sharp he plays solid and vice
versa so I'll just stop trying to
predict his moves Shape Shifter E4 I
think here LeBron has to make moves like
E4 there's a king on E8 where is that
King going if it cast is King side
probably gonna be the victim of a big
attack on the diagonal if it goes to the
queen side well they're open files there
and some white pieces so it's hard to
say what Andrea should do about his King
uh the good news for him is he still is
over two minutes he's doing well in the
clock
I think de is definitely the right
decision yes the Knight is nasty when
it's on e4 but you create a long-term
weakness the iqp on D4 which is
immediately pressured by the bishop and
is Castle's Queen side uh a possibility
here risky yes but nah he'll probably go
king size it's one of these moments
Donya where you're playing hand and
brain you say King another person's like
I don't know what way you want me to
Castle and Castle exactly and look at
this Rook 81 played quickly by Levant I
think this position right is about feel
and for black do you play Rook 88 no
it's Queen before he doesn't care about
his King safety
well she's basically saying this is a
self-sufficient defensive construction
as surprising as it sounds there are
sacks on G5 and they should already be
considered in fact Knight takes G5 might
be something Levon is calculating right
here
I feel like if this were a bullet and
stand on their disc you were playing
1965 would happen instantly 10 seconds
ago yeah just bam well I'm already
seeing a bunch of tricks like Bishop H7
Bishop G8 in the end I would be way too
tempted so A3 plays a queen B3 now he
does not want to trade Queens that's for
sure but where does the White Queen go
to you need to stay in touch with the
bishop on D3
yeah Queen D2 obviously Queen trade is
right into Black's hands
and now Knight takes G5 even more
attempting Robert I don't know and I'm
doing it there's also Bishop B1 he goes
Bishop C2 you're just trying to line the
bishop of Queen up on the diagonal
Queen takes B2 there's Knight F6 and
Bishop H7 oh gosh Queen takes me two as
a move you just you don't play because
you trust your opponent you you have
that enough respect for Lavon not to
take on B2 yeah there's just certain
moves that are like basically illegal
and look at this queen D3 now doesn't
actually carry an immediate checkmating
threat because Knight F6 check is made
by Knight takes F6 which covers the H7
square and the reason why that's so
important is because after Queen D3 well
I can play them with Queen B5 offering
the queen trade immediately while F6 is
covered by the Knight
what am I going to point out right now
um what are you gonna point out
isolated Queen Pawn oh okay the clock
I was like a minute down that was a
trick question I got scared
no no no no we completed each other's
sandwiches so what kind of 30 seconds 30
seconds by move 20. it's a Time trouble
a nice BLT right now you're hungry
hungry guy Knight takes G5 but the thing
is he did this after spending a minute
and now Dimitri is a huge lead on the
clock and levon's out of 25 seconds if
you're gonna do this in a speed chess
game you often just have to go for it
you can't be a perfectionist especially
because it doesn't work we see the eval
bar suggesting it's not good enough but
I just feel like LaVon isn't trusting
himself and he's over calculating in
some moments which is he I don't know
it's hard totally is and now Queen takes
B2 Greymon by Dimitri and Dimitri saying
hey guess what you don't have anything
concrete going on in the king side
Knight F6 there's always Knight takes F6
the hero of the defense here for black
Robert as you pointed out earlier is
that Knight on D7 and this is becoming
virtually residable for Lavon
how does he do that for maybe try to
advance the pawn uh h4h5h6 I like that
he's down to still cheat seconds make a
move yeah he's not finding anything here
he's just letting his time run out Rook
F2 Queen takes defense now Queen takes
D4 scoop them all up
Dimitri taking his time making sure this
is going to be the last game of the
segment which it is okay Rook F4 the
queen 94 defends G7 that's important
which means Rook G4 doesn't threaten
Checkmate or anything like that Rook H4
maybe there's a little something
something on the H7 square but it seems
far away
rookie eight maybe you use the back rank
preventing Knight F6
I like it he goes Rook f81
this should be four yeah what is the
threat oh oh The Rook on d8 is saying so
maybe you should have put the other Rook
on E8 precisely for this reason good
point because Bishop before Bishop E4
Rook takes for Queen takes D check which
still might be good for
black considering how much material
you'd be ahead but not what you want 25
seconds about he does take on e4 now
there's just got to be one more accurate
move here to repel the attack but it's
not that easy no Queen E5 maybe he loved
Queen so he goes for this because
LeBron's no time oh
levana's one second Bishop E5 looks good
there he trades he should be able to win
this
should have Woulda Coulda C form B5
nah this is winning yeah B5 looks really
nice
okay or if we see a repetition stop stop
harassing my Rook leave it alone oh no
now Queen D3 is Queen takes B7 so the
queen would protect them oh and that
means Dimitri might lose one of his
pawns on the queen side Queen takes B7
oh you can't take an F4 because Queen B
check
oh great Point Dimitri sees it he still
has a passer but this has gotten a lot
harder to win yeah all of his pawns oh
look at Queen F1
oh my God first rank
he's holding this is a huge threat Queen
D3 was crazy C5 A4
C4 Rook D2 wins a piece oh my goodness
rookie one move it goes behind the okay
a five
oh he's gone he played it with 0.1
seconds oh my gosh he's getting Queen
but Knight takes Knight takes a two oh
my God it's C2 Dimitri on Jake Drake is
a wizard he wins again and now he
doesn't even have to mate with Knight
and Bishop because he's gonna win all
his pawns he's Checkmate it's mate oh my
God
look at Dimitri he can barely breathe
right now but he's creating Breathing
Room in this match he is now up ten to
seven Dimitri on draken is Unstoppable
this last stretch here he's taking a
two-point deficit into a three-point
lead Dania he's unreal
riding the crest of us of a five-game
winning streak in the SEC against none
other than Levon aronian that was some
magic right there that was some serious
nasty by Dimitri For Whom the first half
of the match was not going his way
Lovato's calling the shots in all stages
of the game but harnessing his strength
forcing these games into these super
gritty time scrambles and then just
demonstrating this ability to find
clutch moves again and again Lavon needs
a miracle at this point in the bullet
and everyone out there in this term and
watching like dimitro dragons not a
person I want to face they've seen
Dimitri be on the edge of defeat and
then go back and win the game he did it
against Fabiano caruana in the global
Championship he's done it here against
levada Ronin Dimitri on draken is not to
be messed with but we still have the
bullet to come here in the speeches
championship match between levonne and
Ronin and Dimitri on Drake and we're
going to take a break along with the
players and when we're back it is bullet
time here at the SEC
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
a storm is brewing you're never going to
beat hikarados on game not in these
positions within the Tempest the best
have come to test their skills and brave
the storm
oh we missed it oh he allowed to drop oh
my goodness the wheels the wheels have
come out that could be the magic for
some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabi exactly exhausting every
light source
the electric that is
dagger the moves will be fast oh my God
so 97
tricked at the end the stakes will be
high he grabs his head he can't believe
it he just gave away the pawn the 2022
speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
we are back here at the speed Chess
Championship Dimitri on draken has take
a three-point lead a commanding lead
over levonne aronian but done it every
single point matters not just for Lavon
to mount this comeback but also because
every Point impacts the prize fun going
to the players
it most certainly does 2000 goes to the
winner but two thousand more goes based
on win percentage as if the players need
any more motivation you can see the
distribution there man those prizes in
the finals are mouth-watering but this
30 minutes of bullet mouth-watering as
well Robert yes a 10-7 lead right now
for Dimitri on draken he was down two
points how easy it is to forget but he
went on a winning streak and there was
no stopping him even when Lavon had
winning positions it felt like Dimitri
still he maintained his composure he's
been doing really well on the clock and
for Lavon now that we're going towards
the bullet section I know there's prize
money at stake for every single game but
as we see the players locked in it just
feels like it's getting out of hand for
him quickly
well he can't afford to lose the first
game of the bullet he needs to set the
tone right now he's still on this losing
streak he's lost the last five games
he's got to prove to himself that he can
defeat Dimitri in these low time
situations and the earlier he can do
that the better 30 minutes it's a lot of
time they got time for 12 13 bullet
games but you can't let this get to like
a four or five point lead and sometimes
this weird effect happens where players
who are slow in the longer time patrols
suddenly speed up and look at Levant do
that he has more time than he started
with he's actually up about 10 seconds
in the opening against drinking and he's
trying to prove all the doubters wrong
yeah and he has played in a couple of
the games very quickly in the opening so
he's capable of doing it he knows what a
pre-move is but he blunders 95 and
there's that sloppy move again but
Knight C6 was Queen D7 so he's relying
on that so he doesn't drop material uh
but it was a bit sloppy but dun dun
Hikaru has always said this it's better
to play good moves quickly than perfect
moves slowly and look at how fast
aronian has been
he's up 30 seconds at Dimitri know that
this is not five plus one he's down a
half of his time after 11 moves and
don't forget that black cannot Castle
kingside because that's castling through
check
yep and that's actually a big problem
for black because you also can't put
your queen on D6 to intercept it and if
Dimitri can get the center open or the
queen Side open ugh things are going to
get really unpleasant here I would go
rookie one and E4 and I knew it was a
place before he wants it the position
open he wants it open now but after B3
there might be the move Knight B6
there's also B5 to consider and he plays
Knight B6 quickly
well obviously from an objective
standpoint this is a very very nasty
situation for black but can Dimitri keep
up his quality of play and time pressure
wow he gives up A7 and takes D4 lavon's
showing me but you can't take B6 as
Queen's B6 is checked oh 10 seconds for
Dimitri I can't believe we're saying
this but at least down 40 seconds
and Lavon steals 45 seconds of his own
Queen A4 again those Queens off the
board good decision B5 drops the pawn on
G7
Dimitri is so tactically alone right now
he is just a monster Bishop F6 Robert
and The Rook is trapped on H7 this is
really bad for Lavon I think Dimitri
could pull this off with 11 seconds
yes and Rook D1 is the threatened mate
it does but B6 opens up some Luft
okay Knight C5
barely holds on but E5 is all remember
Bishop E4 maybe Rook D4 oh oh wait EF
Rook d8 check and then wait oh no he's
oh he's going to do that
yeah he's got chances here but it's not
great he does know what five seconds for
Dimitri
I still don't think oh and he wins The
Pawn on it on C4 that changes a lot
yeah now The Rook gets out
move your knight away oh
yes C5 Knight C6 ac6 oh he's gonna drop
him one and aliban's better
this is really bad for Dimitri B5 now
it's two pawns clear on the queen side
the only problem for Lavon is he's got a
bunch of these weaknesses the bishop is
loose the pawn on C7 is targeted so
Dimitri obviously should go for a draw
if he can pull this out oh he's going
after the H fun
D4 pushed the Pawns he goes for the
other Pawn instead
there is no way that you could hold it
for three seconds if he does hold this
oh no he's got that H spawn Robert this
is ridiculous C4
c three this is so hard to win though
because H5 comes really fast
and now what king C4 uh
he goes Bishop B5 to go to wait it's too
slow though right
C2 Rook C8 Bishop C4
it's winning
with check he's gonna levon's gonna win
the first game
and can we just say that Levon looked
like a very practiced bullet player in
this one I know that is that bodes so
well for his chances the fact that he
was able to splits out that opening and
then navigate a very difficult position
while keeping the time advantage
but he's struggling to check me right
now
checking and checking and checking and
he finally wins The Rook
that was nuts
I think Dimitri just has to play fast
for the first 10 moves like he he didn't
give himself a chance there dropping to
11 seconds in the opening
well let's let our you know if we're
being honest with ourselves and if Chad
is honest nobody expected Levon aronian
after all those losses to come out and
win a bullet game up 20 seconds and more
for most of it that was really something
apt no this is this is a huge win and
this is exactly what the doctor ordered
he wins another one it's a one-point
game like that's basically it
right and the increment is all important
because I mean when you're in time
trouble you can get time back but look
at this C5 is an extra pawn and it's
actually very difficult to get to so
Lavon I think choosing smart bullet
openings it very and he might have
prepared them before the match you never
know but he's better again and he's pays
for Pace on the clock
right E4 right now he can strike in the
center if he wants he was Knight F to D2
why Rush the decision A5 is a bit loose
C5 is well defended uh by this Knight on
B3 so Lavon doing everything you could
ask him in the bullet wow F5 that's a
big move at the top by Lavon carving out
the D4 score for his Knight
wow that's like meeting someone at The
Summit in a dunk attempt right exactly
and he just met him right there and
what's gonna go bear moment there
oh what a bad trade that was for Timbers
but that's neither here nor there
speaking of that E5 and then Knight D4
falling apart in the early part of the
bullet but all credit to Lavon he is
just a monster
he's gonna win this match if this keeps
going in this direction he's up 20
seconds he's up one Pawn about to make
it two Pawns
oh I don't know he trades the Queens
which is a sensible practical decision
he should still win this
look how much time he's up
he's really levada I know I was gonna
make a joke but then you know people
would be like oh you're accusing him of
something but like this is just absurd
yeah you're clearly accusing him of
something Knight F5 and after a trade on
F5 King E6 Rook takes D5 and Bishop C4 I
think it also just wins another Pawn
yeah good point there he goes he's going
for it oh what
I was allowing the discovery
double check or to some other discovery
maybe a good practical try
Knight D4 work F6 check next
mm-hmm
King H5 maybe no it goes back to G7
oh Levon has plenty of time
lavon's just doing everything right
96 check maybe try to get the bishop off
the board
he does it and now the Knight has to
move and then his rookie seven check if
it's a knight G6 there's Rook fd3
oh oh rookie seven wow he saw that
instantly I would play it anyway and
double on the seventh oh that's
disgusting his Checkmate goodbye resign
time the knights trap rotates these I
mean his Checkmate actually by force it
should be six and
unbelievable mate next move rookie shade
and it's a one point match and Dimitri
can't believe it either
and I think we're gonna have to pull a
James candy here LeBron aronian has
shown up for the bullet he is an
Unstoppable force and Demetria Dragon
leads by just one point flexly so right
here
that was that was amazing and improving
on the first game with Knight D7 great
move there to take the sting out of 95.
and then he's gonna go to B6 and then
Bishop takes A3 might happen anyway and
he's better than three oh my gosh he's
much better
and look at the pawn structure on the
queen side the C4 square is weak the
knight's on the perfect square Dimitri
has to try to open up the center maybe
to exploit his Bishop pair but I can't
believe the match the bullet has started
the way that it has
no this is unexpected and queen E7 is
possible somewhere hitting A3 he wants
Knight A5 give me that C4 Square white
has to play E4 but the problems will
still persist C4 is under blast control
D5 will also be under blacks control and
Levant quickly plays Bishop G6 he's not
thinking overthinking I should say and
he's doing the right thing can you take
on e4 with F5 to follow no H6 was
hanging some good choices by Levon but
Dimitri trying to wind up some King side
play there isn't that much going on
there though Bishop B5 you'll have F6
can Dimitri find a way to exploit that
weak Pawn on G7 I don't see anything and
again he's down on the clock
oh this position is really nice for
black strategically speaking I mean look
for the long term Black's Pawn structure
is much healthier and Levant up a couple
seconds he goes Queen D6 now perhaps no
but C6 just shutting down the bishop I'm
a little worried about the Knight and A5
Donna it can't be hit with a pawn but it
is stuck over there for the foreseeable
future and if you have to make that move
I mean you're weakening the queen side
permanently
and C4 player
followed up by night before maybe or
Knight B3 I like both of those moves for
sure
you play C5 called it and now B5 I think
is going to be levon's best chance
there's Queen F6 and Levon still keeping
Pace on the clock great move Queen F6
very practical get the Queens off the
board reduce the pressure on the
position
get the Knight off the board don't like
that 96. Queen E5 Bishop E4 oh he keeps
the Queens on or not
now this is good for black I think just
having a knight against a bishop is just
the trickiness and the control of the
dark squares eventually if you trade
prematurely though you give up this very
important D6 Square for The Rook which
you've got to be careful about let's see
how he handles it maybe five oh goes
Knight C4 instead F4 I guess
yeah F4 and then Rook D7 to follow I
don't like the look of this because
Black's King is stuck on the last rank
exactly you can't play Rook C7 there
because of the back rank mate you called
it and now Dimitri's gonna start
collecting
oh
A4 C4 A5 white spawn too quick
oh this might be losing for Lavon
and you know what you can play Rook B7
oh you can play it that was good yeah
really good move I don't know though no
because then Knight before C3 and C2
94 rupee
oh because you can stop the pawn I'm
sorry Rook c866
yeah you take oh that scared me this
that's better lavonaster was amazing
can you stop wasting time Lavon there he
goes the resignation has happened we get
into the next game but look at Dimitri
on draken I mean he lost two games in a
row the match started veering swerving
out of control and yet he wins that game
he's up two points once more and if he
can win another game and build that big
cushion back up that's going to be huge
already 10 minutes off 11 minutes off of
the match clock this is heating up big
time as Dimitri again repeating his
alopin choice there
yeah I think we've approved of this for
Lavon all match and look at Dimitri
spend about seven seconds before taking
on D4 and now he gives up a pawn but
there are tactics Galore the H2 Pawn so
if you try to take out C6 twice you're
probably not going to get away with it
yeah the bishop H2 Queen D6 ooh I don't
like this Choice by Lavon he's given a
lot of Mobility to Black's Queen side
pawns here
yes and there's no more on iqp a C6 is
loose in some of these positions
Knights
Knight C6 and Bishop F6 I don't buy this
no Bishop H2 King H1
oh my gosh Dimitri kind of mini blunder
there I think he assumed Bishop H2 King
H2 was forced but there's King H1 and
then the queen has moved and then you
take on F6 and it's a good transition
for white no you're absolutely right
this was a huge mistake and Dimitri
again falling behind on the clock
he is in trouble he's down a full Pawn
a full very healthy B3 here white just
up a clip on the bishop on D4 is
excellent uh this is very bad news for
Dimitri in this game yeah he has to try
to whip up that counter play on The
Queen side which he's trying to do but
everything's so well defended and again
he gets these iqp positions that are so
easy to play what a move
my gosh
how about them apples
I mean I think Lavon is underrated in
bullet clearly
what a monster he is
although if the Knight is traded for the
bishop you know what opposite colored
Bishops mean there are chances therefore
for Dimitri
there are still an extra Pawn though for
Lavon but the issue is this game is
going to take a while now 17 minutes
plus remaining on the match clock so I
think Levon actually can take comfort in
that he doesn't need to win three in a
row right now he's only down two points
but you get you get the image here he
just can win the games that are in front
of him he doesn't need to do it in um
you know two seconds he can take it I'm
a little bit worried though
six we're gonna have three
he doesn't do it you were right I'm sure
Queen F7 was working I guess F3 Queen G3
oh I just completely overlooked queen
g3s that was maybe the touch that was
necessary no but this is still winning I
would just take A5
and put your Bishop on B6
on the other hand then of course the
black Bishop is very well placed on D3
it's preventing further progress of
white spawns this ain't over Queen C7
he's playing this a little bit too
conservatively in my opinion
G4 trap that work in oh maybe F5 will be
necessary H5 H5 oh but then it works
pinned now that's really bad news nasty
little move by Lavon
and queen he wants Bishop G3 he wants F5
great move no but Queen takes F5
okay take it in Rook G5
oh an H4 is a big thread
it certainly is but I feel like it's
still good winning chances for white and
but this game is taking so much time off
the match clock which isn't necessarily
in either player's favor it's just
making this even closer
right and Rook F4 okay rookie six
Chicken King of five you get mated oh
he's gonna lose another Pawn
oh no he's not five look at Dimitri
B5 why do you allow that how are you
gonna stop that pawn no but why didn't
you just go Bishop C4 that was a very
odd decision
yeah no it's winning
b-77. we missed it why do you love the
trade
whoa
what was that it might still be winning
because Bishop
oh my gosh and the pawns are yes it's
winning because the H Pawn the bishop
match that's really important here yeah
oh
it's winning close closer than he would
have liked but levonne Vernon getting
the point that he needs well he has to
do me it's not totally over yet yeah it
is come on okay come on
and look at this classy move Bishop G5
couldn't capture wrong color if you're
Dimitri
what I would blame
oh look at me just wasting time now King
takes G5
wow sign of respect
but maybe bad gamesmanship or
matchmanship whatever you want to call
it like that was really polite extended
courtesy to his uh you know very well
respected opponent but in terms of a
match you just gotta waste time if
you're ahead
but can Lavon get over the hump right
it's psychological at this point you've
been down for a while can you convince
yourself that you actually can complete
this comeback
yes and you see the smart predictions
looking like a roller coaster there we
go ups and downs uh those g-forces
getting you a knot in your stomach and
well for Dimitri on Drake and he might
have a knot in his because he was up
three points heading into this time
segment he is the faster player but
levana Rooney's taking not so fast and
look at this G5 he is not afraid anymore
Lavon believes he can win this match I
mean it's just clear in his play that as
I said you win the first game you
convince yourself yeah Dimitri is a good
bullet player so am I and he's playing
so fast so confidently he's striking the
right balance between speed and accuracy
he's playing like a veteran bullet
player like someone who plays Bullet
every day
and this may seem like a random comment
but Lavon is an exceptionally good Bug
House player and I think the combination
of defensive and attacking moves like
doing those simultaneously he's been
doing that throughout these bullet games
where he's just making these really
strong choices and he's creating threats
in his opponent's Camp so right now he's
probably slightly better but he also has
a loose position the pawn G5 it does
stick out if you're not careful you
might blunder it and the Knight goes
into E5 for Dimitri trading some pieces
off but I think the coast is clear for
Lavon I don't know though I don't really
like this from a bullet perspective
excellent move by Dimo there and he
strikes at both sides of the board
email bar didn't like that move
okay why not
um
why are you asking me all the difficult
questions look at Lavon he gives up his
Bishop on G6 which looks bad
a 192 to follow I think he's gonna
eventually pay the price for all of the
weaknesses that he's created and bullet
you want to have as few hanging
undefended pawns as possible
it's true Queen C2 already attacks one
of them
and E4 E5 D5 is such a long-term problem
and E4 is actually it's a it gets rid of
the problem but it creates a new one for
black the B7
oh yeah Bishop C5
aiming at the pawn
the openf file good for Levant wow B4
quite the move there opening up the B
file inviting on passant
and that's a big ball that's a past a
pawn and if you don't trade Queens Rook
takes F4 is a pretty big threat I feel
like it most certainly is it's not only
practical it also creates these massive
threats on the king side he's got to
trade queens and again this looks pretty
decent for Lavon now okay five check
don't blunder that it's a Time scramble
this is where Dimitri has to strike
maybe no Rook I was gonna say Rook F4
and then Knight takes E3 and you have
two pawns on the queen side and yeah two
more are hanging on the king side E2 and
F4 that's right
it's anybody's game totally anybody's
game here five seconds for Dimitri
Dimitri getting a bit nervous down on
the clock Rook f8 going after F4 and F2
he's gonna lose that bond this fonts
hanging Knight's very strong Bishop's
hanging it moves I like the way Levon is
doing this everything protected Rook
takes up for the bishop A6 and I can
move forward is protected look how
quickly lavon's playing he's keeping 10
seconds on his clock and now the a pawn
moves forward he's got champions
it did win a PC misses it because Knight
E4 going after he's winning this and the
white kick
Rook G6 at the end might win for white
or it might win for black
rookie
and then a two goes Rook D2 pins the
bishop and he's gonna win the bishop oh
wait what why do you over K4 there yeah
he panics
Lavon might win this now oh my gosh he
is gonna win this kingy five
wrong way the wrong way but he can go
back right he's got time
eventually you're gonna have to give up
H4 but you have to do it at the right
moment right 10 minutes on the match
clock move the Rook away Rook takes H4
is possible and played and it is still
holding so Lavon missed his chance to
bring his King over earlier and now the
H Pawn's a runner yeah it's a runner and
you've got to be careful if you're live
on now yeah good decision oh what a Save
Right Dimitri at the end and it's still
a one point match but Dimitri once again
he could have played out Chris Rook he
could have wasted another 40 seconds
let's say and got that match clock down
to nine rather than 10 minutes so I
think Dimitri you know he's being
respectful maybe just try playing the
board for now because the match is so
close but at some point he needs to milk
that clock well if there was like a
minute left on the overall batch clock
then you could have milked that entire
minute off of with Rook versus Rook
okay repeating this line again
bad decision in my opinion this I mean
I've seen Lavon totally just get
Advantage after advantage in this line
and you can see the evil bar creeping up
again Knight G5 looks pretty nasty here
oh wow I mean what a it's just a big
threat
how again
oh look at that Queen issues provoking
G6 and going for the dark squares yeah
this decision to repeat this lunch makes
no sense in a bullet context not to say
that Dimitri isn't solid here he is but
he's dropping a Pawn on D5 Lavon
probably won't take it though to keep
the positional blockade going
yeah Knight E5 is possible Bishop E3
let's trade off the dark Square Bishops
Bishop C7 is possible but Knight C5
income White's pieces d5's hanging and
now you're gonna take it because there's
no Rook to come to d8 if the queen drops
back to C8 again Dimitri suffering in
this line
and if you go Queen E7 then Knight takes
B7 I don't care if you take on H2 black
pawns are fallen and here goes D5 okay
there's another bad position
what has happened to Levon aronian and
we see that the match score is off
underneath the players don't worry
everybody uh the live scores 11 half ten
and a half oh my God Bishop's favor
Bishop H6
I think it's winning
no it just wins on the spot Rook takes
C6 and queen D4 oh my gosh Bishop E6
Queen D4 and just cancel winning you
gotta play Fe and then E5 but that
obviously promises no relief at all it's
gonna be a tide match unless we get a
miracle in this game
but seriously though what has happened
with Levon aronian he was kind of slow
stuck in the mud in many of these time
scrambles and now he's just dominating
fair play chess on YouTube uh in this
video good ones it's over Queen D7 you
trading a rookie seven we're gonna get
resign time here any moment now Knight
G5 is mate with Rook G7 and Knight F7
look at that I I think you make sure you
don't get back my checkmated but I think
after this if I'm Dimitri I might let
the 15 seconds on my clock elapse lose
on time just to try to get some sense of
composure to regain the balance because
everything is going wrong for him thus
far and he loses another game I think
I'm gonna make the prediction that if
Dimitri goes down in this match he's not
going to recover I just I think that's
going to be too heavy of a blow so this
next game I think is going to decide the
match
just everything going well for Lavon
right now he is just in charge of the
bullet he is up three pawns and if I'm
Dimitri I play Bishop takes B2 at some
point yeah
well not anymore
okay
so no but this is yeah he he's he's
milking the clock he just wants this
match over as quickly as possible he
wants us to come down to the last game
and now he resigns
okay that's a tie match here we go
I I really feel like he's on the verge
of tilting right like he is struggling
mightily in this bullet and doesn't
matter what color Levon is it doesn't
matter how he changes his move order
Dimitri has been in trouble and look at
this we have the most solid of solid
position the Triangle Pawn structure
from White Daniel Dimitri getting back
to his bread and butter he most
certainly is and that's what he has to
do play solid don't do anything crazy
don't try to play Hero ball play good
solid chess and again try to drag this
into a Time scramble that's the strategy
which has succeeded for Dimitri in the
previous time segments I think he's been
playing just too speculatively and
repeating the same bad openings with
black I mean look at did we use
positions
yeah the C3 Pawn is bad he could have
captured he does this is what I've
actually really appreciate lavon's play
there have been pawns that he can
capture and probably get away with but
he's just making Dimitri's life as hard
as possible he's like you're gonna
have that weakness for the rest of this
game and then I'll grab it when the
moment's right and that's why we've
called Levon a seasoned bullet player
it's these practical decisions that you
don't just make unless you have played a
ton of games no matter who you are
what in the world I mean I just couldn't
possibly expect the Levon aronia would
play this level of bullet but the match
is still really there's a lot left here
Queen takes A5 Bishop E7 okay I'll take
on C3 I'll take all your pawns you get
my exchange but the end of the line
there it looks like black is ahead okay
Bishop F3 setting a trap Queen takes C3
there's Bishop takes E4
defending the queen and loosening black
screen at the same time Lavon taking his
time and moving back to C7 giving
Dimitri a little breather here yeah the
best position to be true has had all
game yeah
but the Knight on D4 it's stable there
you're not getting that Knight off the
board unless you take it with your
Bishop you of course don't want to give
up your dogs for Bishop if you're black
because of the squares around your king
so I think Dimitri is actually holding
on quite nicely yeah A6 trying to open
up a second front on the queen side get
that a file open and create a potential
C6 Square for the bishop but B6 by
Dimitri great bullet move
but Queen B6 Rook Beyond Bishop B5
you're not necessarily winning that pawn
back right away and Lavon says I'm
calling your bluff
and he's doing exactly the right thing
it's so hard to play with down material
in bullet
oh it was Queen F6 he wants the outside
password trade Queens
yeah but Queen takes that green Bishop
C6 oh my gosh this is really bad for
Dimitri all of a sudden yeah levant's
gonna take F3 and then take C3 oh no in
the outside pass pawn and at Bishop C3
here and then A5 and just bring your
Bishop back all is good here is this
going to be enough to win though I don't
think so he just gave away that pawn he
wants to draw in this game
yeah he's making sure that he won't lose
is really the point and Rook A4 I guess
there's Rook to E6 yeah here rookie
seven do not allow those Rooks to double
the seventh no and don't trade if you're
Dimitri
but if you're Dimitri A5 and Rook e to
A7 is always available Rook E5 more
active uh positioning of the rook and
should be a hold because now this I can
really make progress but you have to be
careful D2 at some point Rook T2 and
Rook C2 was actually not a bad chance
for black
just oh watch out for rookie seven
okay
it's anybody's game here I mean you can
see crazy stuff happening oh gosh
oh boy though
huge move I think he's still holding he
is definitely holding because the a pawn
saves the day just take on a five but
now can can milk this Dimitri might win
this this is hard to defend it's so easy
Robert to allow a rook trade by accident
in a bullet game and I'm just looking at
the match talk three minutes and change
remaining here doesn't look like our
last game but Lavon needs to hold
because if Dimitri goes ahead that would
be a must win final game yeah that would
be so hard to do on I mean I
he he should hold this unless he
blunders something in one move
but Dimitri getting to h no then king of
five 245 left
over king of five fearless and it works
and then yeah King takes F4 this is
definitely a draw oh dead dry and it
would be a try even under worse
circumstances
E4 right he says your king cannot leave
the H5 square and wants to go up the
board not backwards and now he's Gonna
Keep The Rook behind the pawn now this
defense by Levon Dimitri could ensure
that the next game is the last one if he
wanted to he can milk another 40 seconds
off the clock
but he's probably not going to do that
or is he he is
he's gonna try to flag LeBron
oh he pushed his King away he's making a
little bit of progress but he has this
check oh he push this thing away again
but this somehow was still a draw I know
this is confusing to some of our viewers
what oh
boy Lavon oh
nightmare scenario for Lavon
oh my goodness he lost on time of all
things well now we have a French defense
oh Dimitri waiting until the end to
uncork a French and Lavon has to win
this game with a win Dimitri wins the
match
yeah even with a drug Dimitri even with
a drug we are going to see either a win
for Lavon or the match is over and if
there's a win for the one we go to arm
again but look at the pawn go off the
board we've seen all the top players
down to Palm Nashi five out of car one
and they play in this style maximum as
well Rook H4 a rook lift not to the
third but the fourth Rank and Daniel the
G7 F7 pawns long-term issues for black
but white has this problem on C2 this is
a great choice by Dimitri a great choice
because in a way that's a high intensity
position for white a high energy
position you need to invest time to
figure out how to make progress on the
king side here Dimitri can rattle off
all these moves super quickly and he's
up a bunch of time already big lead on
the clock move lavon's got a move he's
20 seconds down
okay he
might want to play G4 he does but then
black and he push the Jeep on it himself
open up to the same side Fury and
Dimitri no I think here
if you do play G6 or something the H6
Pawn is a weakness so it's a
double-edged move
in h takes G6 Rook F6 is force now rook
h8 and H5 looks very dangerous right he
plays H5 immediately
oh HG
check
oh he's gotta play Knight f8 oh he
missed it oh my gosh and Rook takes F3
oh we can take with the rook and then
played Rook G3 but this is good too I
think he's winning this
my gosh and we're gonna go to overtime
well not so fast crazier things have
happened E5 was captured the bishop
slides back the other Bishop on D6 not
gonna go back to G3
he's totally winning The Rook F7 another
Pawn Falls but the G file counter play
could get dangerous but that was an
essential Pawn the F7 Pawn right Pawn
train chains excuse me are only as
strong as their base Pawn will be
vulnerable
oh Queen G4 is amazing he missed it yeah
oh my gosh
with background Checkmate oh I don't
like this though Lavon giving up a big
bishop and Robert these light scores on
the king side could could cause him to
pay
okay just run away go Rook back
yeah work F6 safe Square okay he's up on
time that's the best thing Lavon has
done he's keeping hitting the clock all
he has to do is just assemble his pieces
on the king said Queen E5 Queen E5
oh 25 looks super good you guys in the
game oh Dimitri running for his life to
A6
so how do you get a second Rook to the
seventh rank that's the one's hands must
be shaking here oh Rook F7 yikes oh but
he's giving up some pawns this is not
over Rook takes C4 looks like it's
Checkmate but it probably isn't so he
goes queen of three yeah hunting for
more pawns oh what a decision by Lavon
Bishop D7 still dying
Queen E7 Queen E6 taking everything
Knight E5 Dimitri's still still trying
to survive Bishop B7
he gave up a big Pawn a queen before
check uh would be mate if oh Queen D7
that's it unless he can stalemate
himself
nah come on
this is crazy we're gonna get four more
games
of OnePlus One to decide this match
it's just Queen before believable
just don't give up checks right the king
of G2 is actually quite protected from
all the checks but that would be the
worst thing ever you give a perpetual
and this is going to Armageddon the
second Queen appears on the board
resignation and a tied match and Lavon
is probably just kicking himself for
losing on time and the players they do
get a break I know I know they're right
in the thick of the bullet here but the
players they get a mini break here it is
going to be four games of bullet and the
match is tied 12 and a half twelve and
have the players they will get a break I
mean that's important for Dimitri I
think Morrison for Lavon Donya yeah I
mean Dimitri needs to breathe he had a
good opening Choice there but Lavon
aronian I can't believe the clutch
Factor there and that was just such a
smooth game he just totally outplayed
him
he did indeed and wow 12 and a half 12
and a half it was on draken in the three
plus one dominating then erodian strikes
back and that means we are getting arm
not Armageddon just yet excuse me I keep
saying Armageddon because that's what
the tie break means to me and all is
Armageddon but we're gonna get a Best of
four games first to two and a half
points is the winner it's the bullet
type Patrol the colors alternate just
like usual and then if it's tied we get
Armageddon but first there is tie breaks
and the break and everybody in the chat
I want you to make your predictions on
who is going to win this tie break will
it be the 8C levonne aronian or the 9C
Dimitri on drinking we'll find out right
when we turn from the break from the
speed test championship match here by
chess.com
[Music]
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess
chess quack quack how to play duck chest
the duck is a brick pieces cannot move
through the square occupied by the duck
kick on a square to place the dog
[Music]
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the puns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the first time
winning duck chest so exciting
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
one
one ah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
for the tie breaks of this match between
Lavon and rhodian and Dimitri on draken
here at the speeches Championship I'm
Grand Master Robert has alongside meet
Grand Master Daniel naroditsky Dania it
has been a back and forth slug Fest
first it was Lavon with the lead then
Dimitri was able to strike back and then
finally in the bullet it was Lavon
aronian so with the tie break being a
best of four with the time control in
bullet chest do you think Lavon is the
favorite based on his performance in the
bullet time control yeah I think he is I
think Lavon is has all the momentum here
he just won a must-win game Dimitri that
has to hurt I mean you were that close
to winning the SEC match lavon's got to
feel so relieved that he has four more
games as an opportunity to turn this
match around and here they go Levon has
to try to strike early I think Lavon has
to try to win this first game the first
to two and a half wins seat belts
fastened here we go
here we go indeed instead of these uh G3
lines Dimitri playing striking in the
center and plays A3 so again a quiet
approach Lavon develops and Dania it
seems like stable chest but A5 we saw
this earlier than that yeah and I have
been highly critical of Dimitri's
opening choices throughout this match
and I'm gonna criticize him again I
don't know about B6 though by Lavon I
mean that creates a big hole on C6 and
now I think Dimitri solidly better I
thought C5 was kind of a no-brainer
there
yeah that's what uh Levant did in the
earlier game but still his Bishop on D6
positioned aiming towards the white king
side look at white goat trying to play
Bishop A3 that Bishop 96 is removed C7
becomes a Target so I do like Dimitri's
position he is better and I think it's a
kind of two result position yeah and
this is exactly what he wants in a
bullet game he can rattle off a ton of
moves really fast Bishop A3 so common in
this position to get rid of lavon's good
Bishop very bad start for Lavon that
move B6 Robert he's gonna regret that
maybe try to go C6 here change the
nature of the position get yourself a
pawn majority at least some activity
here
he does that you go C5 instead so on
passant would lead to the same position
as C6 and we see A4 is a bit of a Target
B6 is a backwards Pawn but most
importantly there's is a supposed to be
a two-on-one majority for black but
opponent B6 stuck in its tracks yep and
Dimitri building up a nice time
Advantage here maybe bishop B5 forcing
the Bishops off the board and hitting
the pawn on D5 after Rook takes B5 makes
sense he plays it slowly though
yes and Bishop B5 Rook state was still
going to be the move trying to trade on
your own terms D5 a long-term weakness
the white king you know King H2 King G3
king of four and so on if you want to
venture towards the center and he goes
Bishop A6 very smart move trying to
induce Rook C7 so that he could put a
rook on C1 with a pin
and now Knight F6 there's Rook 8 to B3
uh doubling up on that pawn there
because Rook C1 check first then Knight
F6 but Rook a to B3 I think it just wins
a pawn yeah it does and this is big
trouble for leban he's got to try to
generate activity on the king side and
he does with Knight E4 but he blunters
D5 oh it's a big pun to lose Robert
is still terrible Rook B2 looks
reasonable F1 for black there uh-huh
Dimitri might also be fearing Knight C3
although he's got Rook takes A5 you're
absolutely right though Rook F1 picks up
the pawn
10 seconds
he takes only five I think good move oh
Knight F2 I don't know about that A5
comes in and box pieces are stuck on the
king side stuck in mud oh wait six
yeah you gotta bring the second Rook
into the attack Knight E3 and rookie A1
is coming I would go Rook B7 at least
start with that Rook E6
A1
oh oh he's 94 check Knight F1 oh it's a
draw
and King F2 Knight H1 is made yeah
that's incredible Checkmate what the
heck just happened
Dimitri allows a draw
and Lavon aronian showing off the
Tactical Wizardry and Dimitri is going
to be beside himself oh my gosh he's
still a tied match another blown
opportunity for Dimitri and again he
would be oh no finally he deviates with
Knight F6 this is something he should
have done at the start of the bullet
match
he certainly should have but I think
that levona Rooney he's going for the
elephant it's been tried and true
throughout the match and it's a
different position he still likes the
Dynamics he believes in his favor yep
and this is going to lead to a
potentially a queen trade of course
black can't deviate with Queen C7 here
but Dimitri doesn't want to he's fine
with the end game black is slightly
worse though he's crammed that pawn 95
very well placed here that's what I like
about the elephant yes because normally
the pawn E5 is a bad Pawn that Bishop on
C8 we're on a squarely H5 good luck
getting your Bishop out of there so
Knight E4 first the bishop on C1 hasn't
determined where it wants to go maybe he
wants to go to G5 to trade off the dark
Square Bishops that's not you know with
outside the realm of possibility so
Bishop C2 first maybe bishop G5 next and
let's go give me the dark squares yeah
he throws the other Knight onto D5 does
Dimitri on Drake and there it is Bishop
G5 good positional awareness with little
time on the clock for Lavon aronian and
he's gonna Circle it back to D6
there's a big problem for black I think
maybe the evaluation Bar says it's okay
it just feels like a struggle Bishop C6
is what you want for black then Knight
to D4 get rid of that bishop and there's
a3b4 trapping the Knight on A5 because
the only retreating score is C6 C4 is
covered by the White Knight and Levon
prepares
and so the B4 kicks the Knight right
back to C6 but gains some space the one
thing you need to avoid if you're Lavon
is some tricks with Knight C6 takes E5
but with the bishop on D7 and not going
anywhere you don't have to worry about
that for the foreseeable future yeah
Rook ac1 preparing I think the move
Bishop to B3 targeting the Knight on D5
so Dimitri reinforces it I like the way
Dimitri's defending here and keeping
Pace on the clock
no he's doing a great job the problem is
he's passive he has no active plan he
goes Knight of four as long as he'll
fall for 92 checks that's the one thing
to avoid but Rook C7 takes care of it
Lavon taking his time down 10 seconds on
the clock Rook to D2 a little bit too
passive and now Dimitri's over the hump
now Dimitri's over the hump
he certainly doesn't mind if he can't
even move oh no oh no no no this is
getting nasty for White Knight G6 oh
hello
uh Lavon uh Rook F3 still uh keeps quite
happy maybe he moved like Rook D7 to go
Rook C7 if you can get something to the
C file you'll make white pay for
abandoning the queen side and G3 is made
by Knight H3 check a very important move
for black there and it's gonna happen
that is three and King F1 don't go up to
G2 and walk into the PIN
that's the huge Pawn Robert you can't
afford to lose it rookie six oh
tactic
oh my God he won the pawn but it's still
he's not out of the woods look at the
Knight
is there like a oh
now we can take on E6 no we can just
take the Rook
wait what's Happening Here Knight of
cell Rook D2 Knight H2 is a mate
oh my goodness losing it's me oh my
lands and now Lavon has to win with
black if andraken wins he wins the match
with a draw they go to game four
right so that's good news for Levant he
doesn't actually need to win this
specific game and he goes towards a was
gonna be nope King's Indian your style I
don't know though and here's the thing
Robert we always say this and draken
should play for a win he's really good
at this line I've lost a ton of games to
him in this exact line of thinking of
King's Indian whoa what is night before
it's an interesting way to mix things up
and get time off of Dimitri's clock
I love it because instead of just being
worse and passive he's saying let's just
create some threats if Paul attention to
the center of ed5 at any moment like
right now looks pretty good and then
Knight C5 if you take on C5 black is the
two Bishops and the good Bishop on G7 I
think Levon is doing everything he can
in this game although on Dragon remains
solid but look at the clock he's up 20
seconds this is exactly what we saw in
that clutch game live on one he takes on
C5 oh but Dimitri is gonna lose a pot in
the center
here
wow what is Dimitri doing well he just
happened to Lavon he's like Returns the
favorite C6 don't give any piece to D5
square at E5 he's dropping once again on
the pin we might get to a critical game
four here
unreal this is insane and Dimitri down
30 seconds that's what I was about to
say look at the clock mansion by Lavon
here
no it's incredible how does he do this
and he continuing to play good moves
what a good move Retreats are hard to
make especially in bullet but now E5 is
under attack the queen on Diaz defended
and now Dimitri down 30 plus seconds and
a pawn total collapse in the opening
here and he's gonna be down another one
I don't see a reason not to grab it
take them all maybe another one he could
have but he's what that's enough yeah
that's enough for now let's deploy the
bishop back to its me and get out square
Queen C7 completely winning position
completely yes just don't blunder some
kind of attack you know Queen F3 okay
but this is just no but that's desperate
As It Gets and now you could even play a
five because the Knight on G3 was
hanging
but now White's ready to play F5 so
that's why Levon is spending some time
good thing he's up 20 seconds
plenty of time no need to panic no need
to do anything drastic if you're
launched get your pieces out you can't
take C5 even because of oh yeah rookie
three was great
yeah no but you're right couldn't take
out C5 because Bishop D4 check and
Bishop D4 at some point this is
completely losing for on draken and no
hope he scored rookie three Bishop D4
rookie three ends it
goes Queen D6 rookie three is still
available as well the one's got all the
pawns and all the hope
he does indeed and he's up 20 seconds
still after all that
the only thing that can save Dimitri is
a mouse slip here
bring it up I I do feel like Levon is
keeping him in the game but Queen D4
check is huge and takes us
Queen G6 even a threat like how bad of a
threat is that not a threat
here we go oh he plundered up five
wait Queen D5 check I think Queenie five
is still good for black oh my God it's
still winning
that's full rook and it was still
winning that's how winning his position
was to begin with and now he's just
gonna promote his pawns isn't he unless
he blunders his Bishop
oh my gosh this is ridiculous
Abby's in the chat be still my beating
heart
yeah well C3 too many pawns here C2 cc2
C2 oh or D2 and then C2 you're making
the most long-winded possible win like
Levon gave up all
material
[Laughter]
okay do you mean he wins the diamond in
the end with the lone h-man Fabi you
didn't jinx it always good to see you
here he's checking out the rest of the
competition Dimitri andrekin is going to
lose this one the match is going to be
type of look at Dimitri he didn't resign
right away he knows that he's feeling a
little bit on edge and now this is the
final game of the match if it's drawn we
get Armageddon it's not going to be
drawn no draw let's see a decisive game
here
oh
and we're going to see these guys again
of course and Dimitri I I don't like
this I just don't like this it's the
onus is on him to prove that this is
gonna serve him well in this most
decisive game of the match
yeah this is just another situation
isolated Queen Pawn for Dimitri hasn't
had time to look at it he plays Bishop
G4 do you really want to take on F3 the
answer is not really so uh simple trades
from Levant he is just better without
risk no and Maxine wants Armageddon
Dimitri guess what 10 second think as a
direct consequence of the fact that he
has this D5 Pawn he has to babysit for
the entire game he's abandoned it to the
Wolves but Levant keeps doing the same
thing he trades Bishops plays Bishop
he he can't take it but I feel like he's
been playing around it versus capturing
it and just leaves Dimitri
oh as soon as now he takes it
and he says that he wants queen C5
forcing the queen trade and getting a
risk-free end game Robert the ideal
scenario in a game like this
right now
I would take that one gosh that's bad
news for Dimitri because now hello lean
extra Pawn for white yep and now just
move the bishop cleanly away but don't
give up the pawn on B3 how do you do
that though
just I would like go C4 I don't love
that because but then Bishop B5 just
feels awkward right now Queen to C5
offering another queen trade you can't
let that knight jump into C5 this is bad
for Dima
we're gonna get some trades black will
have the activity
it seems not completely unlikely does it
oh my God that's crazy
okay
now aronian down to 24 seconds
uh-huh and the Rooks are double the
default so the only fully open file well
I guess the e-files open but there's a
bishop on E6 is blacks for the taking
and is there a case to be made for
rushing this Apon up the board the
problem is that there's always this
shadow of the Rooks doubling on the
second rank which they're gonna do but
the rules from F3 yeah do you remember
that earlier game when Lavon was up a
pawn or sorry it was much better and
then Dimitri got his Rooks I remember
right like this this house
this gets dangerous 15 seconds for Lev
Oh What A Move though Bishop A4 giving
his Rook to G5 Square
and now the pawn is gonna get to G3 and
there is Rook G5 as you said yes and he
plays it immediately I think I would
have left it on the table just hoping
that Dimitri played G3 without seeing
Rook G5 oh
wait is there Rook D1 and H4 is there
Rook D1 and H4 are you trying to create
it look at the bomb Lavon grabbed his
head he sees it now and it's a little
bit too late he might have to sack on G4
seconds he's two seconds he sacks on G4
no but now Bishop G4 and Rook F2 and
black should be winning
oh
Dimitri is beside himself oh my God he
plundered and now he's up with a million
points
and but Robert Lavon down to two seconds
yeah look at that clock that is
Dimitri's whole Only Hope right now is
that he Flags yes and he's trying to
bring a rook to G1 but he can't attack
G2 a second time and here come the other
pawns LeBron's we're trying a bunch of
Pawns what is he doing he's giving all
the pawns away why did he do that and he
said give it another one away no way
there's rookie five and attacks B5 as
well it's big big move there still
winning it's still basically winning
we're giving another one away how many
pawns can you possibly give up without
giving away the advantage why did he do
that King G2 over here okay five it's
game over it's winning oh my God yes it
is he's gonna make a queen
oh my gosh Dimitri barely getting the
moves off in time move to G2 where is he
going just run away oh it's almost me F6
is almost amazing
the pawn stopped oh but he gives a B5 no
Rook B7 would be seven that's an H7 and
Robert Bishop H5 at the end just go H7
good point but then F5 he's got a flag
hey who's on time oh he lost some time
he's beside himself he's so upset and
that's the match lavono right God drink
of whatever he's been drinking but it's
led him to success in the button he
gives away a little bit of a smile there
oh my God I have not breathed in the
last five minutes this entire overtime
oh man neither player can believe it
look at Dimitri I mean he just gave away
his spot in the next round of the
speeches Championship Robert got a feel
for him this position is actually still
a hold but all he had to do was take
levon's Rook
and double on the second ring that was
already winning he found H4 he did the
hard part but he thought he was mating
him he forgot that he was losing the H
Pawn in the G3 Square was opened up for
the white king unbelievable
that is called nerves
and look at Dimitri I mean he is just so
upset and you feel for him but Donya if
you just make a couple moves in this you
know we could just even bring up a board
for just one second here as we will go
to get an interview with levona Roney in
a second but just there if Bishop takes
H7 in that final position it's it's
actually still a draw somehow some way
because of F5
Dimitri just had to make the move and he
would have made that move and there was
actually an unbelievable defensive idea
in the final position there but Dimitri
on Drake and that's called nerves and we
see that it affect absolutely everybody
doesn't matter what your hundreds digits
of your rating is eight nine seven six
it doesn't matter everybody's
susceptible to that Levon aronian is a
freaking hero in today's he certainly is
and while Heroes need to be heard from
so we are going to take a quick break
and win return we'll bring levonne Ronin
on for a victory interview stay tuned
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kit is educational
the kids it feels just like playing the
chest is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
foreign
and we are here with the winner of his
opening round match this is Grand Master
Lavon aronian Lavon that's just how you
drew it up right winning a bullet
comeback
yes it was all planned of course uh I I
was thinking you know uh I shouldn't
show my
skills before the bullet not to surprise
him this is this is the way it happens
yeah like you know that Messi in the
first uh about 10 15 minutes of the game
he doesn't really show himself he just
looks looks at the formation and only
when he sees the formation he strikes
Lavon you're a former World Blitz
Champion I assume you've played a ton of
Blitz throughout your life and in your
childhood but you don't play as much
online how difficult uh is it for you to
adjust uh to online Blitz do you find it
any different from OTB and how did you
feel about that this match
I think I'm definitely better of TB I
mean being pretty terrible OTB I'm
definitely better or to be done
no because with all the seriousness I
just I don't know I when my I'm down on
time somehow the mouse is already
you know running away from me you know
it feels the cat or something I don't
know but I'm not able to play the moves
that I want to
well in a way Lavon do you feel that it
helped you that in some of the games
that you lost it wasn't necessarily by
position it was on time so that kind of
kicked in your instincts to just move
faster in critical moments
I don't know what the hell be but
definitely in the bullet maybe it was
just I didn't have any more pressure and
I just thought to have fun and those
section I'm I consider I'm drinking to
be a heavy favorite in bullet section I
have actually recorded much I felt if I
managed to do something in in five plus
one or three plus one then I have some
chances you know to get the like a plus
five score and then maybe then uh it can
be an unclear match and uh I came you
know after three plus one segment I was
down three points and I thought okay
zero chances for me because bullet is
normally my weak spot and you know it
was very strange for me I I don't know
what you know perspired I don't know
what happened
Lavon were you surprised that some of
Dimitri's opening choices throughout the
match in particular uh you seem to be
getting advantages very consistently in
the alapin with white and some of
Dimitri's sort of Knight F3 G3 systems
from the white side were pretty
innocuous uh how surprised were the
Dimitri uh you know kept repeating these
lines
I think he was doing great in uh Knight
f33 up to a point when I started playing
this Knight to six business
and then somehow of course it's half
correct I mean it's not a great line but
because it's uh you know it's a format
where you don't have time to prepare and
then if somebody comes with a surprise I
think it worked out very well and then
you know objectively of course
uh Dmitry knows this is a bad opening
and uh I mean you cannot really avoid
playing as a better so he went for it
and uh what about a lot it was strange
that it kind of works so well for me
because of course it's nothing and if he
proved it with many ideas but somehow I
I was getting this safe kind of
positions where maybe did this position
suit my style more
mm-hmm that's some interesting Insight
Lavon we'll let you go very soon it's
been a super long match but first two
feature chat questions the first from
Jules Gambit who asks how does Lavon
stay so cool when he's down points I
would be so tilted what is uh your
secret to your mindset
I think not really caring yeah just you
know
the thing is for me this online
tournament is like playing a computer
game I don't care if I lose or win this
is not like something over the board
where I would get really really upset
it's you know I understand
this is a different era and actually
online chess save chess the game of
chess but as somebody who's from this
different era
somehow uh I I don't get upset when I
wasn't normal anyways
okay fair enough Lavon and I mean the
last question also from the future chat
is from PUD and snack is what was in
that thermos and why did it kick in for
bullet what were you drinking
ginger ale actually mixed with water
foreign
like my three candidate moves
yeah I like it you know the water kind
of water but something with sweet stuff
in it so that's ideal
okay well the last question before I let
you go who's winning the World Cup
um
I'm rooting for Argentina I hope they'll
win
okay well all right you have so many
fans out there you made many more in
that exciting match I know you're
probably sick of moving the mouse at
lightning speed but congratulations on a
match win over Dimitri on Drake and we
look forward to seeing you in the
quarterfinals here in the SEC
thank you so much guys
and that was our good friend Lavon
aronian winning at long last 15 to 14 in
his own words a huge surprise that he
outlasted demetrendrick in the bullet
section of all time goes down here it
was a really mesmerizing performance
let's not forget it was a three-point
lead for Dimitri and Drake and going
into arguably his best segment I mean
that is as slam dunk as it gets and from
game one Lavon showed that he wasn't
going to go gentle into that good night
he put on turbo boost in bullet he
weathered the storm again and again and
he won a must-win game in that French to
take it into overtime and he had the
calmer nerves when push came to shove
what a match
oh what a match indeed is we look at a
bracket and how this affects things the
vulneronia moves through to the
quarterfinals and in all likelihood not
a guarantee but no likelihood he will
face Hikaru Nakamura the number one
overall seed the reigning speech has
championed and normally Hikaru says if
he's down by just two points or
something like that heading to the
bullet he still feels like he's
confident but the levana Rooney we just
saw a bullet that was really impressive
stuff and I think that he has a real
chance against ikaro I mean a car is
still the heavy favorite Don yes but he
showed some excellent bullet skills no
question and if Lavon you know could can
step up his game a little bit in the
five minute portion the way that he
played in bullet I mean he is just a
force to be reckoned with he had good
preparation he showed that he can
compete in time pressure all of the
stuff that I was questioning before in
the match Lavon proves that he can fight
with the best of them in and I was it
was just an honor to watch this match
and such a pleasure I love the SEC
it was fantastic indeed just because
this speed Chess Championship Match is
over doesn't mean that the chest stops
there will be four more matches in the
first round before we get all of our
quarterfinalists but we also have the
women's Candace tournament going on
right now uh there have been two draws
in each of the matches but Alexandra
goriochina Katarina lock no Alexander
kostenyuk and zhangitan are playing and
the winner of this pool will face the
winner of pool Aid that was lead to Jay
and so it could be an all Chinese match
up there to see who will face eventually
against Jew and June but the action
continues the coverage will be on
chess.com so drop the command women's
candidates in the chat for all the
details but Dania any final thoughts
about this match and what you expect to
come in the SEC opening round
I mean I just have no words about what
we just saw that was epic I think
everyone is only now starting to breathe
and that is just the SEC for you and you
can see the price fund is generous but
these players are gonna put all of their
effort on the line even if the price
fund was Zero because it's the SEC
because it has this Prestige and this
fun that's attached to it and that all
of the players look forward to all of
the matches another incredible match the
next one of course the Marquee matchup
between Magnus Carlson and gukesh the
round of 16 continues on Tuesday at 8
A.M Pacific I'll be bringing you that
with Danny wrench I can't wait
I also cannot wait it's always exciting
every single match in the SEC promises
the fans something new and something fun
but on behalf of myself and Grandmaster
Daniel nerdinski here it's been an
absolute pleasure thank you for joining
us and congratulations once more to
levonne aronian for winning this great
match an epic match in tyrex against
Dimitri on Drake and we should tip our
proverbial cap two on draken he has been
a Mainstay in all of the biggest and
best events on chess.com we'll see him
again soon and we'll see you all soon
for the next match between Magus Carlson
and kukashir must be a chess chips see
everybody
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]